hey everyone welcome to this data
analyst course by simplylearn in this
course you will learn how to become data
analyst this course will help you
acquainted with duties and career
processes that a data analyst knows
along with other data analytics concept
let us check out today's agenda data
analyst career here we will understand
what are the career opportunities of a
data analyst along with duties and
responsibility of a data analyst then we
will list out top 10 data analyst skill
and top 10 data analyst tools after that
we will distinguish between data
scientist and data analyst moving on we
will discuss data analyst with python
followed by few concepts of
microsoft excel that will help you as a
data scientist next excel dashboard
followed by we will cover tools like
pandas and matpolip don't forget we will
cover about data analytics using r after
which we will know what is sql and
finally
data analytics interview questions in a
world where there is data generation
every millisecond the role of a data
analyst holds paramount importance this
video will help you understand what a
data analyst does and the various skills
required to back this position
before understanding the job role of a
data analyst let's understand the
meaning of the term data analytics
so what does the term analyze mean
it merely means to scrutinize something
to derive meaningful conclusions from it
well data analytics also works similarly
it is the process by which useful
insights are extracted from raw data by
studying and examining it carefully
these insights can be related to
business information market trends
product innovations and profit loss
report to name a few
here's an interesting comparison i'm
sure all of you have played with jigsaw
puzzles at some point in time for that
first you would have to gather all the
pieces together and then fit them
accordingly to bring out a beautiful
picture isn't it we can simply relate
the process of data analytics to how you
make a jigsaw puzzle
as you can see here data refers to the
raw data which can be structured
semi-structured or unstructured in
nature the process of data analytics
incorporates collecting data from
various sources cleaning it and then
finally transforming it into something
meaningful which can be interpreted by
humans
this information can be visually
presented in the form of graphs and
charts which provide precise results of
the analysis
various technologies tools and
frameworks are used in the analysis
process organizations take the help of
data analytics to convert the available
raw data into meaningful insights hence
there is a high requirement for
professionals who can play with data and
help organizations with crucial decision
making
there are many job roles in the field of
data analytics if you have watched our
previous video on data analytics career
you would have seen a few of these roles
out of all the job roles an important
role is that of a data analyst an
interesting thing about this job role is
that it can be taken up by freshers as
well it can embark on your career in the
field of data analytics it is a
lucrative career as the field of data
analytics is only going to continue to
blossom in the years to come
so let's see who exactly a data analyst
is
a data analyst is a person who collects
processes and performs analysis on large
data sets here the statistical analysis
is done on various data sets every
business generates and collects data be
it marketing research sales figures
customer feedback logistics or
transportation costs a data analyst will
take all of this data and figure out
various measures such as how to price
new materials how to reduce
transportation costs how to provide
better customer experience or how to
deal with issues that cost the company
money
data analysts also deal with data
handling data modeling and data
reporting
a data analyst has a number of duties to
perform let's have a look at their
responsibilities now
first and foremost a data analyst is
required to recognize and understand the
organization's goal this helps in
streamlining and planning the analysis
process accordingly
data analysts assess the available
resources understand the business
problem and gather the right data
this step is done by collaborating with
different team members such as
programmers business analysts and data
scientists
data analysts need to use queries to
gather information from a database they
write complex sql queries and scripts to
gather and extract information from
several databases and data warehouses
they are responsible for data mining as
well here data is mined from various
sources and then organized in order to
obtain a new information from it
this is a vital role of a data analyst
as they have to extract data from
various sources in order to work on it
with this data they can build models
that can reduce the complexity and
increase the efficiency of the whole
system
another crucial step in data analysis is
data cleaning and data wrangling usually
the data you can collect is often messy
and has a lot of missing values so it's
important to clean this data to make it
ready for analysis
data analysts use a number of
statistical and analytical tools
including programming languages for
performing analysis and logical
examination of data
using different libraries and packages
data analysts discover trends and
patterns from complex data sets
this will help them find more unseen
insights from the data to make business
predictions
another important role of a data analyst
is to prepare summary reports for the
leadership team so that they can make
timely decisions for this data analysts
use multiple data visualization tools
some of these tools are discussed as
part of skills required which we will
see later
finally data and lists interact with the
development team business and management
team as well as with data scientists to
ensure proper implementation of business
requirements and to figure out
opportunities for better process
improvement
now let us look at the various skills
required to become a data analyst
so the first skill is more of a
prerequisite you should hold a degree in
any relevant field be it engineering
computer science information technology
electrical or mechanical engineering
you can also be a graduate in statistics
or economics also you should have domain
knowledge in the field you are currently
working in or the role you're applying
for
the next important skill is that you
should have good hands-on experience
with programming languages such as r
python and javascript this would help
you write programs to solve complex
problems
then you should have a good experience
working with databases and data analysis
tools such as writing sql queries and
procedures knowledge of microsoft excel
ibm spss and matlab to analyze trends
forecast data and plan to drive accurate
insights
you must have a strong understanding of
statistics and machine learning
algorithms these include concepts such
as hypothesis testing probability
distributions regression analysis and
various classification and clustering
techniques
and finally a data analyst should be
able to create different reports with
the help of charts and graphs using
several data visualization tools such as
tableau and power bi they must have good
presentation skills as well this will
help them convey their ideas to clients
and stakeholders better
now that we have looked at the various
skills required to become a data analyst
let's now see the average annual salary
that a data analyst earns
here we can have a look at the salary
ranges of both in u.s and in india
so a data analyst in the united states
can earn a minimum salary of 43 000
to a maximum of 85 000 per year
in india you can earn anywhere between 1
lakh 98 000 rupees to 9 lakh 24 000
rupees per annum
the data analyst role is in very high
demand with companies looking for
professionals who can handle their data
effectively and efficiently so let's
look at the different companies hiring
for the data analyst role
as you see here we have the american
e-commerce giant amazon
the american multinational technology
company microsoft capital one which is
one of the largest banking companies in
the us then we have the popular retail
company walmart then we have paypal
next we have the internet and search
engine giant google
social media firms facebook and twitter
as well as apple and bloomberg
with that let me now tell you how simply
learn can help you learn data analytics
and guide you to become a data analyst
so in a new tab i'll search for
simplylearn.com
then here on the search bar i look for
data analyst
let me now click on the first link which
is data and list i'll open this in
another tab
as you can see on your screens this is
the data and list masters program and it
is in collaboration with ibm
on the right hand side you can see the
different courses that will be covered
as a part of the program you will learn
introduction to data analytics business
analytics with excel then you have
tableau followed by power bi later on in
the course you will learn programming
basics and data analytics with python
then r programming and finally you will
get to work on a capstone project
this is a kind of certificate you would
receive after completing the course it
will have your name along with ibm and
simply learn logo
these are some of the tools that will be
covered in this program you will learn
excel the numpy panda scipy ibm watson
power bi tableau python and r
the course advisor for this program is
ronald van loon below you can see the
entire course curriculum and the
different courses that you will learn in
this program
also there are a few electives that you
can choose in this course
there's data science in real life
programming refresher industry master
class data analytics and there is sql
training as well
let's quickly understand how important a
career in data analytics is and what the
future holds for professionals in this
domain
let's take a look at the growth of data
so back in the early 2000s there was
relatively less data generated but with
a rapid rise in technologies and with
the increase in the number of various
social media platforms and multinational
companies across the globe the
generation of data has increased by
leaps and bounds
did you know that according to the idc
the total volume of data is expected to
reach 175 zettabytes in 2025
now that's a lot of data let's take a
look at how organizations leverage all
of this data
as you know there are zillions of
companies across the world these
companies generate loads of data on a
daily basis when i say data here it
simply refers to business information
customer data customer feedback product
innovations sales reports and profit
loss reports to name a few
companies utilize all of this data in a
wise way they use all of this
information to make crucial decisions
that can either hamper or boost their
businesses
you might have heard of the term data is
the new oil well it definitely is but
only if organizations analyze all the
available data very well then this oil
is definitely valuable
and for that we have data analytics
organizations take the help of data
analytics to convert the available raw
data into meaningful insights
so what is data analytics technically
you can see it is a process wherein data
is collected from various sources then
cleaned which involves removing
irrelevant information and then finally
transformed into some meaningful
information that can be interpreted by
humans
various technologies tools and
frameworks are used in the analysis
process
as you might have heard of the term data
never sleeps well it surely doesn't
every millisecond some of the other data
is generated and this is a constant
process this process is only going to
increase in the near future with the
advent of newer technologies the data
analytics domain holds paramount
importance in every sector
companies want to leverage on all the
generated big data and boost their
businesses
they need professionals who can play
with data and convert them into crucial
insights organizations are constantly on
the lookout for such candidates and this
opportunity will only increase as data
is only going to grow every second
so if you want to start your career in
this field or if you want to switch your
job role into a role in the data
analytics domain then we have a set of
job profiles that you can look at
we will look into six job roles in the
data analytics field and learn what each
job role is all about the
responsibilities of a professional
working in that particular role the
skills required to get that particular
job the average annual salary of a
professional working in that role and
finally the company is hiring for that
role so let's start off
first we have the job role of a data
analyst
a data analyst is a person who collects
processes and performs statistical
analysis of large data sets
every business generates and collects
data be it marketing research sales
figures logistics or transportation
costs a data analyst will take this data
and figure out a variety of measures
such as how to price new materials how
to reduce transportation costs or how to
deal with issues that cost the company
money they deal with data handling data
modeling and reporting
now talking about their responsibilities
data and lists recognize and understand
the organization's goal they collaborate
with different team members such as
programmers business analysts engineers
and data scientists to identify
opportunities for solving business
problems
data analysts write complex sql queries
scripts and store procedures to gather
and extract information from multiple
databases
they filter and clean data using
different modern tools and techniques
and make it ready for analysis they also
perform data mining from primary and
secondary data sources
data analysts identify analyze and
interpret trends in complex data sets
this is done using statistical tools
such as r and sas
another key responsibility of a data
analyst is to create summary reports and
build various data visualizations for
decision making and presenting it to the
stakeholders
next let us discuss the important skills
that you need to know to become a data
analyst
firstly you should have a bachelor's
degree in computer science or
information technology a master's degree
in computer applications or statistics
is also preferable
you must have a good understanding of
programming languages like r python
javascript and also understand sql
in addition to that it is beneficial if
you have hands-on experience with
statistical and data analytics tools
such as sas minor microsoft excel and
ssas
basic understanding of machine learning
and its algorithms would be an advantage
acquaint yourself with descriptive
predictive prescriptive and inferential
statistics
most importantly you need to have a good
working knowledge of various data
visualization software along with
presentation skills this will help you
pitch in your ideas and view points to
the clients and stakeholders better
now talking about their salaries a data
analyst earns nearly 5 lakhs 23 000
rupees per annum in india while in the
united states they earn around 62
453 dollars per annum
let's now look at a few of the companies
hiring data analysts so as you can see
we have the american e-commerce joint
amazon then we have microsoft the
american online payment company paypal
then we have walmart bloomberg and
capital one so that was all about data
analyst
the next job role is of a business
analyst
business analysts help guide businesses
in improving products services and
software through data-driven solutions
they are responsible for bridging the
gap between it and business using data
analytics to evaluate processes
determine requirements and deliver
data-driven recommendations and reports
to executives and stakeholders
business analysts are responsible for
creating new models that support
business decisions and come up with
initiatives and strategies to optimize
costs
now let us look at the various
responsibilities of a business analyst
business analysts have a good
understanding of the requirements for
business their vital role is to work in
accordance with relevant project
stakeholders to understand their
requirements and translate them into
details which the developers can
understand
they frequently interact with developers
and come up with a plan to design the
layout of a software
application they also run meetings with
stakeholders and other authorities they
engage with business leaders and users
to understand how data driven changes to
products services software and hardware
can improve efficiencies and add value
they ensure that the project is running
smoothly as per the requirements and the
design planned through user acceptance
and validation testing
they make sure all the features are
being incorporated into the application
findings where each requirement of the
client is mentioned in detail
now let us look at the skills required
for a ba
a bachelor's degree in the field of
science engineering or statistics or any
related domain will suffice
knowledge of programming languages such
as python and java is beneficial
you should be really good at writing
complex sql queries and you should also
have knowledge of various business
process models
along with knowledge of programming
languages ideas about statistical
analysis and predictive modelling is
necessary
decision making strong analytical and
problem solving skills are necessary to
solve software and business issues you
also need to have excellent presentation
and communication skills both oral and
written
moving on to their salary a business
analyst is expected to earn around seven
lakh rupees per annum in india in the us
they earn nearly sixty eight thousand
three forty six dollars per annum
iqea dell philips honeywell the famous
american messaging platform whatsapp the
uk-based company ernest and young are
few of the companies hiring for business
analysts
up next we have the job role of a
database administrator
a database administrator is a
specialized computer systems
administrator who maintains a successful
database environment by directing or
performing all related activities to
keep the organization's data secure
they are responsible for storing
organizing and retrieving data from
several databases and data warehouses
their top responsibility is to maintain
data integrity this means that database
administrator will ensure that the data
is secure from unauthorized access
moving on to their responsibilities
a database administrator develops
designs and maintains a database to
ensure that the data in it is properly
stored organized and managed well they
maintain data integrity by avoiding
unauthorized access and they keep
databases up to date
they run tests and modify the existing
databases to ensure that they operate
reliably they also inform end users of
changes in databases and train them to
utilize systems
they need to cooperate with programmers
data analysts and the it staffs to
ensure smooth running and maintenance of
databases
database administrators are responsible
for taking system backups in case of
power outages and other disasters so
they should have an efficient disaster
recovery plan
now let's have a look at their skills
to become a database administrator you
should have a bachelor's degree in
computer science or information
technology
knowledge of programming languages such
as python java and scala is important
you need to carry at least three to five
years of experience in data management
you need to have an understanding of
different databases such as oracle db
mongodb mysql server and posgra sql also
they should have an idea about database
design and writing sql queries
finally you need to have a good
understanding of operating systems such
as windows mac os and linux along with
storage technologies
talking about their salary a database
administrator in india can earn up to 4
lakh 97 000 rupees per annum in the us
they earn around 78 000 per annum
let's have a look at the companies
hiring for database administrators
so as you see here we have bookmyshow
oracle the american mnc intel amazon
robert half and the new york times to
name a few
fourth in the list of job roles we have
data engineer a data engineer someone
who's involved in preparing data for
analytical and operational uses a data
engineer transforms data into useful
formats for analysis
they build and test scalable big data
ecosystems for businesses
a data engineer is an intermediary
between a data analyst and a data
scientist
now let's jump into their
responsibilities
data engineers develop test and maintain
architectures they are responsible for
managing optimizing and monitoring data
retrieval storage and distribution
throughout the organization
they discover opportunities for data
acquisition find trends in data sets and
develop algorithms to help make raw data
more useful to the enterprise
data engineers build large data
warehouses using etl for storing and
retrieving data
they also recommend ways to improve data
quality and efficiency along with
building algorithms to help give easier
access to raw data
data engineers often work with big data
and submit their reports to data
scientists for analysis purpose they
need to recommend and sometimes
implement ways to improve data
reliability efficiency and quality
moving on to the skills of a data
engineer
a data engineer should hold a bachelor's
degree in computer science or
information technology
they should have good hands-on
experience with python r and java
also data engineers should be
well-versed with big data technologies
such as hadoop apache spark scala
cassandra and mongodb
data warehousing and detail experience
are essential to this position along
with in-depth knowledge of sql and other
database solutions
basic knowledge of statistical analysis
will be an advantage along with idea
about operating systems
here is what a data engineer can earn so
in india a data engineer can earn up to
8 lakhs 85 000 rupees per annum while
they can earn around and three thousand
dollars a year in the usa
we have cab gemini shutterstock the
american provider of stock photography
spotify accenture genpak and facebook
hiring data engineers
the next exciting job role is of a data
scientist
a data scientist is a professional who
uses statistical methods data analysis
techniques machine learning and related
concepts in order to understand and
analyze data to draw business
conclusions
they make sense to messy and
unstructured data and bring value out of
it
they employ techniques and theories
drawn from many fields within the
context of mathematics statistics
computer science and information science
a data scientist understands the
challenges in business and comes up with
the best solutions using modern tools
and techniques to analyze visualize and
build prediction models to make business
decisions
let us now look at their
responsibilities in the industries
data scientists clean process and
manipulate data using several data
analytics tools they perform ad hoc data
mining collect large sets of structured
and unstructured data from disparate
sources
they design and evaluate advanced
statistical models to work on big data
they also create automated anomaly
detection systems and keep constant
track of their performance
data scientists interpret the analysis
of big data to discover solutions and
opportunities
a data scientist takes input from data
analysts and engineers to formulate the
results
they use visualization packages and
tools to create reports and dashboards
for relevant stakeholders they also
adopt new business models and approaches
apart from this they regularly build
predictive models and machine learning
algorithms
now moving on to the skills of a data
scientist
a bachelor's degree in computer science
or information technology will be fine
but a master's degree in the field of
data science will hold a major advantage
you also need to have a good experience
in the analytics domain
you should be proficient in programming
languages such as python java and c plus
plus
knowledge of perl will also be an
advantage
familiarity with apache hive pig and
apache spark is necessary along with the
knowledge of hadoop
in addition to knowing programming
languages you also need to know sql
machine learning and deep learning
data visualization and bi skills are
necessary for creating reports and
dashboards you should also be able to
communicate and present information and
ideas properly
now talking about their salary a data
scientist in india can expect an annual
salary of 10 lakhs 47 000 rupees per
year meanwhile in the us they can earn
up to 113 000 dollars per annum that's a
lot of money
from the many companies hiring for data
scientists here we have a few companies
named they are yet again amazon citibank
apple google the japanese electronic
commerce and online retailing company
rakuten and facebook
and finally we have machine learning
engineer
machine learning engineers are
professionals who develop intelligent
machines that can learn from vast
amounts of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
they use different algorithms and
statistical modeling to make sense of
data they design and develop machine
learning and deep learning algorithms
their main goal is to create
self-running software
let's have a look at the
responsibilities of a machine learning
engineer
machine learning engineers research
design and develop machine learning
systems they use exceptional
mathematical skills in order to perform
faster computations and work with
algorithms to create sophisticated
models
they perform a b testing and use data
modeling to fine-tune the results
they use data modeling and evaluation
strategy to find hidden patterns and
predict unseen instances
machine learning engineers work closely
with data engineers to build data
pipelines and interact with stakeholders
to get a clarity on the requirements
most importantly they analyze complex
data sets to verify data quality perform
model tests and experiments choose to
implement the right machine learning
algorithm and select the right training
data sets
moving on to their skills
a machine learning engineer should have
a degree in computer science and
information technology
they should have an advanced degree in
computer science or maths
in addition to this they should also
have experience in the same domain
they should be proficient in programming
languages such as python rc plus plus
and java
knowledge of statistics probability and
linear algebra is necessary as all the
machine learning algorithms have been
derived from mathematics also having an
idea of signal processing would be
beneficial
machine learning engineers need to have
a good understanding of data
manipulation and machine learning
libraries such as numpy panda scikit
learn etc
they should have good oral and written
communication skills
let us now have a look at their salary
structure
a machine learning engineer earns 8 lakh
rupees per annum in india
while in the us they can earn around 114
000
a year now that's a whopping amount
isn't it
let's have a look at the companies
hiring machine learning engineers
so as you see we have amazon microsoft
oracle salesforce rapido and accenture
to name a few
that was all about the job role of a
machine learning engineer
now that we have seen the different job
roles in the field of data analytics
let's also go ahead and see how an ideal
resume of a data analyst should look
like
seen on your screens is a sample resume
of a data analyst you can grab some
ideas from this and incorporate them in
your resume
nowadays it's quite common to have a
professional photograph of yours on the
resume you can go ahead and have that
then your name in bold followed by your
contact details like email id and phone
number
then moving on you would have to write a
summary briefly explain your current job
role and what you're looking for in the
future
having a linkedin profile link works
well these days employers can just go
ahead and look at your profile and gauge
you well
make sure to have an active linkedin
profile
in addition to linkedin profile it's
also good to have a github profile link
which can show your coding or other
technical skills
if it's impressive enough then a lot of
times the rest of your resume is just
secondary
as i mentioned this is a resume of a
data analyst so as you can see in the
summary here we have just spoken about
the basic responsibilities of a data
analyst
moving on to the experience part you
have to write the job title and below
that you can mention the company and the
tenure accordingly here you would have
to give a brief description of
achievements in the organization any
relevant accomplishments related to the
job you're applying for the tools and
the various technologies you have worked
with
so in the sample you can see we have
spoken about data visualization using r
in tableau next we have spoken about how
the candidate has worked with other
teams for a better business outcome
most of the data and lists use sql and
excel to handle data for reporting and
database maintenance and we have
mentioned that here as well
do make sure that you always specify the
tools you use
then you can also mention if you have
worked on improving data delivery for
example here we have spoken about
developing and optimizing sql queries
data aggregations and etl to improve
data delivery
finally you can speak a bit about your
reporting skills and if needed elaborate
on it
usually professionals would have worked
in a similar domain before becoming a
data analyst
here we have taken the role of a
statistical assistant as the first job
since it's easier for a candidate with
this job role to shift into the data
analytics field nevertheless y'all can
still mention your prior experience here
be it in any domain
under the responsibilities for this job
role we have given basics such as coding
data prior to computer entry compiling
statistics from various reports
computing and analyzing data and finally
some visualization and reporting
moving to the education
here you can mention the name of your
degree and the university name if you
have a post graduation well and good you
can list both the degrees here also if
you have any certifications you can
mention them here under the education
category
now moving to the skills depending on
your skills and your choice you can
either shift this part to the beginning
of the resume or have it here
as you see on your screens this is just
a different way of displaying your skill
sets you can have all the five stars
colored if you are excellent in that
particular tool or language
as you see it's crystal clear as to what
the candidate's strong areas are
you can have various categories like
shown
for example under software development
you can list the languages that you know
and how proficient you are in those
particular languages
it's clear that the candidate knows
python better than javascript here so
the employer gets a clear idea about the
skills you possess and the depth of it
similarly you can mention the databases
as well
the few mentioned here are more or less
a requirement to become a data analyst
at least sql is a must
not to forget data visualization is also
very important when it comes to the job
role of a data analyst mention the tools
you know here and similarly give
yourself a rating out of five
five stars shaded being the highest
here we have mentioned tableau and excel
which are more than sufficient to become
a data analyst
moving to the non-technical skills you
can mention the languages you know here
here we have taken english and german in
addition to the languages you can also
feel free to mention the extracurricular
activities that you are good at
so this is how an ideal resume of a data
analyst should look like you can alter
it according to your achievements skills
and experience
welcome to this session on top 10 skills
to become a data analyst before diving
into our topic let's quickly speak about
the job role of a data analyst
in this 21st century data analytics is
used in every sector be it in
organizations where meaningful insights
are drawn pertaining to the growth of
the company or be it and fighting the
ongoing pandemic covid19 data finds its
importance everywhere speaking of the
role of a data analyst he or she is a
skilled professional who is responsible
for collecting and processing data they
perform analysis on large data sets they
also deal with data handling data
modeling and reporting a data analyst
understands the trends and insights that
are revealed in massive data sets so if
you want to become a data analyst then
there are a few skills that you need to
possess let's have a look at the top 10
skills that can help you back the
position of a data analyst here we will
look into both technical and
non-technical skills at number 10 we
have mathematics
data and lists work with a lot of
structured and unstructured data in
order to analyze and understand all the
acquired data a strong foundation in
mathematics is essential
most of the data analysis will use
linear algebra statistics probability
and calculus for performing analysis and
for the logical examination of data
hypothesis testing such as the null
hypothesis and alternate hypothesis
analysis is another crucial task that
data analysts perform to ensure that the
data they have collected is relevant for
analysis
they need to perform z test t-test and
chi-square test to make sure the sample
data is good for analysis also data
analysts build machine learning models
for solving business problems using
classification regression and clustering
algorithms so to understand the working
of these algorithms knowledge of
mathematics is compulsory
moving to number nine we have the big
data tools and frameworks
data and lists deal with complex and
inaccurate data that is really huge in
volume
now to handle this data they need to
possess big data technology skills such
as hadoop and the tools that are part of
its ecosystem
hadoop provides the hadoop distribution
file system to store data in several
chunks scoop is popularly used as a data
ingestion tool for extracting data from
htfs onto relational databases
data analysts use hedge base which is a
column-oriented database for processing
semi-structured data
there are other frameworks such as
apache big and high for processing and
analyzing data using big latin scripts
and hive query language it would be an
advantage for a data analyst to have an
idea about these tools and frameworks
at number eight we have data cleaning
and data wrangling
in this modern era of internet and
social media data is being generated
every second and often this data is
noisy and messy containing missing
values
data is also often unstructured and this
could be a problem for data analysts to
perform analysis on such data
so they need to pre-process the data and
clean it using various tools and
techniques to make it fit for analysis
data analysts must transform the data
into the right format for carrying out
analytics
they should also have data manipulation
and data mining skills to find out
unseen trends and patterns from the data
some of the tools they should have
knowledge of are open refine and
tri-factor wrangler they need to have
hands-on experience in certain numerical
computation and data manipulation
libraries such as numpy pandas dplyr
sci-fi and idr
at number seven we have bi tools for
data visualization
in order to understand the complexities
of business and derive the desired
solution data analysts should have an
idea about business intelligence tools
business intelligence is a process to
analyze and visualize vast volumes of
data it helps in creating reports and
dashboards to better understand the
trends in data
bi tools help data analysts to sort and
filter the data perform data
manipulation by joining multiple data
sets and build different charts and
graphs to present the data in a
pictorial format
it also helps them to focus the data to
make future predictions the reports and
dashboards created using bi tools can
help data analysts convey their ideas to
clients and stakeholders
some of the popular bi tools used in
analytics are power bi tableau click
view and sas bi all these tools feature
in the gartner magic quadrant for 2020
for business intelligence and analytics
at number six we have microsoft excel
and etl tools
every data analyst should possess a good
working knowledge of microsoft excel
excel is the most preferred tool for
analytics that is commonly used by
managers across the globe microsoft
excel has really good features to
manipulate and analyze structured data
that is in the form of rows and columns
it provides a lot of inbuilt numerical
and text functions you also have the
advantage of creating pivot tables and
pivot charts along with creating
different charts and graphs for building
a report you can explore advanced
features such as excel macros
good knowledge of data warehousing and
etl tools is important
data and lists often gather data from
several data sources then they
manipulate and transform data using
different techniques and finally they
load the data to a data warehouse for
easy access some of the popular etl and
data warehousing tools are informatica
and talent
at number five we have programming
languages
data analyst should have excellent
hands-on programming knowledge for
solving complex business problems
they need to know programming languages
such as python r sas and java
python and r are the most widely used
languages in the field of data analytics
and machine learning
both python and r are open source
programming languages they are easy to
learn and implement python has built-in
mathematical functions regular
expressions and libraries like pandas
numpy matplotlib and c bond for data
analysis
r supports packages such as plier dplyr
tidr tidy words gg plot and lattice for
manipulating and visualizing the data
sas is another preferred programming
software for statistical analysis and
model building while java is mainly
suitable for writing user-defined
methods and object-oriented programming
at number four we have the most
important skill for any data analyst
which is database and sql
the database is a storage container
where companies store huge volumes of
data organizations deal with vast
volumes of structured and
semi-structured data on a daily basis
this data is stored in relational and
non-relational databases
in order to retrieve process and
manipulate the data from such databases
data and list should use rdbms and nosql
databases such as microsoft sql server
mysql ibm db2 mongodb and postgresql
they should know how to write sql
queries using commands such as select
insert update delete drop and truncate
data analysts must have advanced
querying skills like implementing where
and having clauses to filter the data
using built-in sql functions joining
tables and writing stored procedures to
automate complex tasks
those were all the technical skills that
are required to be possessed by a data
analyst
now that you had a look at all the
technical skills you must note that the
role of a date analyst is a blend of
both technical and non-technical you
need to focus on certain non-technical
skills as well to become a full-fledged
data analyst so let's now move on and
look at what non-technical skills are
required to become a data analyst
if you enjoy watching informative tech
videos like this one consider
subscribing to simply learn's channel to
stay up to date on the trending
technologies and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
at number 3 we have problem solving
data analysts should be prepared to face
several barriers on a daily basis being
able to problem-solve the way out of
obstructions is an essential skill
there can be multiple issues like budget
constraints short deadlines and so on
these problems would require you to come
up with innovative solutions hence no
matter what the circumstances having
strong problem solving skills will
always be a virtue
being a data analyst also requires you
to think like an analyst analytical
skills also known as logical thinking
refers to breaking down problems
logically
having strong analytical skills will
help you arrive at a buy solution in any
situation based on information and facts
complex problems can be solved this way
critical thinking also goes hand in hand
with analytical skills critical thinking
is a self-guided and self-disciplined
way of thinking which attempts to reason
in a fair-minded way
as a data analyst critical thinking will
help you stay grounded when you are
searching for a solution to a tricky
problem you should also be capable of
making well thought independent
decisions there are a number of tips
that can help you improve your critical
thinking skills
moving on to number two we have business
knowledge
business knowledge or domain knowledge
refers to holding a sound understanding
of the domain you are working in
this knowledge is different for
different organizations for example if
you're working in the automobile
industry you might need to understand
how systems work and how its output can
be potentially influenced
irrespective of where you work you need
to have good business knowledge and
understand what you're analyzing
you should be in a position to
understand the various business problems
and how to solve them
only if you have a strong industry
knowledge can you try to improve the
business if you keep yourself updated
with market trends you can understand
where your company stands and
accordingly build a business model this
will also help you assist your business
in exploring greener pastures
so now let's have a look at what's at
number one here we have communication
and presentation
this might seem like a very common skill
but it's not as easy as it sounds
data analysts interact with various
teams to ensure proper implementation of
business requirements and for this
collaboration to run smoothly
communication is very important
the ability to communicate in numerous
ways is a key data analyst skill this
includes writing speaking presenting and
listening
written communication is crucial you
will be required to write up your
analysis and provide regular
documentations of it
data visualization and presentation
skills go hand in hand presenting your
analysis results to various team members
and stakeholders holds paramount
importance you might also need to be in
a state to explain a complex topic to
non-technical teammates
there is no point of a great analysis if
you are unable to explain it through
your presentation
you can master the presentation skill
with regular practice until you are
comfortable to explain in front of a
bunch of people
having said that you should also be very
crisp with your presentations you need
to be clear direct and focus on the
result rather than deviating from your
topic like they say you need to hit the
bullseye
before i start off with the top 10 data
analysis tools i'd like to talk a bit
about data analysis
so have you ever wondered why data
analysis is important
there are zillions of companies across
the world all these companies generate a
lot of data they literally work with
this generated data
these companies depend on data to make
crucial decisions which can impact their
businesses
data in its raw format has to be
converted into meaningful information
which can then be used by organizations
this is done by analyzing the generated
data and for this we have data analysis
so what is data analysis
data analysis is not just a single step
but a set of processes it is the process
of collecting data then cleaning it when
i say cleaning it simply means removing
the irrelevant data and then this data
is transformed into meaningful
information
we can simply relate this process to how
you make a jigsaw puzzle just like how
you gather all the pieces together and
fit them accordingly to bring out a
beautiful picture
data analysis also works on almost the
same grounds
to achieve the goals of data analysis we
use a number of data analysis tools
companies rely on these tools to gather
and transform their data into meaningful
insights so which tool should you choose
to analyze your data which tool should
you learn if you want to make a career
in this field we will answer that in
this session
after extensive research we have come up
with these top 10 data analysis tools
here we will look at the features of
each of these tools and the companies
using them so let's start off
at number 10 we have microsoft excel all
of us would have used microsoft excel at
some point right it is easy to use and
one of the best tools for data analysis
developed by microsoft excel is
basically a spreadsheet program using
excel you can create grids of numbers
text and formulae it is one of the
widely used tools be it in a small or
large setup
the interface of microsoft excel looks
like this
let's now move on to the features of
excel
firstly excel works with almost every
other piece of software in office we can
easily add excel spreadsheets to word
documents and powerpoint presentations
to create more visually appealing
reports or presentations
the windows version of excel supports
programming through microsoft's visual
basic for applications vba
programming with vba allows spreadsheet
manipulation that is difficult with
standard spreadsheet techniques
in addition to this the user can
automate tasks such as formatting or
data organization in vba
one of the biggest benefits of excel is
its ability to organize large amounts of
data into orderly logical spreadsheets
and charts
by doing so it's a lot easier to analyze
data especially while creating graphs
and other visual data representations
the visualization can be generated from
specified group of cells
those were few of the features of
microsoft excel
let's now have a look at the companies
using it
most of the organizations today use
excel few of them that use it for
analysis are the uk based company ernest
and young then we have urban pro wipro
and amazon
moving on to our next data analysis tool
at number 9 we have rapidminer
a data science software platform
rapidminer provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
it is used in almost every business and
commercial sector rapidminer also
supports all the steps of the machine
learning process
seen on your screens is the interface of
rapidminer
moving on to the features of rapidminer
firstly it offers the ability to drag
and drop it is very convenient to just
drag drop some columns as you are
exploring a data set and working on some
analysis
rapidminer allows the usage of any data
and it also gives an opportunity to
create models which are used as a basis
for decision making and formulation of
strategies
it has data exploration features such as
graphs descriptive statistics and
visualization which allows users to get
valuable insights
it also has more than 1500 operators for
every data transformation and analysis
task
let's now have a look at the companies
using rapidminer
we have the caribbean airline leeward
islands air transport next we have the
united health group the american online
payment company paypal and the austrian
telecom company mobilecom so that was
all about rapidminer now let's see which
tool we have at number eight
we have talent at number eight
talent is an open source software
platform which offers data integration
and management it specializes in big
data integration talent is available
both in open source and premium versions
it is one of the best tools for cloud
computing and big data integration
the interface of talent is as seen on
your screens
moving on to the features of talent
firstly automation is one of the great
boons talent offers it even maintains
the tasks for the users this helps with
quick deployment and development
it also offers open source tools talon
lets you download these tools for free
the development costs reduce
significantly as the processes gradually
speed up
talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases sas and other technologies
with the help of the data integration
platform you can build flat files
relational databases and cloud apps 10
times faster
those were the features of talon the
companies using talent are air france
l'oreal capgemini and the american
multinational pisa restaurant chain
dominos
next on the list at seven we have nine
constance information minor on nime is a
free and open source data analytics
reporting and integration platform
it can integrate various components for
machine learning and data mining through
its modular data pipelining concept
nime has been used in pharmaceutical
research and other areas like crm
customer data analysis business
intelligence text mining and financial
data analysis
here is how the interface of nime
application looks like
now coming to the 9 features
9 provides an interactive graphical user
interface to create visual workflows
using the drag and drop feature
use of jdbc allows assembly of nodes
blending different data sources
including pre-processing such as etl
that is extraction transformation
loading for modeling data analysis and
visualization with minimal programming
it supports multi-threaded in-memory
data processing 9 allows users to
visually create data flows selectively
execute some or all analysis steps and
later inspect the results models and
interactive views
nine server automates workflow execution
and supports team based collaboration
nime integrates various other open
source projects such as machine learning
algorithms from becca h2o keras park and
our project
nime allows analysis of 300 million
custom addresses 20 million cell images
and 10 million molecular structures
some of the companies hiring for nime
are united health group asml fractal
analytics atos and lego group
let's now move on to the next tool we
have sas at number six
sas facilitates analysis reporting and
predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in sas data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of sas
using sas better analysis of data is
achieved by using automatic code
generation and sql
sas allows you to access through
microsoft office by letting you create
reports using it and by distributing
them through it
sas helps with an easy understanding of
complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using sas we have companies like genpak
iq via accenture and ibm to name a few
that was all about sas
so for all those who joined in late let
me just quickly repeat our list at
number 10 we have microsoft excel then
at number nine we have rapidminer at
number eight we have talent at number
seven we have nine and at number six we
have sas
so far do you all agree with this list
let us know in the comment section below
let's now move on to the next five tools
in our list
so at number five we have both r and
python yes we have two of them in the
fifth position
r is a programming language which is
used for analysis as well it has
traditionally been used in academics and
research
python is a high level programming
language which has a python data
analysis library it is used for
everything starting from importing data
from excel spreadsheets to processing
them for analysis
this is the interface of r
next up is the interface of the python
jupyter notebook
let's now move on to the features of
both r and python
when it comes to the availability of r
and python it is very easy both r and
python are completely free hence it can
be used without any license
r used to compute everything in memory
and hence the computations were limited
but now it has changed both are in
python have options for parallel
computations and good data handling
capabilities
as mentioned earlier as both r and
python are open in nature all the latest
features are available without any delay
moving on to the companies using r we
have uber google facebook to name a few
python is used by many companies again
to name a few we have amazon google and
the american photo and video sharing
social networking service instagram
that was all about rn python
at number 4 we have apache spark
apache spark is an open source engine
developed specifically for handling
large-scale data processing and
analytics
spark offers the ability to access data
in a variety of sources including hadoop
distributed file system htfs openstack
swift
amazon s3 and cassandra
it allows you to store and process data
in real time across various clusters of
computers using simple programming
constructs apache spark is designed to
accelerate analytics on hadoop while
providing a complete suite of
complementary tools that include a fully
featured machine learning library a
graph processing engine and stream
processing
so this is how the interface of apache
spark looks like
now let's look at the important features
of apache spark
spark stores data in the ram hence it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics spark
helps to run an application in a hadoop
cluster up to 100 times faster in memory
and 10 times faster when running on disk
it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in java scala r or python
spark comes up with 80 high level
operators for interactive querying spar
code for batch processing joins stream
against historical data or run ad-hoc
queries on stream state
analytics can be performed better as
sparc has a rich set of sql queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics etc apache spark provides
fault tolerance through spark rdd spark
resilient distributed data sets are
designed to handle the failure of any
worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero
conviva netflix iq wear lockheed martin
and ebay are some of the companies that
use apache spark on a daily basis
at number three we have another
important growing data analysis tool
that is click view
qlikview software is a product of click
for business intelligence and data
visualization qlikview is a business
discovery platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and organizations
with qlikview you can analyze data and
use your data discoveries to support
decision making
clickview is a leading business
intelligence and analytics platform in
gartner magic quadrant
on the screen you can see how the
interface of qlikview looks like
now talking about its features
clickview provides interactive guided
analytics with in-memory storage
technology during the process of data
discovery and interpretation of
collected data the qlikview software
helps the user by suggesting possible
interpretations
clickview uses a new patent in-memory
architecture for data storage all the
data from the different sources is
loaded in the ram of the system and it
is ready to be retrieved from there
it has the capability of efficient
social and mobile data discovery social
data discovery offers to share
individual data insights within groups
or out of it
a user can add annotations as an
addition to someone else's insights on a
particular data report click view
supports mobile data discovery within an
html5 enabled touch feature which lets
the user search the data and conduct
data discovery interactively and explore
other server-based applications
clickview performs olap and etl features
to perform analytical operations extract
data from multiple sources transform it
for usage and load it to a data
warehouse
the companies that can help you start
your career in qlik view are
mercedes-benz cab gemini citibank
cognizant and accenture to name a few
at number 2 we have power bi
power bi is a business analytics
solution that lets you visualize your
data and share insights across your
organization or embed them in your app a
website
it can connect to hundreds of data
sources and bring your data to life with
live dashboards and reports
power bi is the collective name for a
combination of cloud-based apps and
services that help organizations collate
manage and analyze data from a variety
of sources through a user-friendly
interface
power bi is built on the foundation of
microsoft excel and has several
components such as windows desktop
application called power bi desktop and
online software as a service called
power bi service mobile power bi apps
available on windows phones and tablets
as well as for ios and android devices
here is how the power bi interface looks
like as you can see there is a visually
interactive sales report with different
charts and graphs
moving on to the features of power bi
it has an easy drag and drop
functionality with features that make
data visually appealing you can create
reports without having the knowledge of
any programming language
power bi helps users see not only what's
happened in the past and what's
happening in the present but also what
might happen in the future
it offers a wide range of detailed and
attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards you can select
several charts and graphs from the
visualization pane power bi has machine
learning capabilities with which it can
spot patterns in data and use those
patterns to make informed predictions
and run what-if scenarios
power bi supports multiple data sources
such as excel tech csv oracle sql server
pdf and xml files the platform
integrates with other popular business
management tools like sharepoint office
365 and dynamics 365 as well as other
non-microsoft products like spark hadoop
google analytics sap sales force and
mailchimp
some of the companies using power bi are
adobe axa carlsberg capgemini and nestle
moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below
finally on the top of the pyramid we
have tableau
gartner's magic quadrant of 2020
classified tableau as a leader in
business intelligence and data analysis
tableau interactive data visualization
software company was founded in jam 2003
in mountain view california
tableau is a data visualization software
that is used for data science and
business intelligence it can create a
wide range of different visualization to
interactively present the data and
showcase insights
the important products of tableau are
tableau desktop tableau public tableau
server tableau online and tableau reader
this is how the interface of tableau
desktop looks like
now coming to the features of tableau
data analysis is very fast with tableau
and the visualizations created are in
the form of dashboards and worksheets
tableau delivers interactive dashboards
that support insights on the fly
it can translate queries to
visualizations and import all ranges and
sizes of data
writing simple sql queries can help join
multiple datasets and then build reports
out of it you can create transparent
filters parameters and highlighters
tableau allows you to ask questions spot
trends and identify opportunities with
the help of tableau online you can
connect with cloud databases amazon
redshift and google bigquery
the companies using tableau are deloitte
adobe cisco linkedin and the american
e-commerce giant amazon to name a few
and there you go those are the top 10
data analysis tools
let's now have a question and answer
session please feel free to post your
queries in the comments section and
we'll respond in the chat
before the question answer session let's
recap quickly in the meanwhile y'all can
post your questions in the comments
section below
so at number 10 we have microsoft excel
then at number nine we have rapidminer
at number eight we have talent at number
seven we have nine at number six we have
sas
r and python at number five apache spark
at number four
click view at number three
power bi at number two and finally we
have tableau topping the list at number
one
currently all of us are living in an
information driven world and
organizations rely on data for various
decision makings this in turn provides a
lot of job opportunities for candidates
who can play with data out of the many
job roles in the field of data science
the two popular ones are that of a data
scientist and a data analyst
haven't we all wondered at some point as
to what the exact difference is between
these two job roles oh wait are they the
same
well they differ in various ways and you
will see how in this video
we will start off by looking at the job
descriptions of both the data scientist
and the data analyst then we will look
at their responsibilities and skill set
we will also have a look at their salary
structure and the various companies
hiring for these professionals so
without further ado let's get started
let's have a look at the job description
now
a data scientist is a professional who
uses different statistical methods data
analysis techniques and machine learning
in order to understand and analyze data
in order to arrive at business
conclusions
they proactively fetch information from
a plethora of sources and analyze it for
better understanding about how the
business performs and they also build ai
tools that automate certain processes
within the company
they derive meaning out of messy and
unstructured data a data scientist is
usually a senior most member in the team
moving to the description of data
analyst a data analyst is responsible to
collect process and perform analysis on
large data sets
they deal with data handling data
modeling and reporting
they are sometimes the entry-level
members into the data analytics team
they bring technical expertise to ensure
the quality and accuracy of the data
then process design and present it in
ways to help people businesses and
organizations make better decisions
after a few years of experience data
analysts can move into the roles of a
data engineer and a data scientist
now that we have understood the job
descriptions let's go ahead and
understand the various roles and
responsibilities of a data scientist and
a data analyst
firstly data scientists are responsible
for performing cleaning processing and
manipulation of data using several data
analytics tools
they also perform ad hoc data mining and
collect large sets of structured and
unstructured data from a number of
sources
secondly data scientists interpret the
data using various statistical methods
they design and evaluate advanced
statistical models to work on big data
thirdly data scientists regularly build
predictive models and machine learning
algorithms to work on vast volumes of
data
lastly data scientists use visualization
packages and tools to create reports and
dashboards for relevant stakeholders
they also work with data analysts and
data engineers to formulate the analysis
results
let's now have a look at the various
responsibilities of a data analyst
the first responsibility of a data
analyst is to recognize and understand
the company's goal this in turn helps in
streamlining the whole analysis process
they are required to assess the
available resources comprehend the
business problem and gather the right
set of data
this step is done by collaborating with
different team members such as data
scientists business analysts and
programmers
they gather data from various databases
and warehouses through querying they
write complex sql queries and scripts to
gather and extract information
data analysts also filter and clean data
to get the required information they are
responsible for data mining as well
data is mined from various sources and
then organized in order to obtain new
information from it data and lists
identify and analyze trends in complex
data sets using various statistical
tools
a data analyst is also responsible for
creating summary reports for the
leadership team so that they can make
timely decisions
data analysts use multiple data
visualization tools for achieving this
in order to achieve all the above
mentioned responsibilities data
scientists and data analysts are
required to possess a rich skill set
let's now have a look at few of the most
important skills required to back the
position of a data scientist
the basic requirement to become a data
scientist is that you must have a
bachelor's degree in computer science or
information technology but a master's
degree in the field of data science will
be a lot more beneficial
you also need to have a good experience
in the analytics domain as i mentioned
before this role is a senior role and to
get here the right amount of experience
is a must
let's have a look at the tools you need
to know
knowledge of microsoft excel is good it
is one of the most basic requirements
speaking of programming languages you
should be good at python c plus plus and
java
knowledge of perl is a brawny point
you should also be proficient in sql
as we discussed earlier data scientists
work on building machine learning
algorithms hence you need to have a good
knowledge of machine learning and deep
learning
familiarity with apache spark apache
hive and apache pig is necessary along
with the knowledge of hadoop
data visualization and bi skills are
necessary for creating reports and
dashboards you should also be able to
communicate and present information and
ideas clearly
so these are the skills required to
become a data scientist
if you want to explore the role of a
data analyst then you should hold a
degree in any relevant field beat
engineering in computer science
information technology or electrical
engineering you can also be a graduate
in statistics or economics
moving on to the tools once again you
should be familiar with microsoft excel
the next important skill is that you
should have good hands-on experience
with programming languages such as
python r and javascript this would help
you write programs to solve complex
problems
you should also have a good knowledge of
statistical and data analytics tools
such as sas minor and ssas
you must be able to write various sql
queries and procedures
in addition to these you must have a
strong understanding of statistics and
machine learning algorithms these
include concepts such as hypothesis
testing probability distributions and
various classification and clustering
techniques
most importantly a data analyst should
be able to create visually appealing
reports with the help of charts and
graphs using several data visualization
tools such as power bi and tableau
they must possess good presentation
skills as well in order to convey their
ideas to the clients and stakeholders in
a better way
so these are the skills that are
required to become a data analyst
let's now have a look at the annual
salary range of a data scientist and a
data analyst both in the us and in india
in the united states a data scientist
can earn a minimum salary of 61 thousand
dollars to a maximum of one hundred
thirty six thousand dollars per year
meanwhile in india a data scientist can
earn a minimum salary of three lakh
forty seven thousand rupees to a maximum
of two million rupees per annum
a date analyst in the united states can
earn a minimum salary of forty three
thousand dollars to a maximum of eighty
five thousand dollars per year
in india you can earn anywhere between
one lakh 98 000 rupees to 9 lakh 24 000
rupees per annum
let's now take a look at the various
companies hiring data scientists and
data analysts
we have amazon the internet and search
engine giant google deloitte the
american multinational technology
company microsoft then we have apple and
the american social media web and mobile
application company pinterest hiring
data scientists
from the many companies hiring data
analysts here we once again have amazon
then we have the popular retail company
walmart robertoff and atnt next we have
social media firms facebook and twitter
as you might have heard of the term data
never sleeps well it surely doesn't and
not only that but it also brings in a
number of job opportunities with it the
job group in this domain is limitless
and data will only continue to grow
let's have a look at few of the stats
now well ibm had predicted that by this
year that is 2020 the number of job
listings in the field of data science
and analytics will increase by 3 lakh 64
000.
and we had the u.s bureau of labor
statistics predicting that there will be
a rise in the data science needs and
this in turn will create 11.5 million
job openings by 2026. now that's a big
number isn't it
and if you are aspiring to become a data
scientist then you are on the right path
as there is a huge demand for this role
according to deloitte the united states
is projected to face a shortfall of 2
lakh 50 000 data scientists by 2024
that's barely just in four more years
all these stats prove that the job
demand in the field of data science and
data analytics is here to stay
professionals belonging to this domain
are in high demand all across the globe
now let's have a look at the google
search trends for data scientists and
data analysts
as you see the blue color depicts data
scientists and the red data analysts
both the search trends go hand in hand
and over time the search term data
analyst is higher but the search term of
that of a data scientist is experiencing
a steady rise
let's have a look at the worldwide
youtube search trend as well
as you can see on your screens it looks
like people are more keen on exploring
the job role of a data scientist and
looks like they want to learn more about
the job role of a data scientist
compared to that of a data analyst
nevertheless the search term data
analyst is also right there in the
competition
we're going to look at three very
important data related roles in the
field of data science and then we're
going to pit them against each other so
welcome to data scientist versus data
analyst versus data engineer now let's
have a look at what's in store for you
firstly we'll talk about the job
descriptions the skill sets required for
each role the salary the roles and
responsibilities and the companies
hiring for these positions so now let's
have a look at each of these roles in
detail first off let's have a look at
data scientist now a data scientist is
able to create machine learning-based
tools or processes within the company
now they use advanced data techniques
such as clustering division trees neural
networks and so on so that they can
derive business conclusions they are the
senior most member in the team which
involves a data engineer as well as a
data analyst now they need to have
in-depth knowledge of statistics data
handling and machine learning they also
take inputs from data engineers as well
as analysts so that they can formulate
actionable insights for the business now
data scientist also needs to have the
same skills as a data analyst and an
engineer but needs to have a lot more
in-depth knowledge and expertise with
these skills next up we have data
analyst now a data analyst is someone
who is able to translate numeric data
into a form that everyone in the
organization can understand now this is
an entry level position in the data
analytics team he or she needs to have
technical skills in programming
languages such as python and have
knowledge of tools like excel and
understand the basics of data handling
modeling and reporting now in due time
they can move up the ranks by taking up
roles of data engineer and data
scientists with some experience that
they can accumulate over the years and
finally we have data engineer now data
engineer is someone who's involved with
pairing data who's involved with
preparing data for analytical or
operational purposes now they are the
intermediary between the data analyst
and the data scientist he or she needs
to have a lot of experience when it
comes to developing constructing and
maintaining architectures now they do
generally work on big data and submit
their reports to the data scientists so
that they can be analyzed now let's have
a look at the skill sets required for
each of these roles first off we have
data scientists now since this role is a
little more coding oriented you need to
know a great deal when it comes to
programming languages programming
languages such as python r sql sas java
and so on now you also need to be
well-versed with frameworks in relation
to big data such as pig spark and do
speaking of hadoop if you want to learn
more about how it works i suggest you
click on the top right corner and watch
our video on what is hadoop coming back
data scientists also need to be
well-versed with machine learning deep
learning and other similar technologies
next up we have data analyst now this
role is much less technical as compared
to a data scientist as well as a data
engineer considering how it's entry
level here knowing programming languages
is a great bonus so an idea about
programming languages such as python r
sql javascript ssas and so on is a great
benefit at the same time you do need to
be well-versed with tools such as sas
minor microsoft excel ssas spss and so
on and finally we have data engineer now
being a data engineer requires you to be
well versed with a bunch of programming
languages as well as frameworks now you
need to know about programming languages
such as python r sql sas java and so on
while having expertise in frameworks
such as hadoop mapreduce hive pig apache
spark data streaming nosql and so on now
let's talk about money or the salary
each of these roles get firstly we have
the data scientist who earns a whopping
137 000 us dollars per annum then we
have the data analyst who earns sixty
seven thousand dollars per annum which
is a pretty high salary when you
consider that it's only an entry-level
job and a data engineer which is in the
median with a hundred and sixteen
thousand us dollars per annum now let's
talk about roles and responsibilities
firstly we have the data scientist now a
data scientist gets to work with a lot
of unstructured data so they need to
mine and clean the data so that it's
usable they need to be able to design
machine learning models to work on the
big data they need to infer and
interpret the analysis on big data to be
able to lead an entire team to achieve
the goals of the organization and
deliver conclusions that have a direct
business impact now let's have a look at
the roles and responsibilities of a data
analyst they need to use queries to
gather information from a database they
need to process the data and provide
summary reports they need to use basic
algorithms for their work such as linear
regression logistic regression and so on
and have core skills in statistics data
munching data visualization and
exploratory data analysis and finally we
have data engineer now they need to mine
through the data so that they can gain
insights from it they need to convert
erroneous data into a usable form so
that they can be further analyzed they
need to write queries on data they need
to maintain the design as well as
architecture of the data and create
large data warehouses using etl or
extract transform load now let's have a
look at some of the companies hiring for
this role firstly for data scientists
you have citibank facebook schneider
intel amazon and so on for data analysts
you have infosys oracle visa capital one
walmart and so on and for data engineer
you have google cisco flowcast cognizant
apple spotify and much much more so if
all this has inspired you to get started
with data science i suggest you take
simply learn certification now i'm
choosing this certification because it
acts as a great entry point for starting
your career as a data analyst or a data
engineer now with this certification it
goes through all the important concepts
when it comes to data science and has 68
hours of in-depth learning for real-life
industry based projects interactive
learning with jupyter notebooks and
dedicated mentoring sessions from our
faculty of industry experts now some of
the concepts are you will be going
through statistical analysis and
business applications python environment
setup mathematical computing with python
which is numpy scipy data manipulation
with pandas machine learning with
psychic learn and so much more so then
you can start up on your step to
becoming a data analyst a data engineer
and then eventually a data scientist now
if you're already working as a data
analyst or a data engineer you can
become a certified data scientist with
simply learns data scientist masters
program this goes through all the
important concepts that you need to know
so that you can become a successful as
well as certified data scientists we'll
compare the two most popular job roles
in the field of information technology
that is business analyst versus data
analyst first let's understand the job
description of a business analyst
business analyst is a professional who
bridges the gap between the it and the
business teams in an organization they
use data analytics and modern
technologies to assess processes and
deliver data-driven solutions
they understand and solve a business
problem and validate business
requirements
a business analyst generates reports for
executives and stakeholders
they are part of the business operation
and work closely with the technology
team to improve the quality of the
services being delivered they also
assist in the integration and testing of
new solutions
now let's talk about the job description
of a data analyst
with the rapid increase in data
generation today the term data analyst
has found its prominence
a data analyst collects processes and
performs analysis of large data sets
every business generates data in several
formats this data can be in the form of
customer information and feedback log
files transaction data marketing
research and so on it is the duty of a
data analyst to transform these business
data into valuable insights some of the
problems that can be addressed are how
to improve a business how to provide
good customer experience what would be
the ideal price for a new product how to
reduce transportation costs and so on
data analysts deal with data handling
data modeling and reporting with this
brief understanding of the job
description for a business analyst and a
data analyst let's now shift our focus
towards the various responsibilities of
a business analyst
a business analyst identifies the
business goals understands the problems
faced by an organization and comes up
with a cost-effective solution to tackle
the issues
they thoroughly understand the
requirements from the clients and assign
the right resources
bas communicate and work closely with
the development team to design the
solution for a problem they ensure that
the development team doesn't spend their
time understanding the stakeholders
requirements and often give iterative
feedback on the solution being developed
they check and validate if the project
is running fine with the help of user
acceptance testing they also verify if
the solution being worked on is in line
with the requirements and ensure that
the final product satisfies the user
expectations bas assess the functional
and non-functional requirements
a business analyst documents the project
findings and results they present the
project conclusions to the stakeholders
and clients along with delivering
maintenance reports and building
visualizations to make decisions now
let's take a look at the
responsibilities of a data analyst
first and foremost a data analyst must
identify and understand the
organization's goal and requirements
this helps to plan and streamline the
analysis process data analysts collect
data from various heterogeneous sources
they assess the available resources
comprehend the business problem and
gather the right data for analysis they
work closely with different team members
like programmers business analysts and
data scientists
data filtering and data wrangling are
vital jobs of a data analyst the data
collected is often noisy and it contains
missing values hence it is crucial to
clean the collected data and remove
invalid values to make it ready for
analysis
they use a variety of analytical
statistical and business intelligence
tools to spot trends and patterns in
complex data sets discover hidden
insights and prepare summary reports for
the leadership team
they also use programming languages for
data mining and data manipulation
now it's time for us to understand the
difference between a business analyst
and a data analyst based on the skill
set they possess
first let's look at the skills that can
help you become a ba
a business analyst should have a
graduation degree in any relevant field
such as business accounting information
systems human resources or engineering
you can apply for entry-level business
analyst positions or with professional
experience
excel is a powerful analytics and
reporting tool for working with data
bas use excel to perform various
calculations data analysis plan and
editorial calendar and calculate
customer discounts to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
bas use sql to retrieve manipulate and
analyze data stored in relational
databases
critical thinking skills are important
to understand customers business needs
it allows them to distinguish between
requirements that add value to the
business and those that should be given
a lower priority
base should find different ways to
address each challenge
data visualization is a key skill for
bas to build interactive dashboards and
reports to convey the outcomes of a
project
knowledge of tableau power bi and
qlikview is required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
business analysts should have a good
hands-on programming experience to solve
complex tasks and perform faster
analysis of data
hence knowledge of programming languages
such as r and python is a prerequisite
finally they should have good
presentation skills they should also be
confident about their findings and
conclusions and communicated in front of
the stakeholders and clients
let's now understand the skills that a
data analyst should possess
you must have a bachelor's degree in any
relevant field or be a graduate in
statistics economics or science
you're eligible to become a data analyst
being a fresher or as an experienced
professional you should have domain
knowledge in the field you are working
in once again knowledge of excel is
another basic requirement for a data
analyst
data analysts often work with structured
data so they should be proficient in
writing sql queries using data
manipulation and data definition
commands they should know how to create
stored procedures
another crucial skill for a data analyst
is to have hands-on experience with
programming languages such as python r
sas and javascript you can analyze and
visualize large data sets and create
predictive models for making business
decisions
data analysts create data visualizations
using libraries such as matplotlib
c-bond ggplot and plotly
this helps them to perform exploratory
data analysis
knowledge of tableau and power bi is
required to create different business
reports with the help of graphs and
charts
data analysts should have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms to build
sophisticated models and make future
predictions
so they should know about linear
regression logistic regression support
vector machines k-mean clustering and
other supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms
finally data analysts should also
possess good communication and
presentation skills
now let's discuss a salary structure for
both of these job roles
according to pay scale a business
analyst in the united states earns an
average salary of 69 000
while in india you can earn nearly 6
lakh rupees per annum now talking about
the salary of a data analyst according
to pay scale in the us a data analyst
earns an average salary of sixty
thousand seven hundred and ten dollars
per annum and in india you can earn
around four lakhs twenty four thousand
rupees per annum let's now move on and
look at the different companies hiring
for business analyst roles
here we have oracle the search engine
giant google the american mnc cognizant
and e-commerce company amazon in
addition to that we have ernest and
young technology giant ibm dell and
cisco hiring business analysts
talking about the companies hiring for
data analysts we have twitter google the
social media leader facebook and amazon
we also have the american oil company
shell the electric vehicle company tesla
apple and the american credit reporting
agency equifax
now choosing the right field that is to
become a business analyst or a data
analyst could be a challenging task
the key points that you have to keep in
mind before making a decision is
first review your background and see
what qualifications you have check what
skills you possess and the domain
knowledge you have
then gauge your interest to see what
suits you best
and finally consider your long-term
goals and see the job roles that will
help you grow in your career in the long
run
now let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career as a business
analyst and a data analyst
simplylearn offers a postgraduate
program in business analysis that is in
collaboration with purdue university the
endorsed education provider is iiba some
of the skills that will be covered in
this course are strategy analysis
wireframing solution evaluation
dashboarding data visualization agile
scrum methodology scrum artifacts
statistical analysis using excel and sql
database
some of the tools covered in this course
are microsoft excel tableau power bi
jira postgresql planbox and others
some of the key features of this
business analysis program are you will
receive purdue post graduate program
certification master classes from purdue
faculty you can enroll in simply learns
job assist where you will get im jobs
pro membership for 6 months and obtain
35 iiba pd cdus and 25 pmi ptus
you will get 170 plus hours of blended
learning along with capstone projects in
three domains
to become a data analyst you can enroll
in the postgraduate program in data
analytics offered by simply learn
this program is in collaboration with
purge university and ibm
the skills that will be covered as a
part of the course are statistical
analysis using excel data analysis in
python and our data visualization using
tableau and power bi linear and logistic
regression modules clustering using
k-means
supervised learning and others
the tools that you will learn are numpy
pandas scipy scikit-learn excel and
others
some of the key features of this course
are you will get purdue post graduate
program certification industry
recognized ibm certificates enrollment
and simply learns job assist and master
classes from purdue faculty
you have 180 plus hours of blended
learning 14 plus hands-on projects on
integrated labs and capstone projects in
three domains
so please go ahead and enroll for these
programs if you want to grow your career
as a business analyst or a data analyst
applications of data analytics
now the sky's the limit on this in
today's world almost every business act
of life your music on your spotify are
driven by data analytics
but some of the big players when you go
in their job hunting are going to be
your fraud analysis if you want to go
make a lot of money and you're good at
it and you like dealing with numbers
go join the banks and track down the
criminals who are stealing money it's a
lot of you know it's a big thing to
protect credit cards
protect sales purchases bad checks any
of those things when you can track them
down is huge
healthcare exploding
there is everything from trying to find
cures for
the covet virus or any of the viruses
out there
using your cell phone to diagnose
different ailments
that way you don't have to go and see
the doctor you can actually just go in
there and take a picture of the funky
growth on your arm hopefully it's not
too big and then they send it in there
and the data analytics goes in there
looks at it and says oh this is what
this is this is a professional you need
to go see or don't need to see
and that's just one aspect of healthcare
the databases being generated by health
care and getting the right doctors and
helping the doctors analyze whether
something is
benign or malignant if it's cancerous
all those things are now part of the
ongoing healthcare growth in data
analytics
inventory management
think one of those huge warehouses where
they're shipping out all the goods
how do you inventory that in such a way
so that uh you maximize the stuff that's
being purchased the most near the
entrance and all the other stuff towards
the back or even pre-ship it so it's
huge to be able to inventory the
manager inventory and pretty soon
they'll just have a drone come in there
and start picking up some of those boxes
and move them around also
deliver your logistics again this goes
from getting from point a to point b
you can combine it with our inventory so
you pre-ship stuff if you know a certain
area is more likely to purchase it how
do you get it the delivery to the most
destinations the quickest in the short
amount of time and then they even
pre-stacked the trucks going out and
that's all done with data analytics how
do we stack all that stuff so it comes
out in the right order
targeted marketing
huge industry any kind of marketing
whether you're generating uh the right
content for the marketing who are you
targeting with that marketing
researching the people what they want so
you know what products to market out
there all those things are huge
and these are just a few examples you
can probably go way beyond this from
tracking forest fires
to astrology and studying the stars all
of this is part of data analytics now
and plays a huge role in all these
different areas
city planning is another one
you know you can see a nice organized
city like this one where you can get in
and out of the neighborhoods if you're a
fire truck
uh police officers need to be able to
get in and out you want your tourists to
be able to come in you still want the
place to look nice and you have the
right commercial development the right
industrial development like enough
residents for people to stay all those
things are part of your city planning
again huge in data analytics
so sky's the limit on what you use it
for let's take a look at types of data
analytics
and this can be broken up in so many
ways but we're going to start with
looking at the most basic questions
that you're going to be asking in data
analytics and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight
how many cells per call ratio coming out
of the call center
if we have 500 tourists in a forest and
you have a certain temperature how many
fires were started how many times did
the police have to show up to certain
houses
all that's descriptive
the next one is predictive predictive
analytics is what will happen next we
want to predict
this is great if you have a ice cream
store and you want to predict how many
people to work at the ice cream store in
a certain day
based on the temperature coming up in
the time of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive analytics and you can
think of that as combining the first two
we have descriptive and we have
predictive then you get pre-scriptive
analytics
how can we make it happen
foresight what can we change to make
this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions
especially in city development there's a
good one
if we want to have our city generate
more income
and we want that income to be commercial
based
what kind of commercial buildings do we
need to build in that area that are
going to bring people over do we need
huge warehouse sales costco sales
buildings or do we need little mom pod
joints that are going to bring in
people from the country to come shop
there or do you want an industrial setup
what do you need to bring that industry
in there is our car industry available
in that area
if it's not a car industry what other
industries are in that area
all those things are prescriptive we're
guessing we're guessing what can we do
to fix it what can we do to fix crime in
area with education what kind of
education are we going to use
to help people understand what's going
on so that we lower the rate of crime
and we help our communities grow better
that's all prescriptive it's all
guessing we want foresight into how can
we make it happen how can we make this
better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three because a lot of
people stumble on this when they come in
and are doing analytics whether you're
the manager
shareholder or the data scientist coming
in you really need to understand the
descriptive analytics where you're
studying the total units of furniture
sold and the profit that was made in the
past
here we go into predictive analytics
predicting the total units that would
sell and the profit we can expect in the
future
gear up for how many employees we need
how much money we're going to make
and prescriptive analytics finding ways
to improve the sales and the profit so
we can sell maybe a different kind of
furniture we're going to guess at what
the area is looking for and how that
marketing is going to change
data analytics process steps
so let's take a look at some of the
basic processing and what that looks
like when you're working with this data
so there's five basic steps
the five steps of processing and this
changes and then there's a lot of things
that go on when they talk about
agile programming
the whole concept of agile is you take
some kind of framework like this
and then you build on it depending on
what your business needs
so the first step is data collection
and usually with a large company you
might have somebody who
is responsible for the database
management
you might have another one where they're
pulling apis they're pulling data off of
maybe the census bureau
maybe something very very
specific domain specific so if you're
analyzing cancerous growths and how to
understand them then the data collection
is going to be those measurements they
take from the mri or it might be even
the mri images they've used those also
so there's a lot of things with data
collection and how to
control that and make sure it has what
you need and is clean and you don't have
miss information coming in
once you have the data collected there's
a data preparation
so stage two is we take that data and we
format it into something we can use
probably one of the biggest formats that
you see is when you're processing text
how do you process text
well you use what they call a one hot
encoder and each word is represented by
a yes no kind of setup so it'd be like a
long array of bits
that's one way to prepare it and so you
know bit number one is the bit number
two is has or whatever it is
other preparations might be if you're
using neural networks you might be
taking integers or float numbers and
converting them to a value between zero
and one
that way you don't have one of them
creating a bias in there so there's a
lot of different things that go into
data preparation
that is 80
of data science so we talk about the
data analytics which is a little bit
more on the math side and they usually
say talk about a data scientist kind of
being the overall
preparer of this stuff you're going to
spend 80 percent of your data
preparation
data exploration
that's the fun part this is where you're
exploring things
and it is
maybe 10 to 15 of what you do with the
data you spend with the data exploration
it is probably uh the most important
step
because this is where you got to start
asking questions
uh if you ask your questions wrong
you're going to get some wrong
information if you're working with a
company and they want to know the
marketing values then you really got to
focus on hey how do we generate money
for this company or fraud how do we
lower the fraud rate
while still generating a profit
four
data modeling this is where we start
actually getting into the data code
which model to use
that predicts what's going to happen
and then result interpretation we want
to be able to interpret those results
usually see that in your matplot library
where you create nice beautiful images
so it shows up on their dashboard for
the marketing
manager or for the ceo so they can take
a quick look and say hey i can see
what's going on there you want to reduce
it to something they can easily read
they don't want to hear the scientific
terms they want to see something they
can use
and we'll talk about that a little bit
more and we start looking at some of
this in a demo
let's look at one more interesting
feature of excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen
conditional formatting has different
rules which can be applied on your data
and that allows you to basically
differentiate or easily identify data
values which
are
based on certain criterias or rules so
when you talk about conditional
formatting you have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you
you can easily manage these rules
so conditional formatting is very useful
for people who would want to work on
huge amount of data and easily perform
some data analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting
you can format cells based on a preset
condition
you can perform conditional formatting
to identify cells
you can highlight a few significant
cells and you can easily perform
conditional formatting as shown
on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look
so say for example we have our excel
sheet and if you see here
i am highlighting
the sales person who have generated
revenue greater than 10 000.
so
we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color
and how do we get here so for example
let's select
this data
and what i could do is
i could go into conditional formatting
now i could basically highlight cell
rules and we could just say greater than
that's an easier way i could also go
ahead and create a new rule but then i
can use one of this option i can say
greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be interested in looking at
any value greater than twelve thousand
so let's choose twelve
thousand
and here it says what color would you
want to select so for example
i would say
something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay
so right now what i'm doing is
i have all the values where the revenue
generator was greater than 10 000
but then i have also selected all the
sales
people who have made or who have
generated revenue greater than 12 000.
so i can just wait ctrl z to see the
previous result now here
i had the values which were greater than
10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000. so this is one simple
example now we can look at some other
examples say for example you want to
format cells using three color scale so
if you look at the values here i have a
three color scale mainly in green yellow
and red and how do you do this so for
example i can go in here
and i can go to conditional formatting
so i would want to
go for color scales and here
you can create different rules so
we can set up a two color scale so we
can say format
only values that are above and below
average i can format only cells that
contain something
i can get the top and bottom values so
these are different ways in which i can
have a three color based scale now what
i will do is i will select this
and let me show you the rule which i
have so for example
i can go into manage rules and if you
see here there are certain rules which
have been specified now what does that
mean
so you would want to specify a three
grade scale
so for example if i would want to look
at my first rule
it tells me that i am choosing three
color scale i can choose lowest value
percentile and highest value and that
basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is i can
basically
use one of these values i can delete
these rules which i have created
so for example
i have all these rules
but you should always carefully remember
that the rules will be applied in the
order shown so for example if i just
delete these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now
it does not have any highlighting now i
can go in here
i can say condition sorry conditional
formatting i could go for color scale so
i could basically go into
new rule
so i would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red
i can say midpoint is percentile 50
and then the highest value is green and
if that looks good let's say okay and
now if you see the lowest values have
been highlighted as red
you have mid values and then
you have the positive value so this is
the three color scale and that
easily helps me in identifying the data
based on the cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can
basically color the cells based on their
value so what we are seeing here
is if the revenue
generated
is greater than average
then that shows in green
and if the revenue generated is lesser
than average that's shows in orange now
how do we do that so we can basically
again manage some rules so i can
basically create a new rule
now here i can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option i would want to select now i can
select this and it says format values
that are above average
so
in our case we had it in green so for
example i'll say above average and then
here i can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size
so
let's go and look into
the formatting
so for example let's choose yellow
say okay now i'm saying wherever
the cell values are above average it
would be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here
let's go and look into manage rules so
this is basically the rule which we are
applying now we can also add a new rule
and
i need to
select the values so for example i will
say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below
we'll go for format we will choose red
we'll say okay we'll say
now
these are
basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if i select this and then
i could basically choose my area just
hit on enter
and similarly you can go in here and
then select your area
hit on enter and say apply say okay and
now if you see
i have really chosen bright colors but
then i have said wherever my revenue
generated is above average
it should be in yellow and
below average should be in red so we
wanted above
average to be in green and below average
to be in orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always color code your cell values
based on some rules which you are
setting up now similarly you can also
find the top 10 and bottom 10 values and
that's pretty easy so you can just
select this
and then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items
or you can go in for more rules so you
can say format only top
or bottom ranked values so you have top
10
now you can choose the color
and for example i'll go for
blue and
i'll say okay
so now if you see my top 10 values are
blue now similarly i can add one more
rule so i can say new rule and i can say
let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay
say okay and that's it so now you have
your values which are top or bottom 10
values
so you are using conditional formatting
where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors
and here
easy conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also
have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing so what
we can do is we can select our columns
either you could apply this to all the
columns now here i have applied this
only to jan and april now i could apply
this for june so let's say june so you
can go for gradient fill you can go for
solid fill
you can obviously just select the color
and that takes care of the things
you can say for example select this and
now this is selected but i would want to
might be format this so i can go in here
i can go into manage rules now that will
tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so i can just do a edit
rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill
which is color
you have no border this is basically
color is black now i can go for
something like gradient fill
and i can say okay and now if i say
apply and okay so this basically is like
your first column so you can use
conditional formatting for various use
cases and you can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be
here the revenue is getting generated or
was getting generated but did not grow
beyond a particular value
and so on
now similarly you can also go in for
different options
say for example here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased
or say for example if the revenue was
going up for this particular sales
person so here we are looking at carol
so in jan the revenue generation by
sales was very high
then in feb it was falling down
in march it was
kind of stable
then in april it went way below so we
can obviously work
on this wherein we can grade our cell
values so what we can do is we can
go in for
highlighting the cell values now
you can go for color scales you can go
for icon sets
and this is where you can choose your
different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
i would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional i could go
using this three arrows i can go in for
this color i can choose directional
and then
my values are
automatically
using directional now what we can also
do is we can then go into manage rules
and that basically tells me what rules
have been applied
so for example the latest one is the
icon set which i have chosen it shows
the selected columns i can obviously do
a edit rule and then i can choose so i'm
saying the format style is
icon sets
i'm not using a data bar i'm not using
color scale
now here
i have chosen the style of icons
and then here
you can basically give some values so
you have icon which is green
when the value is greater than or equal
to 67 percentage
when i say
hyphen or minus it is less than 67
it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily
highlight your cell values based on this
icon set so i can apply this and that's
how i use conditional formatting so
conditional formatting can be very
useful
if you would want to use icon set if you
want to use your data bars if you would
want to
highlight particular values
if you would want to color code based on
some calculation
if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts
or people who are working business
intelligence teams or people who would
want to use excel
to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value
or finding out less significant or more
significant cells
to then pull out values and carry out
your computations calculations
or analysis
let's learn one more feature of excel
and that's basically your data
validation now this can be very useful
when you would want to work on
validating the data which is being fed
in the cells so you could limit it to
basically a number between a particular
value you could also add some messages
to it
if you would want
or you could even
circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered
you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed
now that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict
that the name should accept only 15
characters now how do you do that so you
can basically select the cells
or
you can just select a particular cell
and then we can later drag
the property to other fields now here
once the cell is selected so for example
let's try this out and let's see if that
works so for example i will say peter
johnson
okay and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
junior
and if i do this it says
input length is greater than 15 do you
want to continue if i say yes
right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then
it has
basically violated the rule
now this is giving a message to the user
that the username should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that
so for this
we can basically
select the column and then we can search
for data tab and get into data
validation
so this is where you can create or
select different kind of rules so for
example i can go into data validation
i can go into settings and i can say the
text length
and that should be less than 15 now this
is the maximum i'm giving and it says
apply these changes to all other cells
within the same settings
so i can do this or i can just drag and
drop so i can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
control data validation in this
particular column
and that will allow only 15 characters
it will pop up a message
if the user really wants to go beyond
the particular limit
now you also have similarly date of
birth so the restriction is date of
birth should be between 10 jan 1990 to
30 december 1998.
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here i have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range
that is 10 jan date
1990
12 30 1998 so that's the start and the
end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now i can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so i can say stop
i can say invalid entered
and this is how i have set a rule so for
example if i just do
something like this
and that says invalidate entered i can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until
i did not
give the right format the date will not
be accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well i
would want to apply this rule to
all these rows starting from c2 to c14
so let's get into data validation let's
look in settings and here we are
choosing custom
now within custom i am choosing
what is the formula so i am saying is
number
and then i am saying find
at the rate for
the rows c2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here is the value
should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for
error alert so for example we can
basically go in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title i'm giving and we can
say
email should
contain
at the rate
so if i do this and if i say okay now
you can test it so you can say abcd
and that says email should contain at
the rate and basically that will not
allow me to add the values so now you
have the field called salary it says
salary should be greater than 50 000 now
we can limit the values by
choosing
a whole number so for example for salary
i can go into data validation
i can go into settings so here i can say
something like
decimal or i can go for whole number so
both of the things are fine it depends
on what kind of values get into this
particular field so if i say whole
number and if i say it has to be greater
than 50 000
so i'm saying the minimum is 50 000
or i could have given a decimal and then
i can say greater than less than equal
or anything or even between so i can
select greater than and then i can just
say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will
generally not be decimal so this would
be whole number salary
is
can be a whole number or it could be
decimals so we have chosen decimal here
and in rank if you click on data
validation i have chosen whole number
i have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends i can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be
based on a list of items
now for example here if you see i have
two columns so one column basically has
the values of city
names and then you have places within
that particular city so if i would want
to
implement a data validation based on
this so for example if you see here city
and that basically shows me only the
four values which can be entered and if
i go to place then it tells me for
maharashtra i can only enter pune mumbai
nasik now how do i do this so say for
example you take an empty field and you
want to restrict the values of city
names so i could
select data validation i could basically
select list
and then it tells me you need to enter
the list values that is the source so
you click here and then i can just
select these fields now if i do this and
if i say ok
it has implemented a data validation but
if you look into this
it will show me the same thing but then
it shows me some empty cells
which did not have any value so this is
fine but it would be better if we do it
in a different way so i can select this
and i've already given my city names
here so i can just do a data validation
and here in the source
let me get rid of this
now
i can just
have my cursor here i can select these
values
and then if i say okay so now if you see
my city names have been restricted to
these values and that's how you can
implement your data validation so i have
this data validation here but i will get
rid of this one by just doing a ctrl z
now i'll come here and say for example i
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in
doing this for all my four cities now if
you see here i have
data validation i could choose bangalore
and if you come and check here there is
no data validation but we have
implemented data validation here now how
is that done so i could select this or
for example i can go in here i can
select data validation
i can select list
and then here in the source
i will say for bangalore the value
should be these
and then
if i basically say ok
now
if we see these are the values which are
fed into bangalore
so we could do this or like what we have
done here so if you can check the data
validation rule
i have used list and then i have said
indirect
f2 so basically i'm giving in a formula
which relates to the value which is in
for the city maharashtra so we could do
this or in a simpler way we could do
this and then just drag and drop here so
we could check for maharashtra what are
the values
let's choose a different city so for
example kolkata and here i will choose
now since we did a drag and drop it has
basically taken the values of bank load
so that's not right
so we select this we go into data
validation and here i can either
feed in the values
that is such as bangalore i could
basically say something like this
kolkata
and i could say okay so now if you see
it shows me the places in kolkata
now here
we have let's choose a different city so
for example let's go for delhi
and here i can go to data validation and
i can just say delhi
so this is an easier way of doing it or
if you remember the formula
then what you can do is
you can just give in
indirect
and then basically
give the
value of the cell
for which you would want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation so you can
provide a list of values and then you
can restrict the values in a cell which
should be
belonging to a particular list
so this is how you do a simple data
validation by restricting the
data in the form of a list
excel is a really powerful tool for data
analytics and reporting and pivot tables
are one of the features that excel
offers for creating tabular reports to
summarize our data
let's begin by understanding what is a
pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in a spreadsheet to obtain
a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to the columns
all row labels are unique values and
duplicates are removed
columns
is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displays the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum
finally we have filters filters apply a
calculation or restriction to the entire
table
so let's jump over to microsoft excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo
so with india being ready for its 16
census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze india's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across india stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socio-economic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first i'll show you one of the features
that excel offers us so suppose i click
on any cell and hit control plus q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis
now you can see by default excel has
prompted certain
features such as formatting we have
charts totals and there's one more
called tables
now excel by default has created some
pivot tables for us now the first one
you see is sum of district code by state
names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others
before creating our pivot table so let's
have a final look at our data set
so first column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of india
then we have the state code we have the
state name
district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each city
then we have the male and female
literates
next we have the sex ratio
then we have the child sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population
for each of the states in descending
order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data
go to the insert tab
and here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now
my range is already selected the entire
table
and here i'll choose existing worksheet
because i want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet and i'll give my
location i'll point to
cell q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state
so what i'll do is
i'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want
the total population for each of these
states
so
in the field list i'll search for total
population which is this one
and drag it under
values you can see
we have a sum of total population for
each of these states
by default
excel will sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want
now we want to sort this column in
descending order so i right click
go to sort option and choose z to a
that is largest to smallest
you can see here
in 2011 maharashtra had the highest
number of population
or the total population in maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
pradesh we had andhra pradesh
and if i come down we have nagaland and
andaman and nicobar islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created
now the next problem we have is we want
to find the total sum of literates in
each city belonging to a certain state
so let's see how to do it
i'll click on any cell go to insert
and here i can click on pivot table
my range is selected
i'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location
which is q5
i click on ok
now here
we want to find the total sum of
literates so what i'll do is
first let me drag
total literate's column to values
you have the total sum of literates from
all the states
next i want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag
state name onto rows and then
we'll drag city
onto rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
to the left of the pivot table you can
see we have the state names and
the cities
per state
and on the right you can see the total
number of literates from each city if i
scroll down we have assam then you can
see we have bihar
and if i keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana himachal pradesh there's
jammu and kashmir which has now become a
union territory
we have jharkhand karnataka and other
states as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
i'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing worksheet
i'll select cell q5
and click on ok
now
since we want
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio so first i'll drag those columns
either you can manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it so if i look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed
can just drag it from there let me
delete this
and i also want the sex ratio
so i'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next
we want to see it based on
different states so what i'll do is
i'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have our pivot
table ready
on the left you can see we have the
different state names listed and on the
right we have the values
now we want to find the average now by
default excel will sum the numeric
columns you can see it tells you sum of
sex ratio and child 6 ratio
so what you can do
you can click on this
drop down and go to value field settings
and here summarize values by you can
choose average
you can see the custom name it says
average of 6 ratio
click on ok
our entire column is now giving us the
average sex ratio
similarly for
this column let me convert it into
average i'll again click on the drop
down
go to value field settings
click on average
and click ok
and you can see here we have the average
of child sex ratio for each of the
states now the next question says
which states had the highest and lowest
sex ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me short it in descending
order
you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011
kerala had the highest sex ratio
and if i scroll down to the bottom you
can see himachal pradesh had the lowest
which is around 818.
up next
let's explore one more feature of pivot
table so suppose you want to see the top
or bottom few rows
of a pivot table
you can do that as well
so here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates
so let's see from the entire pivot table
how we can filter the top three cities
so i'll go to insert
click on the pivot table option
go to existing worksheet
click on q5
and hit ok
now since we want to find the top three
cities
i'll drag
city column onto rows and then
we want the female graduates so in the
search bar i'll look for female
and i'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values
so i have
the sum of female graduates for each of
the cities
now since we want to find the
highest number of female graduates in
the top three cities so let me first
sort this column
i'll sort it in descending order now we
have it sorted now from this you can say
that delhi greater mumbai and bangalore
are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
right click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 i'll select this
here i only want the top three
so either you can
go down like this
or you can directly
type three
your column is already selected let me
just click on ok
there you go
we have the required pivot table ready
and it only displays us the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here
what's the total population for all the
cities in rajasthan and karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing
i'll click on a location this time q6
click ok
now since i want the total population so
i'll drag total population on to values
and then
i'll select the city
onto rose and then the state name also
i'll place it on top of city so you have
in the pivot table all the states and
their cities
and on the right you can see the total
population for each of these cities
but our question is we want to find only
for rajasthan and karnataka
now for that what you can do is go to
insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option
and here you have the option to create
or insert a slicer i click on this
and
since we want to slice the table based
on
state that is rajasthan and karnataka
i'll choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for rajasthan and karnataka so
i'll search for
these two
so here we have karnataka so let me
select karnataka first
and i also want for rajasthan
so let me select rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for rajasthan and karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for
rajasthan
moving ahead
now we will see another very interesting
feature of pivot that is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literature from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
i'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and i'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates
so first i'll drag
male literates onto values
followed by
female literates onto values by default
it has summed up the mail literals and
female literature value
and also
i want to drag
state column
to rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
i want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is
i'll select any cell
and
i'll right click
and i'll go to show value as
and here i have the option to select
percentage of grand total so i'll select
this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total now if i sort this you will get to
know which state
contributed or has the highest
percentage contribution
so we have maharashtra for male
literates
then we had uttar pradesh in 2011.
if i come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and andaman
and nicobar islands
as those states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
i'll go to so value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also maharashtra
uttar pradesh
then gujarat and all had the
highest percentage contribution to
female literature
so this is another
good feature
to convert your data and seat in terms
of percentage
now moving ahead let's say we want to
find the bottom three cities from each
state that had the lowest female
graduates
we can do that as well i'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on ok
now since i want to see based on
states as well as cities so let me drag
the state name first onto rows
and
let's drag the city column on to rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
i'll drag it on to values
now we have the list of
states and their respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each city
now
first i'll
sort this column i'll right click go to
sort
and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest
now since i want to find the bottom
three cities from each state
i'll come to the cell
right click
go to filter
and select top 10
now i'll
replace to opt-in with bottom
and i want the bottom three
cities from each state
i have my
column selected that is sum of female
graduates
if i click on ok
you can see here
some of the states don't have three
cities so you can see andaman and
nicobar islands has only one city that
is port player while the remaining you
can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so andhra
pradesh had these three in assam we had
nagao then there was de brugar and
silcha
similarly if i come down in haryana we
have palwal kathal and zind
if i come further here you can see for
karnataka this gangavati this rani benue
and the scholar similarly you can see
for kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example i'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items
calculated fields are formulas that can
refer to other fields in the pivot table
calculated fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value fields a calculated field's
name may proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here
we have a sales table that has columns
like the items which has different
fruits and vegetables
and those have been categorized as
fruits and vegetables we have the price
per kg and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field so your sales
column is going to be
the product of price per kg
and quantity so let me show you how you
can do that with the help of a pivot
table
i'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit ok
now
if you see on the top
under pivot table analyze
and under calculations we have the
option fields items and sets
if i click on this drop down i get the
option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field i click on this
i'll give my field name as sales
and
i'll select my formula
i'll first click on
price per kg and hit insert field
i'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol
and then i'll double click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
i'll click on add
and i click on ok
if you see here
there's a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table our original table is the
same but here we have added
a calculated field which is present only
in the pivot table list
now we can use this
it has already taken it under values
now let's say i want to find the sum of
sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here
we have our category fruit and we have
our category vegetable
and under that we have different
items like apple apricot banana
similarly in vegetables we have broccoli
this carrots corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create
a calculated field in a pivot table
now this one more good feature that
excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so i'll show you how to do that
if i go to insert
here i have the option of recommended
charts
click on this
excel
gives me some default charts which you
can use
let's say i'll select this
let me drag it
a bit to the right
here you can see i'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice
bar chart that excel has created this is
called a pivot chart now here you can
see the category fruits and vegetables
and the different fruits and vegetables
or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
sales
if you see
from the graph
guava made the highest amount of sales
now if i sort this
let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava made the
highest amount of sales now since i
sorted and changed my pivot table
the pivot chart also automatically gets
updated
similarly there are other charts also
that you can create let's go to the
insert tab
and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on ok
so here is our pie chart and each pie
represents
a certain item
and the pie that has the highest area
represents
it had the highest amount of sales in
this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first i'll
click on my pivot table go to insert
and under recommended charts let's now
select a
line chart
if i hit ok
move it to the right so this is a line
chart
you can see it starts
from guava
which had the highest amount of sales
then it
drops
and in the x axis you can see the
different items
similarly when it starts with the
vegetables broccoli made the highest
amount of sales with
2800 rupees
and our lowest was
eggplant at 900 rupees
for fruits papaya sold the least at 700
rupees
let's take another chart i'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical column chart
like this
this is an horizontal
bar chart now you can always increase
and decrease the size of these charts
let's
explore
a last chart let's take the area chart
for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the
line chart it starts with guava which
had the highest amount of sales
similarly papaya under fruits had the
lowest amount of seals under vegetables
it was
broccoli
and finally eggplant made the lowest
amount of sales under vegetable now
let's go to our first sheet and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for people tables in excel so we had our
data
this is
2011 census data from india we had the
different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literature female literates male
literates we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding how to
create a simple pivot table
where we calculated the total population
for each state and sorted it in
descending order
we found that maharashtra uttar pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then
we saw
another pre-vote table where we
calculated the total sum of literatures
in each city belonging to a certain
state so you can see we had the
different state names and
the cities under each state
then we saw another feature where you
could calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that delhi
greater mumbai and bangalore but the top
cities with highest number of female
graduates
next
we saw how to use slicer in a pivot
table so we sliced our table based on
rajasthan karnataka state and saw the
total population for all the cities in
rajasthan and karnataka
in the next sheet
we
explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literature from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates and one
thing marked that some of the states did
not have three cities for example
andaman had only one city that was sport
player but the others we found out the
bottom three cities that had the lowest
female graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table
so we saw how to create a
calculated field called sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw
there's a column chart we also saw or
looked at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart
similarly we saw how to create a pie
chart as well
in this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email ids
in the comments section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards
an advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo
for creating our dashboards we'll be
using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random
it was not validated though we have
applied certain transformations to the
data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if i go on top you can see
this data set has
17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have middle east and
north africa there's north america
asia
sub-saharan africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits etc
then we have the representatives name or
you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales channel column so
there are basically two channels
whether the item was sold offline or
online
next we have the order priority column
now here c stands for critical
then we have h which is for high
priority orders then we have m for
medium priority orders and finally we
have l which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column
then we have the order id the ship date
next we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column
this is the price at which
each product was sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally
we have created two more columns that is
order year and then we have
order month now these two columns were
actually generated using the power query
features
so we use the order date column which is
this column and extracted order year and
order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for revenue by order
year revenue by year and region revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate pivot tables and
po charts and format them to make them
look more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
i'll click on a cell in my data set
and then i'll go to the insert tab here
we have the option to select the pivot
table
i click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next i want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet and let's just click on ok
there you go
so we have a new sheet where i can place
my pivot table
so first
i need to find the total revenue
generated by each year so what i'll do
is i'll drag my order year column
under rows
and then
i'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see i have my pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order year from 2010
to 2017
now
based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so i'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts i
click on this
now actually i want a line chart so i'll
click on line here and select ok
there you go
so we have successfully created our
first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first
let me delete
these so i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the
buttons present on the chart
now
let me go ahead and edit the chart title
so the title i want is total revenue
i'll type it down
by year
all right next
let's do a few more transformations
so if i click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines legend and others
okay
so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total legend is gone
now let me add access titles so we label
our x axis and y axis
so here under x axis
i can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis i'll put
revenue
okay now you can move
a bit
all right
now
let me select this chart style option
and go to colors first
here
i'll select
yellow color
okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
i want
this style
okay
now
you can also add
data
labels so i'll just click on data labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if i click on this arrow
here i have more options
if i scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
i'll expand this
and under category
i'll select custom
now here
we'll give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so i'll write if
my revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
99 000
let me make sure there are 6
9's here so one two three four five and
six okay we are good to go
i'll close the bracket
i'll give a hash
give to commas
so if the revenue is greater than
9 lakhs 99 000
i'll put it in the format of millions so
within double quotes i'll write m
i'll give a semicolon
followed by another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be
0 million
let me click on add
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data
and you see here we have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and
adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up
i'll delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions
for example if you see here in 2010 the
total revenue generated was nearly 175
million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011
then the revenue constantly grew from
2011 till
2014 it reached 195 million
and after
2014 it again came down to
180 million and the revenue dropped
significantly between 2016 and 2017
in 2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet
so i'll write it as
revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
i'll click on any cell
go to insert and select pivot table
i just click ok so that my pivot table
is placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue
by each year and region so first of all
let's drag
region to
columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows
and then
i'll select total revenue on to values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly if you see for 2013
this was the total revenue generated in
europe
and
we have for other years as well
now let's
create a line chart based on this pivot
table so i'll select any cell in the
pivot table i'll go to insert
and i'll click on recommended charts
from this list i'll select my line chart
and click on ok
there you go
so we have our next
pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the
sub-saharan african region
in 2012
sub-saharan africa made the
highest amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for north america has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for
europe
this was the revenue trend between 2010
and 2017.
so if you see here in 2011 the sales
were at this level then it significantly
dropped in 2012
then in 2013
there was a huge spike and then and
again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these
line charts
now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the
field buttons present on the chart
and we'll also
delete the legend alright now
let me just reduce the size of the chart
next
we'll
add a chart title
so
we'll
give the title as revenue
by
year-end
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of millions
so i'll right click on this axis
and i'll select format axis
i'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down let me scroll again
under category i'll select custom
and
we'll use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can
reduce the font size or increase the
font size let me just show you suppose
you want to increase the font size of
the chart title so you just select it
and from here you can either reduce or
you can increase you can see now it's 12
if you want you can make it 16.
similarly you can also edit the
access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this
so let me show you how to do it
i'll go to my data sheet
i have my cell selected
i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table
let me just click on ok
all right
so for this
i'll select
my region onto rows
and then
i'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column
all right so here we have the pivot
table ready now based on this pivot
table
let's create our pivot chart so i'll go
to recommended charts and if you see
below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the
preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on ok
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is
the bars represent the total revenue
which is this column
now
the line represents
the total
cost
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next
we'll add
data labels so i'll click on data labels
here
okay so these are the
data labels for
the bars or
the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so i'll click on this arrow go
to more options
if i scroll down
i have number
from here i'll select custom and
i'll choose
my type that is
in millions all right so you can see we
have formatted our
data
next thing we'll add
a chart title
so here i'll write as
revenue
by
a region
it's actually
revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well i'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet also i am going to rename it as
revenue
by
year
and region
so this
makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority
and for this we are going to create a
pie chart
so let's go to the data sheet
and create our pivot table first
i click on ok
now
i'll select order priority under rows
and under values i'll select
total revenue
so this is a
very simple pivot table so you have your
order priority so c is for critical h is
for high l is for low and m is for
medium now based on this
let's create a pie chart
so i'll go to recommended charts and
here you have
pie chart
i want to select
this 3d type of pie chart
and i'll click on ok all right so we
have our pie chart ready let me just
resize it
and from here i'll remove the fill
buttons
and i also don't need the legend so i'll
delete this as well
all right now let's give a chart title
so this is going to be
revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels i'll check this option
okay
now let's again format this in terms of
millions
so here
i'll click on the last option i'll go to
numbers
under category i'll select custom
and
my type is going to be in terms of
millions there you go
let me close this
i will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue
by
i'll just put op which stands for order
priority
all right
now
let's create our horizontal bar chart
i'll go to insert
click on pivot table
and select ok
so i want my revenue based on different
countries so i'll select country and put
it under rows
and then
i'll choose total revenue and place it
under values
so here you have the different country
names we have afghanistan this albania
let me scroll down you have bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have czech
republic there's estonia france gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have india there's jamaica italy and
all the way to the bottom if you go we
have new zealand this netherlands
philippines portugal
we also have
singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the uae united states of america
zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
so based on this pivot table let's
create our pivot chart
so i'll go to insert and select
recommended charts
from here
i'm going to select the column chart you
can see the preview here and let me
click on ok
all right
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and
the revenue for each of the countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart
so first of all i'll delete
the field buttons okay
and let me also remove the legend
here i'll write
revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so i'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
i'll select
style 6
okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally
we create another report which is going
to be part of our revenue dashboard and
this is
revenue by items so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this
we have cosmetics vegetables cereal
fruits this cloth snacks households and
other products as well
so let's check the revenue for each of
these items
so we'll continue the same drill i'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time i'm going to drag
item type under rows
and
we'll have the total revenue under
values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so you can see
here office supplies made the highest
amount of revenue
followed by household then cosmetics
and fruits
made the lowest amount of revenue
i'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts
this time i'm going to create a bar
chart so this is how my bar chart is
going to look like
i'll select ok
alright
now let's format this chart a bit
i'll delete the field buttons
and i'll delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to
change the
color of the bars so i've selected all
the bars i'll go to my home tab
and here let's say i want to select
green color
all right
i've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
14
and i'll remove the
bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
items cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
i'll create a new sheet
and first thing i'm going to do is
i'll click on the view tab and
uncheck gridlines so this will remove
the gridlines present in the worksheet
next
i'm going to insert an image
so we'll have a background image
on our dashboard
so the way to do is i'll go to the
insert tab and under illustrations
i have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so i'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
i'll go to desktop and here i have a
folder called
excel dashboard files
and i'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image
now let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so i'll hit shift and i'll drag it
all right
so you can see i have successfully
added a background image if you want you
can still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so i'll click
on insert and here
i have the option to select a text box
so
i'll click on a text box and
i'm going to place a text box in the
middle
and i'm going to name this text box as
excel
revenue dashboard
on
sales
i'll
centralize it
let's do some more formatting so i'll
select this text box on the top you can
see
shape format
here
i'm going to expand this
shape fill
and i'll select no fill
so
my text box is transparent now and i'll
also remove the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and i'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to
britannica bold
and i'll increase the size to let's say
30
all right i'll just
drag the
text box i'll make the text as white
instead of black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now
if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard
so i'll go to insert and i'll click on
illustrations again
and select
pictures
i'm going to add
this to pictures which is of a store and
a cart
to make it look
visually appealing
so i'll
place the icons
here
and similarly let me just copy it
and i'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so i'll
hit
ctrl v to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see i have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts our
column charts the combo charts this pie
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and
format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered
so let's adjust the
labels let me bring this down
similarly i'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right
this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the
white background from each of the charts
and make it transparent so let me show
you how to do it so i'll select this
chart
then i'll right click
and go to
format chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called no fill so if i select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now
similarly let me also remove the grid
lines so i'll select the gridlines and
hit delete so you have also removed the
gridlines from here
now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so i'll select this chart
go to format
and here
i'll go to shape outline and i'll select
no outline
you see this
so we have our total revenue by year
which is a line chart and this is
completely transparent now now what i'm
going to do is
i'll place this chart over a box
so i'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so i'll
click on illustrations and here i'll
choose a shape
and let me select a rectangle
so i'll just
create a rectangle here
all right
and now
what i'll do is
i'll select this and bring this to front
i'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and i'll place this
shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first i'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and
let me increase the transparency so i'll
right click and go to format shape
here i'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25
or let's say
20
all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the access labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better
now we'll just
adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so i'll go to shape
outline and i'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart
let's just
pull this a little up
all right
now we'll add
this blue background to all the other
charts so we'll first add the background
make it transparent and then we'll
convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible
so
for the time being i'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens
we have nicely formatted our dashboard
so
i've added a few logos for
each of the
charts you can see the logos here so for
revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the
labels in terms of millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year and region are all
formatted in terms of millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by revenue in terms of
millions
so the way to do is you can select this
graph
right click and go to format access
here if i scroll down
you have numbers
and
under category i'll select
custom then i'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and
you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to our
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add
date columns so if you want to see what
was the amount of sales or revenue
generated on a particular year or a
particular month you can do that using a
timeline
so
i'll select one of the charts
and then
either you can go to the insert tab and
here you can see under filters we have
slices and timeline
or
if you go to the
pivot chart analyze tab
here also you have
insert slicer and timeline option
so i'll select insert slicer here first
now it's giving me the list of
fields present in the
data set
so i'll select
country
region
and let's say
we want to
know by item type and sales channel so
these are going to be my four
slicers i'll click on ok
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values on the region we have asia
this europe north america and others
similarly we have the different country
names for country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slices to a dashboard so what
i'll do is
i'll right click
on this option
and i'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables so let me
check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on ok
all right now that we have connected
one of our slicers will now connect the
other
remaining slicers
so i'll right click on this go to report
connections
and i'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on ok
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
i'll go to report connections
and let me select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have
the item type so i'll right click
go to report connections and then i'll
select
all my pivot tables
and let's hit ok
all right now let me just
organize this a bit so i'll place my
pivot tables
to the right
i'll just reduce the size
let me scroll
down i'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
i'll add my final slicer that is sales
channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be
the profit dashboard i'll show you how
to add a timeline
all right
now i have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for
an item type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here and
all your charts
so the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for
beverages only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for
beverages item type
if i scroll down
now this chart represents the
revenue that was generated in each of
the countries only for item type
beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
india
so i have selected india here
and now you can see
my graph has changed only for
country india
you can see here it is showing only for
india now
now similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to
know the revenue generated
based on sales channel so we have two
sales channel that is offline and online
suppose you want to know the revenue
generated offline so i'll just
select
offline you can see
the values have changed so these were
the revenues generated for each of the
items only for offline
if you
see here
now these were all the
offline sales for the different regions
so this is
our entire
excel revenue dashboard on sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added
different icons then we formatted the
labels also
next we added
slicers
and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this
sheet as
revenue dashboard i'll write rev
dashboard okay
now
we'll move to our data sheet and
start creating our pivot tables and
pivot charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table
so
i'll create
a new worksheet
this time i'm going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so i'll drag my total profit column
to values
and
my order year to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to
get an idea
as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since i have
sorted this data in descending order so
2014
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
i'll just do ctrl z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my po chart so i'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
i'll click on ok
let me close this
similarly we are going to
edit this chart now so first i'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart
and i'll
rename the chart title as
total
profit
by year
next i'm going to remove the legend so
i'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
i'll go to style
and
this time
i'm going to select
my style type
okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have
this yellow color
next let me add the
data labels so again if you see here
this is not formatted properly
so let's go ahead and format the
data labels
so i'll click on number
and i'll select custom here
and the type i'm going to select is in
millions
and i'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next
we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this i am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so i'll
go to insert and i'll click on pivot
table
let me click on ok
since i want the country name so i'll
select country under rows and then i
have
my total profit under values
the next thing i'm going to do is i'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then
i'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
i'm going to select this pivot table
go to the design tab
here we have subtotals and grand totals
i'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again i'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right
now we want to create a
map out of this the way to do is
i'm going to
select my data
copy it
i'll go on top
and i'll paste it here
using this data i can create my field
map now so i'll go to insert
here we have the option to create a
field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
i can expand this
now as you can see
our map has a color scale which comes
from light gray color to dark blue color
so the countries that are in gray or you
can say light blue
have the lowest amount of profit while
the regions or the countries that have
been shaded in
dark color
a dark blue color have highest amount of
profit
i will go ahead and delete this
scale
okay
next
we need to connect this
map to the original data source so what
i'll do is
i'll right click on this map and i'll go
to select data
here instead of the previous range i'll
give my
new range now so
my new range
will be my original pivot table that i
had created
i'll go on top and click on ok
so we have our
map ready now
now if you want you can change the
color of the shade so i'll just go to
colors
and let's say we'll keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made
least amount of profit
okay
now moving on
next
we want to create
a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel
so for this we are going to create
another line chart
so i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so i'll select
new worksheet
here
since i want to know the profit by year
first of all i'll drag my order year
column to rows
and then i'll choose my total profit
column under values
next i'm going to select my sales
channel under columns
there you go so we have our pivot table
here
now based on this pivot table let me
create my po chart so i'll go to
recommended charts
and i'm going to create a line chart
i close this
you see here
based on this
chart you can tell
the profit generated with
online
sales were actually
lower than that of offline so here the
blue line represents offline profit and
the orange line represents online profit
if you mark clearly
in year 2012 the online profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
i'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and
add
a chart title so i'll write
profit
by
year
and
sales
channel
okay
so this is my
second report
before moving ahead let me just
rename this sheet so i'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say sc for sales channel
okay
moving ahead
now i want to
create a pie chart based on a pivot
table that will show the profit by sales
channel only so this is going to be a
simple pie chart so i'll first
go to insert click on pivot table and
click on ok
so i'll drag my sales channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table
now let's create our pivot chart which
is going to be a pie chart let me
explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so i'm going to select a donut
chart here i click on ok
let's
edit this chart i'll remove the field
buttons let me now remove the legend as
well
i'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
i'm going to
format this label
i'll select the category as custom
and my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
i'll write
profit
by
let's say c which stands for sales
channel
cool
finally
i'm going to create a report that will
show the revenue and profit by items
so i'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time i'll choose my
total profit under values
and will also have the revenue column
so i'll put my revenue at the top
then
i'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table
let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the orange line represents
the total profit
i'll click on ok
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title
i'll name it as
revenue
and
profit
by items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use
for our profit dashboard
next let's create a new sheet
and we'll get started with building a
dashboard
so i'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
we'll continue with the previous drill
so
first of all let's go to
the view tab and remove the grid lines
now
we'll
insert a background image
like we did for our revenue dashboard so
i'll go to insert
under illustrations i'll click on
pictures and select this device
i'm going to have the same background
i'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization
let's just
drag this
a bit to the right
we'll adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard
so here you can see i have brought my
revenue dashboard
and i'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
i'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center all right
the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
excel
profit dashboard instead of revenue
now
we'll copy each of the charts that we
just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard
so let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the
adjustment copy this as well
similarly i'll bring the other three
charts on to my sales dashboard
okay so here on my profit dashboard i
have added all the charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
i've also
made some formatting for example i've
reduced the size of the chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so i'll
select
the first chart i'll right click and
i'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill i'll select no fill
next i'm going to remove the grid lines
so i'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so i'll go to design
actually format and i'll remove the
outline
next i'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and i'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and i'll bring this to front
and i'll move this
to the back
next i'm going to change the font color
all to white
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
i'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here
i have my first chart ready
the same i am going to do for the rest
of the charts
okay so now you can see here
i have formatted all my charts i have
also added
a blue background you see here i have
also formatted the
y labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit
similarly here i have added the data
labels this is for revenue
some of the charts also have the data
legends so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
i've also formatted the
map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our
slicers as well as timeline
first let me show you how to add a
timeline
so i'll
select one of the charts
and i'll go to insert
under insert i have the option to create
a timeline
so i'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so excel has only
shown us two columns so i'm going to
create my timeline based on order date
so i'll select my order date column and
i'll click on ok
you can see here this is called a
timeline i can expand this
now this timeline is based on months now
if i
scroll this timeline you can see here i
have
my
order year 2010 and i have all the 12
months similarly we have for 2011 then
we have for 2012
all the way till 2017.
now you can filter this in terms of
years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so i have
years from 2010 till 2017.
let me just squeeze this
and i'll place it somewhere here on the
right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so i
have selected one of the charts
under insert i'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which
i want to create slicers
so i'll create a region
let me also select
country
let's say i want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and i'll click on ok
so here i have created three slicers
let me
first
resize it and
i'll place it
on the right
similarly i'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
i'll
resize this and i'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
i have to connect all the slicers and
the timeline
to
the pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so i am going
to click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here
i am going to
select all the pivot tables that are
related to profit
so here i have selected four and i need
one more which is
pivot table number 10 i click on ok
similarly let's create or connect my
region filter to all the pivot tables so
i right click
go to report connections
here i'll
choose all my pivot tables which are
based on profit
i'll click on ok let's do it for the
country slicer as well
click on ok
and similarly i'll connect my
timeline as well i'll go to report
connections
and i'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then i'll click on ok
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so i am
selecting one of the pivot charts
i'll go to insert click on slicer
and i'll select
sales channel and hit ok
so i have my sales channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on ok
now
let me just bring it here all right
the next thing i want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017.
now suppose
you want to know the profit that was
generated in the year 2012 so i'll just
click on
this range and now you can see our
charts only so information for 2012. so
this dot represents there was
51 million profit in the year 2012.
similarly you can see here
the profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit
each of these countries made in 2012.
if i scroll down you can see
the revenue and profit by items
now
if i select
another year let's say 2013 i can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it
went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
excel has prompted all right so this is
how you can use a timeline
now as i said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
i'll
send it back to the place where it was
and i'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose
you want to check the profit made by
different representatives you can select
them one by one
let's say adam churchill
this is the
profit generated by
adam churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer
let me just bring this to the middle
and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart i'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly
okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say united kingdom you can
select united kingdom so this is the map
of united kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
united kingdom
and
below you can see
the revenue and profit
for all the items that was sold in
united kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item made the highest
amount of profit in
united kingdom
now you can also select
multiple countries let's say i want to
know for france as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now i
have
united kingdom and france selected and
the other charts present in my dashboard
change accordingly
now i have my
country selected as india you can see
the map of india here
and these were the respective profit
values now one thing to note here is
this is actually
not millions that should be in k that is
thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually k and
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is
on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables in
pivot charts and then we formatted our
pivot charts based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing
you can also change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes
so here you can select different themes
currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select
another theme let's say facet
you see
the colors have changed and it looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic
you see
our chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore one more theme let's say
this time i am going to choose
depth
and
this is more
of a
green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my revenue
dashboard and see how it looks
there you go
so since we changed our theme even our
revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and
play with different themes colors fonts
and effects
all right
so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts and then we learnt how to add
slicers and connected to different pivot
tables
and we filtered our data to see
revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more
let's quickly see
some more
examples of doing data analysis using
excel and for that we can
use
some inbuilt add-ins which can be added
to our excel sheet so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive
analytics or descriptive analysis on
your data say for example getting your
descriptive statistics such as your mean
median mode and so on so we can do that
and we can use excel for it so for
example you can if you are given some
data say i have temperature price of ice
cream units sold and i would want to
have descriptive statistics on this what
i can do is i can click on file
and here in file you can click on
options and within options click on
add-ins
now within add-ins you have excel
add-ins which is selected here so click
on say go for example and that shows
what add-ins are available and you can
choose which ones are you interested in
so for example i have chosen analysis
tool pack
and solver add-in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your excel so if you click on data
so here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance
descriptive statistics you have
histogram so let's click on descriptive
statistics click on ok now this one
basically asks your input range so while
your cursor is blinking here
also it is
said
grouped by so let's give it a range so
for example i will say say temperature
now if i do this and i have selected the
heading just look at that
and now you need an output range so
let's just select this
and then you can have your cursor
blinking in here
let's select save fields here
and this is where i would want the
output now it also said what options do
you want so it has output range we can
then select summary statistics
confidence level so i will say summary
statistics is what i'm interested in say
okay
and this says input input range contains
non-numeric data now why is that because
we chose temperature the heading also so
click on ok and here we will alter the
range
so this one
is our range should be
only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on ok
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here
i could basically
given a value for this so i can say
temperature
and that's my descriptive statistics for
temperature might be i can just do some
formatting
and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here
now similarly we can do it for price of
ice cream so what we need is
we need to basically
go for data
data analysis
descriptive statistics say okay
now you need to give a range so here i
will
change my range to these values output
range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on ok
and this says output range will
overwrite existing data press ok to
overwrite data in range
i will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do
we need to give a new range so let's
select our new range which is here
and now click on ok
so now we get the values which is for
your price of ice cream so again we can
basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier i can select this i can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this
now i can go into data and i can go into
data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this b2 to b8
and this one which is h6 to h19 we would
want to shift it
might be two columns up so might be i
can just say h5 and i can manually
change it to h17
and let's say okay
and
we will basically get this and i can get
rid of this so i can have it in the same
range
so similarly so this one will have to be
renamed and i can basically say price of
ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for
my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data
we can click on data analysis
descriptive statistics so we need to
give the range correctly so this time
our range changes to units sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay
if
we were selecting the heading so let's
do it in this way so in my range
in my range
let me empty this
i can basically select this which we
know has non-numeric data in the first
row say for example i'll say labels in
first row i'm interested in summary
statistics and this range will now have
to be changed from h
to basically something like
j
so let's say j
and let's select these values so that
should take care of things
and now you see you have your units sold
you did not have to manually rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis
using data analysis here
you can basically get your descriptive
statistics for your columns and then you
can do whatever needed formatting you
need
to basically make your data look
in a
good way
now
let's look at one more example of data
analysis
where we may want to look at the
frequency of values or frequency of
values occurring in a range of values so
for example if you have been given
temperatures you have been given some
pins where you would want to identify
how many values fall into the range of 0
to 20
20 to 30 30 to 40 40 to 50 and the
easiest way to do that would be creating
histogram now histogram is usually used
for data analysis where you would want
to look at different variables or say
features for example temperature is one
such feature
might be there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see
if
the increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be a sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find a relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to
first do analysis on one single variable
look at the frequency of values might be
also look at the defects and for which
we can use something like pareto chart
so we can go for histogram and that
basically gives us the frequency of
values now how do we do that so we have
already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay
now i have already selected input range
so if you see here my input range is
temperature which is also with the
headings
and i have bin range which is basically
the range of values so for example i can
select this and that's my bin range i am
selecting
or the option labels because i'm using
the first
row which has the heading such as
temperature and pins now we need to give
a output range so for example let's say
i would want my data here
and that becomes my output range so you
can have a sorted histogram or basically
a pareto chart
so if that's what you're interested in
looking at the frequencies for your
different ranges and here i'm also
selecting chart output because i would
want to have a visual histogram which
gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on ok
and now you get your bins
so it basically tells you frequency of
values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20
so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we can
basically say there is 120 here with the
20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20 then you have 20 to 30 which shows
three values so might be in that case i
can say 26
is one thing then i can say 30
that's the second one
and then basically i can look at 22
so
basically this one does not select 20 as
the lower range but it basically selects
30 as the higher range so i do see 20 to
30 there are three entries similarly we
can see values for 40 and 50
and since we have selected pareto or
sorted histogram that shows in a
descending order what is the highest
frequency of values within a particular
range
so that shows me highest frequency is 5
and then you have 3 and 3 and then 2. so
this is how we can create a histogram
and we can perform analysis on a single
variable
now
as discussed earlier as i said sometimes
we may
be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables
are they linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on and for that we can use the
correlation
of your data analysis add-in so for
example you want to find out correlation
of temperature and units sold and what
we can do is
we can find out that using a formula so
for example if i search for something
like
co
relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select
the range of values for temperature and
then i am interested in finding out the
correlation of temperature in units sold
so let's select this
and that basically gives me a range of
values it gives me the correlation value
which is 0.2859
say okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of value so here we are interested
in temperature and price of ice cream so
let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that
let's close our bracket and here we have
the correlation value of temperature and
the price of ice cream similarly you may
be interested in finding out temperature
and units sold like what we have done
earlier
so we can do the same thing based on
function so this is same as
correlation of temperature in units sold
so i can get rid of this one now how do
i do it using the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into data
we need to go click on data analysis and
here you have the option called
correlation let's select this now that
basically needs an input range
so we need the range now i might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
i've selected all the columns here
we will say group by columns obviously
we need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on ok
and that basically gives you
that basically gives your
correlation of your different variables
and what are the values and we can check
these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically
temperature
and price of ice cream
and that basically shows me 0.96149
you have temperature and units sold so
you have 0.2859
now you can also look at units sold
and say for example price of ice cream
you can look at
these particular values so if i would be
interested in finding out
what is the relationship between these
variables i can easily find using
correlation so i could be basically
writing in a formula here and selecting
what are the cells so here we were
selecting a2
and c
here we were selecting a and b now might
be i'm interested in price of ice cream
and units sold and if that's what i'm
interested in then i will give a range
of b2 to b8 c2 to c8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values
so it's very simple in excel and you can
use either the data analysis tab
and
get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means
might be i'm interested in range of
values i'm interested in seeing a sample
of values for
a particular period
which could be basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if i go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which i see here might be i want
to see
say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or i
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly i would want to pick
up say three temperature values now how
do i do it so for example here i have
seven values now if i go
for periodic sampling
the sample
or periodic sample value which i need to
give has to be lesser than the total
input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here
and let's go for data analysis so we can
go for sampling here click on ok and
that needs a range of values so we will
select a2 to a8 now i could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case i can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row
now here we can go for
number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
i have seven values so what if i select
five
so for example if i say five
that means
i could just get one value
so basically when i'm saying 5 out of 7
so that's just giving me out of 5 i want
one value so i can then just give an
output range so here i can basically
select this cell i'll say okay and now
you see
it just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is i have
said five it has given me the fifth
value that's your periodic sampling so
for example we want more values so let's
reduce this period
to might be 2
which basically gives me every second
value so i can basically say for example
2 and say ok
and then
say ok so that shows me
26
then you have 35
then you have 40 and then well this one
does not have any more values so that's
your periodic sampling now if you go for
random sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling i'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly i want three values
and i can just give this say okay
and then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this
values of temperature so we can use
excel to do a simple sampling and we can
choose whether we would want to go for
periodic sampling or
random sampling since this is data
analysis with python
we got to ask the question why python
for data analytics i mean there's c plus
plus there's java there's
dot net from microsoft why do people go
to python for it
so the number of reasons one it's easy
to learn with simple syntax
you don't have a very high type set like
you do in java and other coding so it
allows you to kind of
be a little lazy in your programming
that doesn't mean that it can't be set
that way and that you don't have to be
careful it just means you can spin up a
code much quicker in python the same
amount of code to do something in python
a lot of times is one two or three or
four lines
where when i did the same thing say in
java i found myself a 10 12 13 20 lines
depending on what it was
it's very scalable and flexible
so there's our flexibility because you
can do a lot with it and you can easily
scale it up you can go from something on
your machine
to using
pi spark under the spark environment and
spread that across hundreds if not
thousands of servers across terabytes of
data or petabytes of data so it's very
scalable
there's a huge collection of libraries
this one's always interesting because
java has a huge collection of libraries
c has a huge collection of libraries dot
net does and they're always in
competition to get those libraries out
uh scala for your spark
all those have huge collections
libraries this is always changing
but because python's open source you
almost always have easy to access
libraries that anybody can use you don't
have to go check your licensing and have
special licensing like you do in some
packages
graphics and visualization they have a
really powerful package for that so it
makes it easy to create nice displays
for people to read
and community support because python is
open source it has a huge community that
supports it you can do a quick google
and probably find a solution for almost
anything you're working on
python libraries let's bring it together
we have data analytics and we have
python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics
in the big five players are numpy
pandas matplot library scipy which is
going to be in the background so we're
not going to talk too much about the
scientific formulas inside pi and psi
kit
so numpy supports n-dimensional arrays
provides numerical computing tools
useful for linear algebra and fourier
transform
and you can think of this as just a grid
of numbers
and you can even have a grid inside a
grid
or data it's not even numbers because
you can also put words and characters
and just about anything into that array
but you can think of a grid and then you
can have a grid inside a grid and you
end up with a nice three-dimensional
array
if you want to talk three-dimensional
array you can think of images you have
your three channels of color four if you
have an alpha and then you have your xy
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine
watching a movie well now you have your
movie clips and they each have their x
number of frames and each of those
frames have
x number of x y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your three dimensions for the colors so
numpy is just a great way to work with
in-dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas
useful for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame
and if you're working with big data and
you're working in spark or any of the
other major packages out there you
realize that the data frame is very
central to a lot of that and you can
look at it as a excel spreadsheet you
have your columns you have your rows or
indexes and
you can do all kinds of different
manipulations of the data within uh
including filling in missiling data
which is a big thing when you're dealing
with large
pools or
lakes of data where they might be
collected differently from different
locations
and matte plot library
we did kick over the sci pi which is a
lot of mathematical computations which
usually runs in the background of the
fur of numpy and pandas although you do
use them they're useful for a lot of
other things in there but the matte plot
library that's the final part that's
what you want to show people and this is
your plotting library in python several
toolkits extend matplot library
functionality
there's like a hundred different
toolkits to
matplot library which range from uh how
to properly display star constellations
from astronomy there's a very specific
one built just for that all the way to
some very generic ones we'll actually
add seaborne in when we do the labs in a
minute several toolkits extend matplot
library functionality and it creates
interactive visualization
so there's all kinds of cool things you
can do as far as just displaying graphs
and there's even some that you can
create interactive graphs we won't do
the interactive graphs but you'll see
you'll get a pretty good grasp of some
of the different things you can do in
matplot library
pandas really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
that come off of it there it actually
sits kind of on numpy so if you already
had our numpy array hopefully you've
already gone through the numpy tutorial
one and two so today we're going to
cover what is pandas we'll discuss
series we'll discuss basic operations on
series then we'll get into a data frame
itself basic operations on the data
frame file related operations on a data
frame visualization and then some
practice examples roll up our sleeves
and get some coding underneath there and
let's start with just some real general
what is pandas pandas is a tool for data
processing which helps in data analysis
it provides functions and methods to
efficiently manipulate large data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or hadoop in big data so we're not
talking about big data here but we are
talking about pandas when there is some
connections there's like an interface
going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
big data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column and you have an index and
different that kind of set up and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as a giant excel
spreadsheet that's optimized to run a
larger data on your computer
and then i said it that it's a data
frame so the data structures in pandas
are series one-dimensional arrays and
then we have data frame two-dimensional
array and it really centers around the
data frame the series just happens to be
part of that data frame and here's a
closer look at a pandas series series is
a one-dimensional array with labels it
can contain any data type including
integers strings floats python objects
and more so it's very diverse if you
remember from numpy we studied they had
to be all uniform not in pandas and
pandas we can do a lot more and pen is
actually kind of sits on numpy so you
really need to know both of those if you
haven't done the numpy tutorials and you
can see here we have our index 1 2 3 4 5
and then our data a b c d and e very
straight forward it's just two columns
and we have a nice index label and a
column label for the data and then a
data frame is a two-dimensional data
structure with labels we can use labels
to locate data and you can see here we
had if we go back one we had our index
one two three four five so in each one
of these series they would share the
same index over there the row index so
you have your row index df.index and
then you have a column index df.columns
and this should look like i said this
would be really familiar if you've done
any work with spreadsheets excel so it
kind of resembles that this does make it
a lot easier to manipulate data and add
columns delete columns move them around
same thing with the rows so you have a
lot of control over all of this now
we're of course going to do this in our
jupyter notebook you can use any of your
python editors but i highly suggest if
you haven't installed jupyter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on i
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or ides for editing my python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r.org
and then i always let mine sit on
anaconda
anaconda.com and just real quick we'll
open that up for you oops offline mode
don't show me that again
but you can see here that i have
different tools that i can actually
install in my anaconda including the
jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then i have access to the
environments
and again that's anaconda.com named
after the very large one the largest
world's largest snakes and then jupiter
notebook in this case jupiter.org and
when we're in our i'm going to go in
here to our jupiter notebook and we're
going to go ahead and just do new and a
python3
and this will open up a python3 untitled
folder
so diving right in let's go ahead and
give this a title pandas tutorial and
we'll go up to cell and we'll change the
cell type to mark down so it doesn't
execute it as actual code
one of those wonderful tools when you
have jupyter notebook so you can do
demos with this and let's go ahead and
import
pandas
and usually people just call it pd that
has become such a standard in the
industry so we'll go ahead and run that
now we have our pandas has been imported
into our jupiter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the control plus since it's internet
explorer i can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view oops too big
there we go and whenever you're working
with a new module it's good to check
your version of the module in pandas you
just use the in this case pd dot
underscore underscore version underscore
underscore that's actually pretty common
in most of our python modules there's
different ways to look up the version
but that's one of the more common ones
and we'll go ahead and run that we get
0.23.4
and if we go to the pandas site we see
0.23.4 as the latest release
and of course a reminder that if you're
going to environment you need to install
it so you'll need to pip install pandas
if you're using the pip installer we're
going to close out of that
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
stuff you do in series you can then do
on the whole data set we need to do what
create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query it query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer
right into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go
creating a series from
list
and let's just call this arr equals
and we'll do
0 1 2 3 4. if you remember from our last
one we could easily do
r equals
range of 5 which would be 0 to 4. but
we'll do r equals 0 to 4 and we'll call
this s1 and we'll go pd
and
series is capitalized this one always
throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you've
got to watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do arr
so we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series
and then because we're in jupiter we
don't have to put the print statement we
can just put s1 and it'll print out this
series for us
and let's go ahead and run that and take
a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get 0 index row 0
is 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4. and because it's a
series it doesn't need a title for the
column there's only one column so why
title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created
and let's do a second series
pd and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order
equals oh let's do it this way let's go
index
equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order equals and let's
do one two three four five so instead of
starting with zero we're going to give
it an order starting with one we're
going to run that and we'll go ahead and
print it out down here
s2 and we'll see that we now have an
index of one two three four five and
that represents zero one two three four
in the series and we're still data type
integer 64.
and very common as you're missing with
numpy arrays is we can import our numpy
as np remember that from our numpy
tutorials we can go ahead and create a
numpy out of random with the random
numbers of five
and let's just see what that end looks
like so we see what our number looks
like so we have some nice random float
values here 2.33 so on and this from our
last tutorial the numpy tutorial 1 and
2. and instead of calling it order let's
call it index
and we're going to set our index equal
to a b c d and e
i want to show you that the index
doesn't have to be an integer so it can
be something very different here and
then let's go ahead and create our we'll
just use s2 again and here's our np for
numpy
series capital s
and n is our
np for numpy
pd for pandas there we go switching my
anachronisms so we have pd.series of n
and we want to do our index
equals our index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like s2 is a print it let's
run that
and we can see here we have a nice
series going on a b c d and e for our
indexes so instead of being 0 1 2 3 or 4
we can make this index whatever we want
and you can see the numbers here going
down that we randomly generated from the
number array so we use numpy to create
our panda series right here
and so continuing on with creating our
series this one i use so often we create
a series from a dictionary so we have
our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of one b is two c a
three d four e of five so each one of
those is a key and then a value and then
we're gonna use oh let's use s3 equals
pd for pandas
series
and then we want to go ahead and just do
d in here
print out s3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is one
b is two c is 3 d is 4 e is 5. and it's
still of integer 64 because the actual
data is 1 2 3 4 5 and it's all integer
64 type 64. and the last thing we want
to do in the creating section of our
series is to go ahead and modify the
index because we're going to start
modifying all this data so let's start
with modifying the index of the series
and if you remember let's do a print
this time s1
i'll go ahead and run this and the
reason i did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if i put
s1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take s1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously
the number of objects in our index has
to equal the number of objects in our
data and then because it's the last
variable we can go ahead and just do an
s1 and let's run that and you can see
how we went from zero to zero zero one
two three four as our index we've now
altered it to a b c d and e
so this would be much more readable or
might be representational of a larger
database you're working with
so cool tools we've covered creating a
database based on
a basic array python array we've showed
you how to reset the index
then we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series a numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in
the pandas and then we looked on
changing your index so now we have a new
index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do s1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so i'd usually it doesn't
change s1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals s1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there i'll go ahead and take that out
but just a reminder that it's not
actually changing s1 it's just viewing
s1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append oops before we do
a pen let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the e of
course you can do minus two on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a two here
cde to the end so it starts at the
second one and another way we can do
this is we can do a minus two over here
and that looks at just the last two in
the slice so you can see how easy it is
to slice the data and of course
there's no reason to do this but you
could select all of them
if you wanted to view all of them on
there helps 32 there's not 32 so it's
just going to show the first three there
we go and then we can also append so i
can take and oh let's create another
series and append one to it and if you
remember we had s3 there's our s3 and we
have our s1 we'll go ahead and do s1
and let's go ahead and do
oh let's call it s4
equals s1
a pin
s3 so we're just going to combine those
two into s4
and if we go ahead and print s4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one so very easy to append one
series to the next
and if we're going to append one series
to the next we need to go ahead and drop
or delete one and drop is a keyword for
that and let's just do e our index e and
so if i run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
a b c d there's no e and remember all
these changes if i type in s4 again
you'll see that s4 still has e in it so
this change does not affect the series
unless you tell it to so i'd have to do
like x s4 equals s4.drop e and there's
another way to do that which we'll show
you later on let me just cut this one
out
there we go
all right so we've covered all kinds of
cool tools here we have appending we
have slicing we did all the creating
stuff earlier as you can see here on the
setup how easy it is to manipulate the
series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series let
me go ahead and change this cell to
markdown there we go and run that
so series operations what can we do with
the series and let's start by creating a
couple arrays we'll call it array one
and we'll do zero through seven and
array two six through six seven eight
nine five i don't know i threw the five
on the end let's go ahead and run those
so those load up into jupiter
and uh we'll do this a little backwards
we're going to do s5 equals a panda
series of array two so i'm doing this in
reverse and then when we do s5 you'll
see that we have zero to four it
automatically assigned the index
67895
for our series
and let's go ahead and do the same and
we'll call this s6 and we'll set this
equal to pd series for
our first array and if we do an s6 down
here to print it out
we'll see something similar i got zero
through six
zero one two three four five seven for
the data so those are two series we just
created series six five and 6.
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so i
can do s5 dot add s6 and let's see what
that generates and just a quick thing if
you never use pandas what do you think
is going to happen with the fact that
this only has five different values in
it and this one has seven values
so let's see what that does
and we end up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it
goes oh i can't add this there's nothing
there so it gives us a null return
very different than the numpy that would
have given you an error this instead
tells you there's no value here because
we couldn't generate one so we can
easily add s5 dot add s6 and likewise we
can do s5 dot
sub for subtract s6
and we'll run that and on the add the
subtract and you guessed it we're going
to do multiply and divide next again you
can see there's the null values where it
can't subtract the two because there's
no values there to subtract we can also
do s5 multiply and mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this
and you can you can see how they're
multiplied together and then we can also
do the s5 div three letters again
s6
and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
infinity because we have zero in the
wrong position so it actually gives you
a whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
no off of missing data and since we're
in data science let's do s6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply median sorry for those
who are following the three letters
because median is not three letters and
you can see an s6 is 3.0 and let's do a
print here and we'll do median
or average
s6
and let's print max
comma s6
and just like median there's max value
and if we're going to have a max value
we should also have a minimum value so
let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this and you're
starting to see something that would be
generated like say an r where you're
starting to get your different
statistics we have a median value of 3
max value of 7 and a minimum value of 0.
and what it does when it hits these null
values if there is no values in there
because we could still do that we could
actually you know what let's go up here
and do
let's pick this one we multiplied let's
go s7
equals
i'll go and print the s7 just so i keep
it nice and uniform so i still have my
s7 down there and run it and then i want
to take the s7
because s7 now has
null values and an infinity value and
let's see what happens
this is going to be interesting because
i want to see what it does with infinity
and we end up with a median of 6 maximum
of 27 and minimum of 0. which is correct
it drops those values so when it gets to
there and it doesn't know what to do
with them it just drops those values and
then it computes it on the remaining
data on there so it's important to know
when you're making these computations
you're looking at min and max and median
you're not going to know that there's no
values unless you double check your data
for the null values it's a very
important thing to note on there so just
a real quick
review on there we've done our
created our pd series and we've
gone ahead and done addition subtraction
multiplication division all those are
three letters so sub min div add
and then we looked at median maximum and
minimum so we're going to go ahead and
jump into the next big topic which is to
create a data frame
so now we're going to go from series and
we're going to create a number of series
and bundle them together to make a data
frame
there we go cell type markdown let me go
and run that so we have a nice title on
there it's always good to have a good
title all right so our first data frame
we'll jump in with some stuff that looks
a little complicated we'll break it down
first i'm going to create some dates and
you know what let's just go ahead and do
this i want you to see what that looks
like what i'm creating here i've created
a series of dates pd date range and
we're going to use these for the index
okay so when you look at this you'll see
that it's just basically it comes out
kind of like a basic python list or
numpy array however you want to look at
it with our different dates going down
and we've generated six of them and it's
going to have whatever time it is right
now on your on the thing for the date
for the time that's that time stamp
right there and then you'll see we have
11 19 2008 11 20 11 19 and looking into
the future there so that's all this is
is generating a series of dates that
we're going to use as our index
and this is a pandas command so we have
a date range which is nice that's one of
the tools hidden in there in the pandas
that you can use
and next we're going to use numpy to go
ahead and generate some random numbers
in this case we'll do the
np.random.random in 6 comma 4. you can
look at this as rows and columns as we
move it into the pandas and of course
you could reshape this if you had those
backwards on your data but we want the
six to match the rows and we have six
periods so our indexes should match
along with the rows on there and then
you know before we do the next one let's
go ahead and just print out our numpy
array so you can see what that looks
like here we have it one two three four
by one two three four five six four by
six
so it's a nice little setup on there and
since working with data frames can be
very visual let's give our columns we
have four columns and we're going to
give them names a b c and d so now we
have columns on there also and then
let's put this all together in a data
frame and we can actually you know what
let's do this since i did it with
everything else let's go ahead and do
columns and you can see there's our
columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1 equals
pandas dot
data frame and note that the d and the f
are capitalized
series it was just the s and i always
highlight this because you don't know
how many times these things get retyped
when you forget what's capitalized on
there it's a minor thing you'll pick it
up right away if you do a lot of it and
the first thing we want to do is we want
to go ahead and take our numpy array
because that's what we're going to
create our data frame off of is the
numpy array and then we want our index
equal to our dates so there's our index
in there and then we also have columns
equals columns
and then finally let's see what that
looks like now remember we had all the
different data that just looked like a
jumble of data we have our column names
and everything else our numpy array kind
of just a jumble array over there four
by six you could sort of read it but
look how nice this looks i mean this is
you come into a board meeting you're
working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe it's one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is if it's in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like
higher the temperature low of the day
humidity of the day whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one i use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data let me just go down a notch so you
can see all the data on there we have an
animal in this case cat cat snake dog
dog cat snake cat dog we have the age so
we have an array of ages we have the
number of visits and the priority was it
a high priority yes
no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what i want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.nand numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a
the first cat b the second cat c the
snake d the dog and so on so we'll go
ahead and create our labels which we're
going to use as an index
and we'll call this df let's do it this
way we'll call this
df2 equals pd for panda's
data frame
and then we have our data just like we
did before and then we have our index
equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very visual and
easy to read animal age visits priority
and then a through j cats and all your
different animals so on and so on and
then when you do programming a lot of
times it's important to know what the
data types are so we can simply do df2
d types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go df2
[Music]
head
and if we print that out the df2 head
returns the first five and we can change
this you don't have to do five you might
want to just look at the top two maybe
you want to look at
let's see let's do six so maybe we'll
look at just the top six in the database
in your data frame
and you can actually this creates
another data frame so i could have a df3
equal to df2 and this now takes the df2
and just the first six values
so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tail it's the same thing
df tail you can look at the last we'll
just do the tell which by default does
five the last five and of course you can
just look at the last three of those
real quick just to see what's at the end
of the data and this is i need to tell i
love doing the tell of one because i'll
have like the index or something like
that and it will just show me the last
whatever the last entry was looking at
stock values and i might want to look at
just the last five days of the stock
values i can do that with the data frame
tail
and some other key things to look up
are the index so we can do df2 dot index
and i want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if i put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there
so we do df2.index
there's also
columns so we can go ahead and let's do
a let's print this
remember the first one is not going to
show unless i print it and then df2
column so now we can see we have our
indexes
and we have our columns listed here
df2.column animal age visits priority it
tells you what kind of object it is
or what kind of data type it is and
they're both object
and then finally df2 dot
values and again there's no brackets on
the end of df2.values
because this is an actual object it's
not a callable function so we'll go
ahead and run that and it creates just
displays a nice array a very easy way to
convert this back to a numpy array
basically so before i go into the next
section let's just take a quick look at
what we covered so far with the data
frame we came up here we created our
data frame we did it from a numpy array
first
setting the columns and the index the
index is setting it up is the same as
when we set up the series so that should
look very familiar so is the whole
format the numpy array the index dates
and the columns columns and remember in
our numpy array we're looking at row
comma column so six rows four columns is
how that reads in the data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date
data underneath that column and then age
with that data visits that data priority
that data and then of course we added
our labels in there for our index so
there's no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with a data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up d type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick
we also did index and columns and values
and note these don't have the brackets
on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go and describe
the data so we have
df2.described to do that and we're going
to manipulate it in just a minute but
let's just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits
so looking at our data from up above let
me just go all the way up here
animal age visits priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value
25 or in this group 50 75 and your
maximum value so this should look
familiar as a data science setup with
your describe for a quick look at your
data frame data so let's start
manipulating this data frame moving
stuff around and we'll start with
transposing and it is simply capital t
for transpose
and when we run that it flips the
columns and the indexes so now the
indexes are all column names and the
columns are all indexes animal age
visits priority
so if we had come in here with our data
shaped wrong up above where we had a
four by
we can quickly just swap it if we had it
backwards not a big deal and we can also
sort our data something that you can't
do which is more difficult to do with a
lot of other packages in the data frame
it's really easy to do take our data
frame df2 and we're going to sort
underscore values
by equals age and so when we run this
you'll see the default is ascending so
we have 0.52 2.53 and everything else is
organized so if you look at your indexes
they've been moved around because each
index it moves a whole row not just the
one piece of data is not being sorted so
very quick way to sort by age are
different data in the data frame and in
addition to sorting it we can also slice
the data frame so i could do df2 and
this should look familiar from earlier
we'll just do one
to three so we're going to pull out oops
it does help if i use the df instead of
just d and we're going to pull up just
between 1 and 3. so we have no 0 which
is a we have b which is 2 or b which is
1 and c which is 2. so 1 2 and then it
does not include 3 which is the standard
in python and we can even do something
like this we can combine them which is
always fun because remember this returns
a data frame so if i take df2 dot
sort
values and we'll do by
equals age this is just kind of fun and
then i'm going to slice it
there we go double check my typing and
run it
and now you should see fa because fa are
now 1 and 2 on there so you can very
quickly create a whole string on here
which narrows it you know that you can
sort it then slice it and do all kinds
of fun things with your data frame we'll
just go back to the original one run
there we go and if we can slice it by
row we can also query the data frame so
we can do df2 and this is a little
different because i'm going to create an
array within an array and in this case
we're going to look at oh let's do age
comma
visits
so look at the different format in here
we have one to three so we've done this
by slicing by an integer value and then
on here i've done df2 age comma visits
in an array and when i run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get agent visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is i location
which uses the integer location one
comma three
there's a push in pandas to move to this
particular setup instead of doing just a
regular slice and that's because this
can be confusing when we slice one to
three and then we select agent visits
so there is a push to go ahead and move
to an i location which does the same
thing you can see here bc it's the same
as up above there's also copy command so
we can do df3 equals df2 copy we're just
going to create a straight copy of it
and of course if we do df3
it'll be the same as the df2 on there so
df3 equals df2.copy
and then let's do df3 dot is null so
we're looking for null values
and this will return a nice map and
you'll see that everything is false
except when you go up here under the cat
or h they had a null there and so if we
go down a couple up here also underneath
of let's see the dog okay there's a
bunch of nulls in here there's d up here
so let's look at d down here and you'll
see false true there it is there's our
null value so we can create a quick
chart of null values you can use this to
do other things we can leverage that
null value to maybe take an average or
something and fill those null spaces
with data and we can also modify the
location so here's our df3 location
and notice this is location not i
location ilocation has i for integer
location uses the
in this case the variables on the left
and what we can do on here and we'll go
and just set this equal to
one
five and then let's um i'll pick a spot
let's go back up here where we had let's
do f
a just let's see what are we looking at
oh here we go let's do f and h
and up here f is set to age of 2.0 and
we find out that that's incorrect data
so we go ahead and switch to df3
equal and then we're going to print out
our df3
and if we go to f and h it is now 1.5 so
we're just changing the value in the df3
and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice
and like it returns another data frame
this changes the actual data frame and
that value in the data frame
so we've covered uh location and eye
location is null making a copy here's
our eye location which is equivalent of
a slice
and also selecting columns
so now we want to dive just take a
little detour here and let's look at df3
means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if i run that there's our age
but if i take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal
well those are not integers so it's
really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average i guess you could do a
histogram which probably will look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have
the average or the mean on the age is
3.375
and the mean on visits is 1.9
and let's do df3
visits we'll go and steal the visits
again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we could also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is 1
max
so all that functionality is here
i'll just go back to summing it up and
adding it all together so real quick
we've shown you how to take the series
operations and put them into the data
frame and then we can actually this is
interesting one we can just do df3 sum
run and you'll see the different
summations on there
it just combines them i like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals pd series
and we just put it right in there we
have a c d a a b a c a popped in a null
value
cow and owl i don't know why they picked
cal and al in the background someone
must like those animals and of course we
can just do string if we run that you'll
see
leave the r out we'll get an error but
if we put it in there you'll see that we
have a simple series 0 a 1c 2d and it
automatically indexes it 0 to 8.
and then we can go string dot lower so
when we're talking about
our data frame in this case our data
series string in this case we use the
string
function str and we're going to make it
lower and if we go ahead and put the
brackets on there and you'll see that
we've gone from capital a capital c so
on to abc and baca cba cow al they were
all lower case already and of course if
you want to go lower you can also do
upper we'll go ahead and run that
and you can see we now have a c d a a
baca everything's capitalized except for
the null value which is still null
alright so we looked at a few basic
string you can see that string functions
upper and lower
we're going to jump into a very
important topic i'm even going to give
it its own
header on here because it's such an
important topic what do you do with
missing values
panda has some great tools for that so
we'll dive into those
we'll call we'll work with df4 and if
you remember the df copy from above
we're just going to make a copy of df3
and let's just take a quick look at the
data we're working with oops df3 forgot
the three on there there we go
so here we have our cats snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll give it the value 4. so i
can run in here and you'll see now that
df4 now has where the n a was is filled
with the value of four same thing down
here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so i might do a mean
age
equals df4
and then we want to go ahead and do age
and dot mean
and then i'll do something like this df4
i only want to select the age and i want
to fill that
with the mean
age
i run in there and you'll see that our
df4h now has the means in there
just a quick way of showing you how you
can combine these
let me go back to our original one there
we go and run that
and keeping with good practices df5
equals df three dot copy
and we'll print our df5 which should be
the original one and then on the df5 we
can now
drop our missing data
i'm going to simply drop in a and we're
going to use how equals any so i'm going
to drop any row that has missing data in
it
and you'll see we had d here with
missing data and h
and then let's go ahead and see what df5
looks like when we do that
there we go and there it is d is gone
and so is h so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power the data you
got
so just a quick look at processing null
values
or missing values you can fill them
usually with the means some people use
medium or the mode there's different
ways you can fill it one way is means
and we can also just drop those rows
those are the two main things we do with
missing data
here we go we're going to cover next
this is i so love data frames for this
file operations
it saved me so much time because they
have so many different tools for
bringing data in and saving data so
we're looking at the data frame file
operations it's really streamlined i
don't know how many times they'll go on
to
different data downloads and they'll
have panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a csv so we have df3 to csv or animal
and let me just show you what the
folders going into
right now i have some untitled a few
things in here but nothing labeled
animal so we go ahead and run this
and this has now saved the animal to
my hard drive and you can now see the
animal folder up here and if i let's do
edit with a notepad oh let's open up
with just a regular notepad there we go
or word pad if i open that up you can
see it's comma separated our titles they
don't have an index on the categories on
the top and the index comma then all the
different data is separated by commas
standard csv file on there and if we're
going to send it to csv and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore csv
and it's just the name of the file we're
sending it to you can also put the
complete path by default it's going to
go whatever the active directory this
program program's running on that's why
those other folders are in there so we
have our df3 to csv and then if we're
going to put it in there we want to also
get it back out and we'll call this one
df underscore animal equals pd read
underscore csv i always have to remember
is two underscore csv and read
underscore csv i always want to do like
a capital in there and not the
underscore we're going in here again
it's the active directory so if i now do
print out my df
animal and let's just do the ahead we
only want to look at the first three
lines so if i go ahead and run this
we'll see the first three lines and they
should match up here what we saved to
our csv
so very easy to save and import from our
csv files on here
and it turns out df
3 also has a 2 xl they actually have a
lot of different formats but you know
old school
excel was real popular for so long still
is we can go ahead and save it as animal
dot xlsx we're going to call the sheet
named sheet1
and then i can also do df we'll call it
animal 2
animal 2 and this one's going to come
from in the same format on here there we
go so we still have our animal xlsx
the sheet one that's where it's coming
from index columns equals none so we're
not gonna we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign that's zero on up on
your indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because there's
no values in here and we want to just
make sure that they're marked as n a and
we'll go ahead and just print out the
animal animal two there we go and let's
run that let's make this let's just do
the whole thing so we'll go ahead and
run that
and it probably doesn't help that i
completely forgot the read so animal two
equals pd.reed
there we go excel so now we go ahead and
run it
and what we expect is happening here we
have the same data frame on here and if
i flick back to my folder you can now
see that we have the animal one of these
is in excel and one of these is a csv on
here and so there's our two file types
on there and they have other formats
these are just the two most common ones
used and i don't know how many times
i've had stuff from excel i need to pull
out if you've ever played with excel
it's a nightmare in the back end
because of the way they do the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an excel spreadsheet so we
looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there put your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where a really important part of data
science is
so let's go ahead and bring in our tools
we're going to do import numpy as np we
want to make sure we have our ambersign
matplot library in line this just lets
jupiter know that we're going to print
it on this page if you're using a
different ide you don't really
necessarily need that but this does help
it displays correctly in jupiter
notebook and if you remember for earlier
we could create a uh we're gonna call it
ts we're gonna create a pandas which are
cute cuddly creatures versus a pandem
short for pandemonium no so we have ts
equals pd series and we're just going to
create a random
setup of 50. we'll do an index we'll set
it equal to the panda's date range today
periods equals 50. so the 50 should
match and i want you to notice something
here i did not import the matplot
library why because it's already in
there pandas already has its built-in
connection and interface with matplot
library so you don't have to import it
and we'll go ahead and do ts
equals ts dot
cumulative sum we're gonna do the
cumulative sum
so a little reformatting there and we'll
go ahead and plot it and let's take a
look at what that looks like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus four to looks like about two maybe
or one minus four and one so what we've
done here we plotted a basic series just
a single row of data and we've set an
indexes on there but we can also do the
whole data frame on there and let's see
what that looks like
so first let's go ahead and create the
data frame we have here random numbers
we're going to do 50 by 4 and then we'll
go ahead and create columns a b x and y
just because we can index is the
ts.index on there so we use the same
index as before
just to keep it nice and uniform we've
already generated the dates to go with
it and then we can do just like we did
with the series
we can also do with the data frame
df equals df cumulative sum
so we're going to sum the whole data
frame and then we'll do simply df plot
and let's put that in and let's go ahead
and run this and look how easy and quick
that was to generate a nice graph with
all the different data on there so we
have our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh i think i mentioned
stock earlier because i've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a stock b stock x y
whatever it is and you can put them all
on one chart and see how they
what they look like next to each other
and this isn't too far off from what
some of those graphs look like and this
is just randomly generated so stock has
a lot of randomness in it which is one
of the reasons i actually play with it
for doing some of my models on for
testing them out
now there are a lot of features in
pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there's some of the
things like i didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a csv and from an excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
changes to a markdown and run that
so how would you remove repeated data
using pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's a feeding
from one location and instead of noting
that it's repeated the date like oh
let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have the stocks from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down
so let's start by creating a quick
database or data frame not a database i
keep saying databases a data frame and
we'll just make this data frame has
using our dictionary going in this data
frame only has one data series in it
which is fine so if we do df to print it
out you'll see a
one two two two two four five four five
six seven so on so how would you remove
that well there is a neat feature in
data frames called shift
along with another feature that lets us
select just certain date information and
we'll go with
the location function put that in
brackets remember that from above
location and then in the location let me
just spread this out a little bit so
it's really easy to read in fact i'm
going to go upscale on that since we're
doing some a little bit more complicated
here
what you can see on this on the location
is i have
dfa.shift
so this is going to shift up one by
default you can actually change this to
two or three you can even do a minus one
and it shifts the other way but it's
gonna shift up by one by default that's
gonna say if that does not equal df of a
then we want that if you look down here
we had one two two two two two when we
run this logic on here and we do the
shift
it now gets rid of all the duplicates so
we went from one two two two two four
four five whatever it was here it is one
two two two four four four five five
five six six six two one two four five
six seven eight
and you'll see on the index it just
deletes them out of there so the index
stays the same obviously you don't want
the dates to change if you're working
with an index dated setup so it just
deletes those duplicates out of there
this is just a quick way to introduce
you to one the fact that you can add
logic gates into here and two the eye
location
allows you to use shift so there's the
shift function and then the i location
selects that based on true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame how to index rows how
to slice how to plot
hopefully you'll take this beyond that
and start combining these different
things and you can create long strings
and really explore your data generate
some nice graphs if you're in jupiter
notebook it's a great demo to show
others
and i didn't know this about jupiter
notebook you can do this in jupiter
notebook and then you can download and i
always i never really look too closely
at all the downloads
which you now learn as an html and post
it to your blog so it's got a neat
feature in there but any of this is
really powerful tool all of this is
really powerful tools for doing your
data science
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
today we're going to study the matte
plot library and the python code so
what's in it for you what is matte plot
library types of plots plotting graphs
and sub graphs adding a graph inside a
graph graph parameters title label
legend line graphs line types color and
transparency canvas grid and axis range
2d plots scatter step bar fill between
radar chart histogram contour image 3d
surface image and then we'll hit a
practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matte plot
library map plot library is an open
source drawing library which supports
rich drawing types it is used to draw 2d
and 3d graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the maplight library
that we can't even cover them all today
but we'll hit the main one so you have a
good understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy i
use a lot of histograms in my stuff
scatter plot line chart
pie chart and area graph
let's start plotting them and to do this
i'm going to be using jupiter notebook
you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupyter notebook
which opens up in this case i'm using
google chrome you can go up here to new
and we'll create a new python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupyter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that you'll
look at any of our tutorials i usually
cover a number of them showing how to
set up jupiter and anaconda i myself use
jupiter through anaconda in fact let's
go ahead and open that up and just take
a look at this see what that looks like
you can see your anaconda navigator if
you install it it will automatically
install the jupyter notebook and that
also installs a lot of other things i
know some people like the qt console for
doing python or spyder i've never used
them i actually use notepad plus plus as
one of my editors and then i use the
jupiter notebook a lot because it's so
easy to have a visual while i'm
programming and even simple script in
python i'll take it from the jupyter
notebook and then do a save as you
always go under file and you can
download as a python program so that
will download it as an actual python
versus the ipython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot library tutorial and i'm
going to turn this cell into a mark down
so it doesn't actually run it
you can see it has a nice little title
there that's all jupiter notebook
and then from mat plot library
let's import
pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print we'll go pi lab
and the version let's go ahead and run
this so we're going to import our pi lab
module from the matplot library and we
find out the word version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're going to graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us and there is a lot of
ways to create data but we're going to
use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers we're just going to divide that
equally up between 0 and 10. and if we
have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times x
plus 2 and let's just take a look we're
going to print x
and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see we got going on here so we
have our x coordinates which is 0 0.4
0.83 etc and you can look at this as an
xy plot so we have 0 we have 2. we have
0.416 we have 2.17
and just as a quick reminder we're going
to do print np array x comma y dot
reshape 25 comma 2. and the reason i
want to do this is i want to show you
something here a lot of times a program
returns x comma y and it's an array of x
comma y x comma y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pie
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want x and
y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it
and then for our basic plotting of this
data it only takes one command to draw
graph of this data and so we use our
from up here we imported pi lab we take
our pi lab
and the key under there is plot for
plotting a line and then we want our x
coordinates and our y coordinates and
we'll throw in r and the r simply means
red so we're going to draw the line in
red let me go and run that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but whatever
they're using whatever the company is
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs
okay so let's take our pi lab and create
a sub
plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values
and we're going to represent by rows
columns and indexes and let's do one two
one so it's going to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to
plot data onto the subplot so the order
is very important and we're going to
stick with our x comma y
and let's do this we're going to add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dashed lines so this plots the
data into row one column two and if
we're going to do that let's do another
one pilab dot subplot and if we're going
to do row one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're gonna add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pi lab subplot
there we go by lab we've got to go ahead
and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells it the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switched them and the color and then the
style shorthand let's go ahead and run
that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has a little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's this
depreciated there's another way to do it
but most people just ignore that warning
because it's not going to go away
anytime soon now that's using the same
setup what happens if we do instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
it didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to two
and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index two it squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers till you
get a handle on them because
you know we have to repeat it 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three
run there we go but you can see it takes
a little bit sometimes to play with
these and get the numbers right i hope
they hit the wrong one that's why let's
go three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the where we have column and
row two and the two different indexes so
they appear nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
markdown and run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember i talked about
the canvas earlier i briefly mentioned
it we're going to look a little bit more
at the canvas later on but that's what
the figure is fid we're going to add
axes so we're going to initialize a
subplot add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and i want you to notice
that there's fig which is the actual
canvas in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas is pd and numpy
array is np certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but i would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above
with the pi lab but with the plt so if
it looks familiar there's reason we're
doing this because we want to show you
how the figure part works and working
with the canvas goes but we're going to
do the same plot as we did before and
we'll call it fig and we're going to set
that equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to fig dot at
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one
and so we can go ahead and i'm just
gonna put some stuff in there i got
point five point one
eight so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
fifty percent ten percent eighty eighty
percent but it's a control it's going to
control your left and your right along
with the width and the height so the
width and the height we're gonna use
eighty percent and we're going to have
like a little indent on the left and the
right and this should look familiar from
above x's dot plot
x comma y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we're recreating the same
graph let's keep it uniform oops and it
helps if i use a axis instead of ax es i
don't know where that came from but this
looks identical to the one we had up
above so here's our axis plot x comma y
of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
our canvas our axis is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs let me
put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different temptation here we have fig
comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals 2. so if you remember
before we did we had one row with two
different graphs on it we're going to do
the same thing but know how we did this
here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create row 1 column 2. and so axis is
an array of information so we can simply
do
4
let's do x in axes
this will look familiar x dot plot we're
going to do x comma y we'll go ahead and
make it red
keep everything looking the same
remember nice uniform graphs everything
looks the same and if we go ahead and
run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's even
make it a little bit more interesting
we'll do in rows equals to two and you
can see down here we're going to get an
attribute eric's just trying to scrunch
everything together
so it does have a limit how much stuff
you can put in one small space that's
important to know you can fix that by
changing the canvas size which we'll
look at in just a minute and there's
other ways to change it on here but here
we go we can do in rows two and columns
equals one you can see two nice images
right above each other we'll go back to
the original one row two columns side by
side left to right and
we can also
draw a picture or graph
inside another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation
so let's start by uh fig let's create
another figure so we're going to start
over again with our canvas we set that
equal to plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axes
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier
and
this here similar numbers we used before
saying how big this axis is this figure
in the axis is so this is going to be
the big
axes and let's do axes 2 equals
another figure at axes and then
0.2.5.4.3
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axes so axis1 dot plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red and then let's go
axes2 dot plot
and let's reverse them y comma x comma
green there we go doing what i told you
not to do you shouldn't be swapping axes
around and plotting your data in five
different directions because it's
confusing let's go ahead and run this
and see what this looks like and then
let's talk a little bit about this we
talked about the 0.2.5.4.3
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2
0.5 is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one that actually is they had
it down at left right i thought this was
wrong it's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that and this is 0.3 let's make
this 0.3 also and that is the width and
then of course there's the height we can
make that really tiny actually let's do
0.2
let's run that and you can see it
changes the height on there we make it
even smaller 0.2 by 8.2 and as you can
see you can get stuck playing with this
to make it look just right it can
sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel
and i mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas sides so this is from earlier
i just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at
and what we can do is we can change the
figure size to 16 by nine let me run
that show you what that looks like so it
fills the whole screen and then if you
are normally when you're working on the
screen you don't worry too much about
this but we can set the dpi
to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good
solid number to use your dots per inch
and you can see it drills a nice it
draws a nice large canvas here which is
16 by nine and then the dpi is 300 on
here so it's a little higher quality and
just out of curiosity i wonder how long
it takes to draw something double that
size 600 and you can see here where
at 600 dpi it's going to take a while
there it goes just because it's
utilizing a lot more graphics on there
and let me just go back to the 300 now
we'll actually do let's do a 100 you're
not going to see a difference on this
because it is web based graphics are
pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this
and you should get almost the same thing
here here's our
axis on the subplot on here with the
fixed size and the dpi let me take this
all out let me just remove all that real
quick run it again there we go now we're
back to our original figure and let's
look at some of the other things you can
do with this
one things we do is we can set a title
for the axis so axis set title you'll
see right here since they put this on
the axis it's the main title for the
whole graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our x
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it x and y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
x label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our x y and we run
that and of course we can also do up our
size a little bit you can see what's
going on a little better so here we have
x label x if you come down here you'll
see our x label and our y label we can
of course change this to x
label you can change this to y
would be whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our x label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do one
more thing on here we have a thing
called the legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax legend label 1
label 2 up here it's a format for it but
let's go down here and actually use it
i'm going to do two different plots
we're going to have axes plot x by x
times x squared and x cubed and if i run
this you'll see it puts two nice graphs
on the setup on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we can actually do
axes since we have the two plots legend
and on here we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom
location one i can't remember where
that's at there we go upper right so
each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen zero kinda have to play with them
or look them up to remember where
they're at but they do work it just kind
of moves around depending on where you
want your legend out on there so on this
section we cover the title of the graph
the y labels and legends this is we're
getting into some starting to look
really fancy here so we now have
something we can actually put out you'll
see the title the graph looks a little
fuzzy so i might in a web setup put the
dpi up a couple notches maybe put it at
200 100 might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots dpi equals oh let's do
200 and see what that looks like
so you can see it now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure and our axes equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see
let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus once which is
going to be a straight line plot
x plus x plus two
and axis.plot
x x plus three this looks like we're
doing nearest neighbor setup or showing
how it uh located data and putting your
lines on there between the nearest
neighbors there we go so it draws a nice
little graph with three lines on it one
of the things we can do is we can
control the alpha on this oops and you
can actually see the when they did these
lines it automatically pulls in
different colors for your setup so
there's some automatic automatic things
going on in there and a lot of times we
do that comma r where we're going to do
color equals red another notation on
here let's go ahead and run this now we
have a bright red line down there and
with the matte plot library you're not
limited to red you can also use the one
of many different color references as
you see here with the pound sign one one
five five
just is just blue and we can do the same
thing with another color on here which
turns out to be green i can just as
easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to say what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when i
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because i plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this alpha equals 0.5 and oh you
know what instead of squaring it let's
take it to the 0.5 power that'll be kind
of interesting to see what that does
we'll just go to keep it squared there
we go and run that and let's go back and
look at this where it crosses over and
the first thing you see right here is on
the blue it's kind of light blue now you
can see how the two colors add together
you get almost a purple on there so i
can clearly see where the red crosses
the blue line and then the green just
blanks it over because i didn't do any
opaqueness no alpha on there so this is
great if you have lots of data that
crosses over and you need to be able to
track those lines better and we'll go
ahead and do this 0.5 and we'll run that
oops i did
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as uh
the default is one solid so we can
change this all to point eight let me
just do that
oops 58 there we go run
oops i must have hit a wrong button
there let me try that again i actually
get rid of a bracket and let's go ahead
and run that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at
eighty percent instead of fifty percent
when you can do less that's kind of fun
although at some point the lanes kind of
fade
so point five is usually the best
setting on there we have a nice pastel
here at point three and you can easily
see where they cross over and just like
you can play with the colors we can play
with line width and you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
if i run this they should all appear the
same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
i forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line width
width
equals
0.25 and let's just copy and paste that
down here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one let's make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line a point five
a one our one point five and two which
is twice the width of the one and if
we're going to do different sizes we had
different colors we had our alpha scheme
let's take this whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles and something to know here you
can actually abbreviate this with lw so
line width can also be point let's just
do everything 0.2 and let's set up a
line style we'll do the first one dashes
and let me just paste that down here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot we'll just do the
dash dot here and a colon here there we
go and there's a lot of different
options we'll look at a few more as we
go down for different ways of
highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything as a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus um
four so it goes right on the top and do
color black line width 1.5 so it's a
smaller line
and we're going to take the line and
we're going to set dashes so look i've
changed some of the notation here for my
line and my ax plot so i can set my line
comma equal to x plot and then i can
change the line settings this way and
when i run this let me run that on here
you'll see the 5 10 15 10
creates a series of dashes that are
buried in link
link in this case they alternate between
a short dash and a long dash we can play
with these numbers curiosity always has
me what happens when you play with the
numbers just to see what they look like
let's do this let's paste this down here
i'll do two of these just because
they're kind of fun to play with and
let's change this from 10 to
3 and we're going to change this one
from 15
to
4. and let's run that
and you can see the differences in the
lines oops very a little bit confusing
on there because i forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when i change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
three you can see now we have the dashes
of five let's see i'm going to guess
this is a dash is a five skip ten dashes
of 15 skip three and then it goes back
to the beginning dash is five dashes
skip ten fifteen dashes skip three and
of course the last one we just switched
up a little bit it looks a lot more
uniform because i'm using two sets of
ten or if i did something like this and
change it to thirty it really becomes
pronounced as far as the distances
between them and instead of 4 let's go
oh let's put 30 here also 30 by 30.
there we go really pronounced on that
one and let's look at one more important
group for plotting our data and in this
we're gonna here's our plot we started
with with the x plus one x plus two x
plus three and did it in blue on this
one's three or four different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this you'll see it puts a dot for each
of these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
you can also do
plus sign that's another option dots is
most common i'll actually like the dots
the best if we do the plus sign you see
it puts a nice crosshairs or plus sign
on there and we can do a marker there's
a number of different markers you can
use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one that's for square o
for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is the number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second let's do marker
size equals two
and change that to five and run that and
you can see here it's a nice little tiny
dot versus
the size dot here this is interesting
because it said two i thought it would
be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here
and we'll do we had marker size so we
also have marker face we'll set that
equal to red of course we need to take
change the so it's up one notch we'll
run that whoops must have mistyped
something on here and i did it's marker
face color equals red and so when i run
that you can now see i have the squares
on there with the marker face color of
course we can mix and match these
come down here and we'll make this
instead of let's make this plus seven
and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color
equals
and we'll do what green just because
there we go run very hard to actually
see what's going on there still 25 dots
they kind of overlap as you can see they
print them over each other of course if
we really wanted to make it look
horrible we could just make that really
huge generally though you want something
a little bit smaller and cuter we'll
just try doing it this way there we go
that's too small to even see the face so
four
you can start to see the face on there
around four and maybe an eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show and display
so we've covered a lot of stuff here as
far as our lines we've covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line with
different size on there different
formats for the line itself and these
are all you can combine all these so we
can have our line width equals two line
style equals dash you can bring this
down here also to the markers and then
we added markers in just entered a
circle a plus sign the square a little
tick which uses a one
then we had a marker size and a marker
color face and we combine those you see
we get a nice different series
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here and have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to i changed them to red and
blue so you get very precise on the
color if you have a very specific color
set that you need to match your website
or whatever you're working on all those
are tools in the matplot library so we
have
one more piece to formatting the graph
so we want to show you and then we have
two big sections we're going to go over
the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go to the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data
so this first primer is going to paste
in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're gonna do a figure size of ten
comma five this should all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're gonna go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axes zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of 0 is still the
axes of the first axes out of 2. and
we're going to plot x
x squared
x
x cubed line with 2. so we're going to
go ahead and just plot two graphs right
on top of each other without doing
multiple plots on here and we'll set the
grid equal to true one here let's go
ahead and run that and you can see here
our two plots with the x value going
across
and i'm going to do
something similar and by the way as you
can just if you look at it you can see
the grid on there that's all that is
easier to spot the data going across
we're going to take the same
data for axes one so we have our plot of
x x squared x and x cubed line with two
and this time we're going to take our
axes one and do y limit
it's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
zero comma sixty i'm just making these
numbers up the guys in the back actually
made them up i'm just using their
numbers
we're gonna set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as
don't forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit zero to sixty so we're looking at
just the lower part of this curve here
up to here and we have the x limit two
to five so that starts right here at two
and you can see very different graphs
this is kind of nice because you could
actually put one of these on top of the
other if you wanted to draw focus to one
part of a graph remember how we did that
earlier one inside the other but just a
quick note you can easily limit your
graph and re kind of reshape the way it
looks quite easily and we can also add
that grid down there if we want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make the cell a markdown so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
0 to 5 on here there we go and let's
look at four common graphs we'll put
them side by side so we'll do a figure
our axes equals plot subplots one four
columns and then figure size hopefully
it'll fit nicely on here it seems to do
a pretty good on here and i'll go and
just run that since we're in there run
you'll see i have my four blank plots on
here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of
zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our
n we can do x or n there we go and let's
go ahead and do axes set title scatter
i've already did that we're just going
to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable x
x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are i have a lot
of random numbers connected to them
that's why they do them on there and so
the bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker
this is plotting basically just the
marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
x is one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time we'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n
n times 2 our n squared n times 2 n
squared line width equals 2 and if we
run that it creates a nice step up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step
plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula in n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9
run and if we take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha now i can't
say i've used the step craft very much
there's certainly there's certain i
guess domains of expertise require a
step graph but the scatter plot and the
bar graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very uh concrete
objects somebody how many people are
wearing yellow hats
that kind of thing but if we're going to
do that let's go ahead and do the last
one which i see a lot more in the
sciences certainly using the data
science but more like for mapping i saw
publication on uh solar flares and they
were discussing the energy and so
filling in the graph gives it a very
different look so we're going to do the
fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's fill between but with a underscore
between them and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor and
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest i've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science i can't find
a reason to use one now so the first
line for doing a radar chart we have to
add axes into the figure and with this
this actually creates our oh let's let's
run it so you can see what it creates it
creates a nice looks like you're on a
submarine and you're tracking the hunt
for red october or something like that
and it needs all of these the polar is
the fact that we're doing polar
coordinates
zero zero point six point six has to do
with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box
if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had point six on here i'll go ahead
and leave it as one because that's just
kind of fun that's all about the size on
here the height and the width and then
let's create some data t equals np line
space and this is 0 to 2 times np times
pi so if you remember that is the
distance across and we're going to
generate hundred points
so this is just a thing of data we're
putting together then we simply do an ax
dot plot and in this case let's do t
comma t which would be a diagonal line
on a regular chart and we'll give it a
nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t time 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we could do t times
two spirals that a little quicker so
it's kind of just a fun i've like i said
i've never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar submarine kind of
looks like one of those or in an
airplane
and none of this would be complete if we
didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh do
i use a histogram so much and we'll use
our numpy that we have set as np to
generate oh looks like we have a hundred
thousand variables we're going to set
equal to n and of course we create our
figure and our axes subplots one two
figure size twelve fourteen so we're
gonna look at two different variations
of the histogram and we'll set a title
default histogram set our title there
and then this is simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here
so we generated an array here of data
1000 random arrays
looks like they're mostly between minus
four and four
and then it adds up each one it says
zero you have 35 000 that are zero so
that's what's most common on here and we
have 20 000 that are somewhere in this
range right here between the minus two
and well it looks like one and minus two
and somewhere between zero and one
there's 30 000 numbers so all this is
saying is this is how common these
variables are and this gives you this
point in so many directions when you're
looking at data science to go ahead and
run your histogram so you should always
have your histogram and you can always
put limits and all the other different
things on your array just like you did
on the other graphs on there and then
we're going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram
and all it is is a histogram let me just
do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the
cumulative equals true is important but
we can now choose how many bins we have
in the first one it kind of selected
them for us in this case let me go ahead
and run this and you'll see it has the
prints of data out for us and here's our
whoops
must have missed oh there we go doesn't
help that i put it over the old one
there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that and we could
set that for 5
and run that
and then we have our 5 on there and we
go ahead and take the cumulative equals
true out just so you can see what that
looks like and let me run that on here
too
that looks just like it did before i
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different look
wait it shifts at all to the right no it
doesn't actually shift it to the right
it's cumulative so it's the total of the
different occurrences and so what that
means is like if you consider this like
for the year of rainfall we have like
day one you had a little bit of rain day
two we have more rain and so if you look
at the number this is a hundred thousand
thirty five thousand so it's
accumulative detail the histogram of the
currents as it grows and rainfall is a
good one because that would be a
cumulative histogram of how much rain
occurred throughout the year and we're
going to look at two more graphs we've
already looked at a bunch of them we
looked at our radar graph we've looked
at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
we'll import matplot.cm
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can even do your own color map
they're pretty diverse and of course our
plt we're gonna our pi plot and to
generate our different data we're going
to create a delta
0.025 and we'll start with x and we're
going to create an array between -3 and
3 and delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our x y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for z1 we'll do a z2 so
we have two different areas and z equals
z of 1 minus z2 times 2.
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs and this
is going to be our contour so right here
cs is our contour surface and we're
feeding it x y and z if you remember x y
we created as our x and y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print
x
and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
those are x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components x and
y be in the coordinates well z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do a title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
that looks like
and you'll see we generated a nice
little contour map there's different
settings you can play with on this but
you can picture this being you're on a
mountain climb and here we have a line
that's represents zero maybe at sea
level and then moving on up you have
your contours of 0.5 and then minus one
and different setups little hills i
guess if it's minus that's like a pit so
i guess you're going down into a pit at
minus five and minus one but on the
other side you can see you're going up
in levels so here's a mountaintop and
here's like a basin of some kind and in
data science this could represent a lot
of things this could also be
representing two different values and
maybe profits and loss i don't know if
i'd ever really do that as a contour map
but i'm sure you could be creative and
find something fun to do with a contour
map and then we're going to look at one
last map which is the 3d map and those
are can be really important as a final
product because they can show so much
additional information that you can't
fit on two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3d image
and so we're going to import from our
mpl toolkits the implant 3d and the axis
3d we're going to import axis 3d this is
what's going to let us work with the 3d
image and this should look familiar
we're going to create another figure
just like we did before figure size 14
by 6 that's a good fit on the screen
we'll go ahead and run that
so we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our x and we're going to set
that equal to fig dot add subplot that
should also be familiar from earlier and
we're going to work with this sets the
settings for the projection we're going
to use one two one projection 3d and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute and we just created some
three-dimensional data here before
where we had x y and z capital x y and z
so we're going to reuse that data we're
just going to use that since this also
this is also a three-dimensional image
so let's use that for a
three-dimensional graph and we simply do
ax plot underscore
surface
and our capital x
capital y capital z so there's our data
coming in and we're going to add some
settings in here we're going to do r
stride 4 c stride 4 and line width 0.
i'll show you what that is here in just
a minute let's go ahead and run that so
we can see our graph
and of course it helps if i don't add an
extra comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the c stride 4
and the projection 3d projection 3d is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3d graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these i'm
going to change this to five
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to one
and that didn't work let's change this
middle one to three instead
and you're going to see how it starts
reshaping the size and how it fits on
the screen
and we'll change the first one to two
we'll run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle
i'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size now fits
on the canvas
but we'll leave it at the one
two
and just so you get a good look at what
we're talking about here this is column
width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole set up on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and i'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat
map you might see that it's kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people who still talk about heat
maps what is a heat map well it is
simply a color map that's all it is so
if you ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into
let me go back up here here we go this
one has different colors for the
different values
a lot of times you'll use like instead
of x and y you might do a heat map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3d image in a nice
colors represented by heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell
cell type mark down and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a path python
program to create a pie chart of the
popularity of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and i'll just throw in
our import our map library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have java php javascript c sharp c
plus so those are six categories and
then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent java 17.6 and
i don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled
my guess is that they might have just
been made up because i don't know if
python's really that much more popular
than the other ones maybe specific to
data science because python is very
popular in data science right now
because it has so many options the only
other program that's highly used and
exclusively for data science is r so
python's big and python also does a lot
more it's a full programming language
where r is primarily for data science
they didn't put r in here so we have
python we have java we have our php and
you can see the different values i've
given it or different percentages
and i did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors i'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so i'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that you could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is point one and
then zero zero zero zero zero point one
when we put this in here under the
explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart
and this is simply
plt.pi
and we're plotting
popularity there we go
and before we add in all the really cool
settings for this let's go ahead and run
it and you'll see we generate a nice
flat pie
not too exciting there and then we'll go
ahead and put in all the extras i talked
about explode where we can explode one
of the values out so here's our explode
equals explode labels as languages
because we want to know what the
different colors mean here's our colors
equals colors our auto picture and this
is standard print format so that's a
python setup on there and that's just
going to put the value on the pie slice
and then we're going to add shadow
because it just looks cooler with a
shadow gives a little 3d look and we'll
do a start angle of 140. let's go ahead
and run this and take a look and see
what comes out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slices
pushed out there's our shadow a 3d
effect
and then we started at 140. we could
also rotate this let's just do this
angle
90.
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pi slice has moved
up a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run he'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that appear on the left
because people read left to right and so
it draws a focus onto in this case
python and how great python is i'm a
little biased we're teaching a python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the map plot library dot pi
plot set up and if you go underneath
there the different functions on there
you can look this up on their website
you'll see a full list and this is why
it's so important to go through a
tutorial like this because this list is
just so massive trying to figure out
like here's our bar plot
there's a bar h you can add barbs
there's a box plot we didn't cover
c labels a totally different kind of for
your contour plot you can set up in
there if you go down here we have our
figures we used on there we showed you
the basics how to do the figure you'll
see some
closer references on those
there's a histogram down here h i s t
there's also the hiss2d makes a 2d
histogram plot h lines all of this these
are all the different commands that are
underneath of here and you can see it's
pretty extensive
we've covered all the basic ones so that
you know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your matplot library
let's go ahead and open up another
python 3
setup in here
and so we want to explore what happens
when you want to display this this is
where it starts getting
in my opinion a little fun because
you're actually playing with it and you
have something to show people
and we'll go ahead and rename this we're
going to call this
pandas
and pie plot
so pandas pie plot
just so we can remember for next time
and we want to go ahead and import the
necessary libraries we're going to
import pandas as pd now remember this is
a data frame so we're talking rows and
columns and you'll see how
pandas work so nicely when you're
actually showing data to people
and then we're going to have numpy in
the background numpy works with pandas
so a lot of times you just import them
by default
seaborn sits on top of the matplot
library so sometimes we use the seaborn
because it kind of extends it's one of
the 100 packages that extends the
matplot library probably the most
commonly used because it has a lot of
built-in functionality
almost by default i usually just put
cborn in there in case i need it and of
course we have matplot library as pi
plot as plt
and note we have as pd as np as sns as
plt
those are pretty standard so when you're
doing your imports i would probably keep
those just so other people can read your
code and it makes sense to them that's
pretty much a standard nowadays
and then we have the strange line here
it
amber sign matplot library inline
that is for jupiter notebook only so if
you're running this in a different
package you'll have a pop-up when it
goes to display the matplot library you
can with the
most current version of jupiter usually
leave that out and it will still display
it right on the page as we go and we'll
see what that looks like
and then we're going to go ahead and
just do the seaborn the sns.set and
we're going to set the color codes
equals true let them just keep the
default one so we don't have to think
about it too much
and we of course have to run this
the reason we run this is because these
values are all set if we don't run this
and i access one of these afterward
it'll crash
the cool thing about jupiter notebooks
is if you forgot to import one of these
you forgot to install it because you do
have to install this under your anaconda
setup or whatever setup you're in you
can flip over to anaconda and run your
install for these
and then just come back and run it you
don't have to close anything out
and we'll go ahead and paste this one in
here real quick we have car equals pd
dot read underscore csv
and then we have
the actual path
this path of course will vary depending
on what you are working with uh so it's
wherever you save the file at and you
can see here i have like
my onedrive documents simply learn
python data analytic using python slash
car csv it's quite a long file
when we open that up what we get is we
get a csv file and we have the make the
model the year the engine fuel type
engine horsepower
cylinders and so on
and this is just a comma separated file
so each row is like a row of data think
of it as a spreadsheet
and then each one is a column of data on
here and as you can see right here it
has the make model so it has columns for
a header on here
now your pandas just does an excellent
job of automatically pulling a lot of
this in
so when you start seeing the pandas on
here
you realize that you are already like
halfway done with getting your data in i
just love pandas for that reason
numpy also has it you can load a csv
directly into numpy
but we're working with pandas and this
is where it really gets cool is i can
come down here
and i can print remember our print
statement we can actually get rid of it
and we're just going to do car head
because it's going to print that out
the head is going to print the top
values of that data file we just ran in
and so you can see right here it does a
nice printout it's all nice and inline
because we're in jupyter notebook i can
scroll back and forth and look at the
different data
and just like we expected we have our
column it brought the header right in
one thing to note is the index it
automatically created an index 0 1 2 3 4
and so on and we're just looking at the
head so we've got zero one two three
four
you can change this you might wanna just
look at the top two
we can run that there's our top two bmws
another thing we can do is instead of
head we can do tail
and look at the last three values that
are in that data file
and uh you can see right here it
numbered them all the way up to 11 913
oh my goodness they put a lot of data in
this file i didn't even look to see how
big the file was
so you can really easily get through and
view the different data in here
when you're talking about big data
you almost never just print out car
in fact let's see what happens when we
do if we run this and we just run the
car
it's huge
in fact it's so big that the pandas
automatically truncates it and just does
head plus tail so you can see the two
so we really don't want to look at the
whole thing i'm going to go back to
let's stick with the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's a head of our data gives us a
quick look to see what's actually in
there
i can zoom out if you want so you can
actually get a better view
although we'll keep it zoomed in so you
can see the code i'm working on
and then from the data standpoint we
course want to look at
data types uh what's going on with our
data what does it look like
now this you know you show your when
you're talking to your shareholders
they like to see these nice easy to read
charts they look like a spreadsheet so
it's a nice way of displaying pieces of
the chart
we talk about the data types now we're
getting into the data science side of it
what are we working with well we have
make model we have an integer 64 for the
year
engine fuel type is an object if we go
up here you can see that there most of
them are
like you know it's a set manual
rear-wheel drive
so they might be very limited number of
types in there
and so forth and you'll it's either
going to be a float64 an integer or an
object is the way it's going to read it
on here
and
the next thing you're going to know is
like your columns
and since it loaded the columns
automatically
we have here the make the model the year
the engine
the size all the way up to the msrp
and
just out of something you'll see come up
a lot
is whenever you're in pandas and you
type in dot values
it converts it from a pandas list to a
numpy array
and that's true of any of these so then
you end up in a numpy array so you'll
see a little switch in there in the way
that the data is actually uh stored and
that's true of any of these
uh in this case uh we want car dot
columns
you have a total list of your car
columns
and like any good data
scientist
we want to start looking at analytical
summary of the data set what's going on
with our data so we can start trying to
piecemeal it together so we can do car
describe and then we'll do is we'll do
include
equals
all
so a nice panda command is to describe
your data
if you're working with r this should
start looking familiar
and we come down here and you can see um
count there's a
make the model the year
how many of each one
how many unique values of each one
the top value of each one what's most
common the frequency the mean
clearly on some of these it's an object
so really can't tell you what the
average is you know it'd just be the top
ones the average i guess
the year what's the average year on
there
all this stuff comes down here your
standard deviation your minimum value
your maximum value
what's in the lower quarter
50 mark where's that line at and what's
in the upper 75 percent the top 25
percent going into the max
now this next part is just cool uh this
is what we always wanted computers to be
back like in the 90s instead of 5 000
lines of code to do this maybe not 5
000.
all right i built my own plot
library back in 95 and the amount of
code for doing a simple plot
was
i don't know probably about 100 lines of
code
this is being done in one line of code
we have our car which is our pandas we
generated that it's our data frame and
we have dot hist for histogram
that is the power of seaborn now it's
still going to generate a numpy graph
but seaborn sits on top and then we can
do the figure size this is just um
so it fits nicely on the paper on here
and we do something simple like this and
you can see here where it comes up and
does say matplot library and does
subplots and everything
but we're looking at a histogram of all
the different pieces in our database
and we have our engine cylinders
that's always a good one because you can
see like they have some that are they
had a null on there so they came out as
zero
maybe a couple maybe one of them had a
two-cylinder engine away back when
four is a common uh six a little less
common and then you see the
eight-cylinder
uh 12-cylinder engines well it's got to
be a speedster or something
uh but you can see right here just
breaks it down so now you have uh how
many cars
with how many whatever it is cylinders
horsepower uh and so on and it does a
nice job displaying it
you can see if you're working with your
uh um
you're going into your demo it's really
nice just to be able to type that in and
boom there it is it can see it all the
way across
and we might want to zero in
and use like a box plot and this time
we'll go ahead and call the
seaborn sns box plot
and we're going to go ahead and do
vehicle size in versus
engine horsepower xy plot and the data
comes from the car so if we run this we
end up with a nice box plot
you see our mid-size compact and large
you can see the variation there's our
outlier showing up there on the compact
that must be a high-end sports car
a large car might have a couple engines
and again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on them
very powerful and quick way to zero in
on one small piece of data and display
it for people who need to have it
reduced to something they can see and
look at and understand and that's our
seabourn box plot our sns.box plot
and then if we're going to back out and
we want a quick look at
what they call pair plotting
we can run that and you can see with the
seaborn it just does all the work for
you
it takes just a moment for it to pull
the data in and compile it
and once it does it creates a nice grid
in this grid if you look at this one
space here which is you might not be
able to see the small number it says
engine horsepower this is engine
horsepower uh to the year was built
and it's just flipped so everything to
the right of the middle diagonal is just
the rotation of what's on the left and
as you expect
the engine horsepower
gets bigger and bigger and bigger as
time goes on so the the year it was
built the further up in the year the
more likely you are to have a heavy
horsepower engine
and you can quickly look at trends
with our pair plot coming up and look
how fast that was that was it took a
couple a moment to process
but right away i get a nice view of all
these different information which i can
look at visually and and kind of see how
things group and look
now if i was doing a meeting i probably
wouldn't show all the data
um one of the things i've learned over
the years is um people myself included
love to show all our work you know we're
taught in school show all your work
prove what you know
the ceo doesn't want to see a huge uh
grid of of graphs i guarantee it so we
want to do is we want to go ahead and
drop
the stuff that might not be interested
in and we're going to i'm not really a
car person
a guy in the back is obviously
so you have your engine fuel type we're
going to drop that we're going to drop
market category vehicle style popularity
number of doors vehicle size
and we have the axes in here if you
remember from numpy we have to include
that axis to make it clear what we're
working on that's also true with
pandas and then we'll look at just what
it looks like from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make model year
and so forth
and we took out the engine fuel type
market category etc
and this should look familiar to you now
when you start working with pandas
i just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice
spreadsheet for you you can just look at
it and view it very easily it's also the
same kind of view you're going to get if
you're working in spark or pi spark
which is python for spark across big
data this is the kind of thing that they
they come up with this is why pandas are
so powerful
and we may look at this and decide we
don't like these columns
and so you can go in here and we can
actually rename the columns
simple command car equals car rename
columns equals engine horsepower equals
horsepower
this is just your standard python
dictionary
um so it just maps them out and you know
instead of having like a lengthy effect
here we had
engine horsepower we just want
horsepower we don't need to know what's
the engine horsepower
engine cylinders we don't need to know
that it's for the engine because there's
only one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that cylinders
and we'll go ahead and just run this and
again here's our car head and you can
see how that changed we have model year
in horsepower versus model year engine
horsepower engine cylinders and just
cylinders
again we want to keep reducing this so
it's more and more readable the more
readable you get it the better
and of course we can also adjust the
size a little bit
so that when it prints out instead of
splitting it on two lines we get like a
single line we can do that also that's
just your control mouse up or plus sign
you use in chrome that's a chrome
command
and if you remember from numpy we had
shape well pandas works the same way
we can look at the shape of the data so
we now have
11 914 rows and 10 columns
so you'll see some similarities because
pandas is built on numpy
and questions that come up just like you
did in numpy we might want to know
duplicate rows and so we can do car
and look at this switch here um we're
doing a selection this is a pandas
selection with the brackets
but we want to select it based on car
dot duplicated so how many duplicates on
there
so we're starting to look a little bit
different as far as how we access some
of the data on here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns again
and this is one of those troubleshooting
things that we end up doing a lot more
than we really feel like we should
we might go ahead and do like a car
count
just to see how many rows we're dealing
with
and then right after that we might want
to go ahead and say hey
let's drop duplicates so remember we did
all the duplicates on there so car
equals car dot drop duplicates and then
we can print the head again we'll just
do car head here and you can see the
data on there um looks the same as
before
and just note that we did car equals car
draw duplicates
there are commands in here where you can
do where it changes the actual value and
it works on some of them and not on
others depending on what you're doing
but by default it always returns a copy
so when we do this we're reassigning it
to car
and you can see it's the same header but
we want to go ahead and do count and see
how the count changes let's go ahead and
run this and you can see here instead of
11 914 we have 10
925
so we've removed
about 100 cars
that were duplicated just slightly under
100 there
and then as we're prepping our data we
might want to know
car is null
so it's going to count the values of
null and then we want to sum that up
and when we do that we do the car is
null function dot sum
we end up with uh hp the horsepower 69
have null values and 30 have cylinders
have no values
now if you don't put the sum at the end
it's just going to return
a mask with the true false of is it null
or is it not
by
zero and one so you're summing up the
ones underneath each column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
values there's a lot of different
options it might be that you need to put
in the average or means
maybe you want to put in the median
value
there's a lot of different ways to fill
it
usually when you first start out with
the data a lot of them you just drop
your null values and you can see here
car dot drop in a
which is equal to all and then we're
going to go ahead and count it and you
can see that we've dropped almost
another 100 values so from 10 1925
to 10 8 27
yeah maybe 75 or so values
uh so we clean that this is really a big
part of cleaning data you need to know
how to get rid of your null values or at
least count them and what to do with
them
and of course if we go back to
counting our null values we should now
have
no null values
there we go and you'll see there's zero
null values
i don't know how many times i've been
running a model that doesn't take no
values and it crashes and i just sit
there and look at it trying to get why
did that crash it should have worked
it's because i forgot to remove the null
values
so we've been jumping around a lot we're
going to go back to
finding outliers and let's go ahead and
bring that back into our seabourn and if
you remember we did a box plot earlier
this time we're going to do a box plot
just on the price
and you can see here
our price value
and we have the deviation with the two
thinner bars on each side of the main
value and then as we get up here we have
all these outliers in fact we have one
way out here that's
probably a really expensive high-end car
is what we're looking at
if you were doing
fraud analysis you would be jumping on
all over these outliers why are these
deviation from the standard what are
these people doing
again this is probably like i said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at
and we can also look at the
box plot for the horsepower
we'll put that in down here
and run that
and you can see again here's our
horsepower and it just jumps and there's
these really odd huge muscle cars out
here that are outliers
and we're going to jump into making this
a little bit more
as you start displaying your data or
your information to your shareholders
we're going to look at plotting a
histogram for the number of cars per
brand
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is we have with our car go back over
here here we go
we have our make value counts largest
plot
and we want to do a kind equals bar
figure size 10 5.
and
right off the bat we jump up here we see
chevrolet it's going against what was it
it's um figure recession the value
counts and we want the largest value so
here's our value counts and compared to
what the different cars are chevrolet
puts out a lot of different kinds of
cars i didn't realize that they made
that many cars
or different types
and then for readability let's go ahead
and add a title number of cars by make
number of cars and make if you looked at
this the first time you would have been
like what the heck am i looking at well
we're looking at the number of cars by
make and then you can see here now we're
talking about the type of cars
and the different ones are put out lotus
i guess only had a few different kinds
of cars over there very high-end cars
and then as uh doing data analytics and
as a data scientist one of the things i
am most interested in is the
relationship between the variables
so this is always a place to start we
want to know what's going on with our
variables and how they connect with each
other
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and set a figure
size because we want to make sure
it fits our graph
we'll just go ahead and set this one
plot figure set to figure size 2010.
if you never use the matplot library
which is sitting behind seaborne
whatever is in the plt
this is what's loaded it's like a canvas
you're painting on so the second you
load that
pie plot as plt
anything you do to that is affecting
everything on it
and then we want to go ahead since we're
using seaborne
we'll go ahead and create a variable c
for
relationships or correspondence
and car dot c-o-r-r that's a correlation
in
seabourn on top of pandas again
one line and you get the whole
correlation on there
and because we're working with seaborne
let's put it into a nice heat map if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
means we're just using color as part of
our
setup so we have a nice visual
and we can see here that the seaborne
connected to the pandas prints out a
nice chart
we'll talk a little bit about the color
here in a second it prints out a nice
chart this is a chart i look at as a
data scientist these are the numbers i
want to look at
and we'll just highlight one of them
here's cylinders
versus horsepower
the closer to one the higher the
correlation so
0.788 pretty high correlation between
the number of cylinders and how heavy
the horsepower is
i'm betting if you looked at the year
versus horsepower
we just look at that one here's year and
horsepower
0.314 not as so much but if you combine
them you don't actually add them but if
you combine them you'll start to see an
increase in horsepower per year in
cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there
and just like 0.78 is a positive
correlation
you might notice if we look at cylinders
and or let's look at horsepower and
mileage uh so if we go here to
horsepower to mileage you get a nice
negative we'll do cylinders that's a
bigger number
with cylinders to the miles per gallon
it's a minus 0.6 so it's a negative
correlation the closer to minus one the
more the negative correlation is
and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice heat map this is
all our colors and it's just those
numbers put into a heat map the darker
the color the higher the correlation you
can see straight down the middle
obviously the year correlates directly
with the year horsepower with horsepower
and so on that's why it's a one the
closer to the one the higher the
correlation between the two pieces of
data
now this is a good introduction pandas
goes way beyond this most the
functionality in numpy since panda sits
on it is also in pandas and then it even
has additional features in it and we use
seaborne pretty extensively sitting on
top over our pie plot so keep in mind
that our pie plot has a ton of other
features in it that we didn't even touch
on in here
we couldn't even if you had a soul
course in it uh there's just so many
things hidden in there depending on what
your domain you're working on
but you can see here here's our seabourn
and here's our matplot library that's
all our graphics that we did and then
the seaborn works really nicely with the
pandas we really like that
in the next project we'll understand how
to perform data analysis using uber data
set from new york city so let me show
you the data set first
so this is the data set that we'll be
using for our analysis you can see
this data set
has around 5 lakhs 64 516 rows
it has information about uber bookings
in the new york city
you have the date and time column when
the booking was done
or you can see when the pickup or the
trip was made
next
we have the latitude and longitude
information basically defining the
location from where the uber was booked
the last column is the base column it
has data regarding tlc based company
code affiliated with the uber pickup
that is the base that dispatched the
uber
now let me take you straight to my
jupyter notebook where i have
implemented this project
so i have my code ready i'll run through
each cell of code and tell you what it
does
in the process we'll also learn some of
the functionalities of python 2.
first
let's start by importing the libraries
so first we are importing numpy library
as np
panda as a spd now numpy is used for
numerical computation
pandas is used for preprocessing and
data manipulation finally we have
matplotlib and c bond for data
visualization and exploratory data
analysis
so let me hit shift enter to run this
cell
okay
now
let's go ahead and import our uber data
set so it's a csv file
for that i'm using the pandas library
and read underscore csv function and
inside this function i provided the
location where the data file is you can
see this is my location
followed by the data set name this is
the name of my data set
and the extension as well that is dot
csv
let me hit shift enter to run this cell
now we have successfully
imported our data set
now to display the head of the data set
i'll write uber
dot head
this is the function which is used to
display the head of the data set
now the dot head function will display
the top five rows from this data set
there you go so we have our first
five rows from the data set
now
if you want to display some additional
information about the data set
you can use info function
so let me hit
shift enter to run this cell
you can see
the info function gives you the total
number of rows and columns in the data
set
you can see we have 5 lakh 64 516
entries that is rows and now we have a
total of four columns
and you can see all the columns listed
here date time latitude longitude base
and we also have the data type for each
of these columns
now moving ahead
in the following cell
we'll check if there are any missing
values or null values in all the columns
for that i have defined a function
called
num missing and it has one argument that
is x
i am using the is null function to
return the total sum of null values
in the final print statement i have used
pandas library and
apply method now this apply method takes
a function and applies it to all the
values of pandas series
let's
run this cell
you can see
none of the columns have any missing
values it says 0 0 0 and 0 which means
there are no missing values in any of
the columns
next
there's another method to find null
values where you can use is any function
so let me show you how to do that
i'll write uber which is my data frame
dot
is an e is my function
and i'll use the sum function
let me run this
there you go it has written the same
results indicating there are no null
values or missing values
now
we are interested to extract some
additional information from the data
so i am converting the date time column
into a data frame using two underscore
date time function
and i have my format specified you can
see it here
next
i am finding the day of week num which
means i want to know a particular day
falls on which week number so 0 for
monday 1 for tuesday 2 for wednesday and
so on
you can see i have used dd dot
day of week method
similarly
you can also find the weekday name
that is if a particular day is a monday
or a tuesday or a sunday or anything
and for that i have used dt dot weekday
underscore name
now let me extract two more information
that is the day number and the hour of
the day at which the trip was made
so i'll write uber which is my data
frame name i'll give square brackets and
inside that i pass in my column names
say
d num
and
that will be equal to
my data frame that is uber
followed by
a column name that is date slash
time
and i'll use the method dt
dot
d
similarly
to find the r
i'll write uber
within square brackets i give my column
name r of
day
that will be equal to
uber
followed by the original column name
date slash time
and
the method i'll use is
dt dot r
let's run this
okay
now
let me display the head of the data set
once again
so i'll write
uber
dot head
you can see
towards the right we have our new
columns added
that did not exist in our original data
set
now you can also display the save of the
data set
now the shape will return the total
number of rows and columns present so
i'll use uber dot
shape
you can see we have 5 lakhs 64 516 rows
and 8 columns now earlier if i go on top
we had four columns
now there are eight columns in total
you can also
find out all the unique base code names
from where the uber was dispatched
so let me show you how to do that i'll
write uber
and inside square brackets i'll give my
column as base
and give the unique function
if i run this
you can see we have five different base
code names
now
coming to our first visualization of the
project
here
we'll see the total count of uber trips
from each piece
for that i have used the c bond library
and
cat plot function
in the x axis i have my base column
defined
i have passed my data frame name that is
uber and kind i have given as count that
is i want to count the number of
bookings at each base
so let me run it
this might take some time
there you go
you can see on the screen we have a nice
bar graph here
the x axis shows the count of trips for
each base code
so base
0 two six eight two
had the highest number of trips or
bookings in april 2014
and base
zero two seven six four had the lowest
number of bookings
in the next cell
let's explore another feature of pandas
library that is to create a pivot table
for that i have used pivot underscore
table function
for index i am using the column names d
of week num and day of week
values i have passed my base column and
the aggregate function i have used is
count
now the cell of code will create a table
to understand the total number of trips
for each day of the week
let me run this
you can see in april 2014
wednesdays had the highest number of
drips which is around 1 lakh 8 000
while sundays had the lowest 51
251.
now that makes sense because sunday is a
holiday in new york and people would
like to spend time at home
now let's visualize the pivot table in
the form of a bar plot
so
i'll write
uber underscore week
underscore
data
dot
i'll use the plot function
inside plot function i'll give kind
is bar so i want a bar plot
and i'll define my figure
size and i'll give
equal to
let's say
8 comma 6
run this cell
there you go
as we saw above wednesday had the
highest number of uber pickups while
sunday had the lowest
similarly
let's visualize the bookings based on
our of the day so i have created a pivot
table and then i am trying to plot a
line graph
let's run this
ok
you can see the trend
at midnight
the number of trips are less
it slowly increases early in the morning
and during the evening time
uber bookings are higher
so you can see around
4 in the afternoon to
7 in the evening uber trips attain a
peak and trips gradually decrease after
8 pm in the evening
moving ahead
let's now analyze the number of uber
bookings based on each day in the april
month of 2014.
so i have created my pivot table and
then i'm trying to plot a bar graph you
can see i have kind equal to bar
let's run this
okay
we have our bar graph ready
now this bar graph depicts
30th of april had the highest number of
uber bookings
followed by
4th of april that is this one
now i can
show you in the next two cells of code
now in the current cell
we are basically counting the number of
trips for each day in april month
i have grouped each day number using the
group by function and used the apply
function to count rows
let's run it
so i have all the day numbers listed and
the total number of trips that were made
for each day of the month
now let me sort the bookings for each
day in ascending order
so i'll write
by underscore date
underscore
sorted
equal to
by underscore
date
dot
i'll use the function sort underscore
values
now to display i'll again use by
underscore
date
underscore
sorted
let me run it
now we have
arranged this in ascending order
the results tell us that
20th of april had the lowest number of
trips while
30th of april had the highest
followed by
4th of april now you can also create a
histogram to analyze the pickups by ours
let's run this cell
i've used the hist function for this
okay
so we have our histogram ready
now this histogram is similar to
the line graph that we plotted above
this one
now let's create a cross table to
analyze uber bookings based on day of
weeknum and r of t
so here i have used group by function
split function apply as well as unstack
function
let me run this
there you go so this is my
cross table ready on the top we have day
of
week num that is 0 for monday 1 for
tuesday
2 for wednesday
5 for saturday 6 for sunday
and then here we have the r of day
now let me tell you how to read this
table for example
at 11 am
on tuesday there were
2949 trips
if i scroll down
let's consider
this one
at 2 pm
on
sundays there were 2 934
trips
let's move on to our final section of
the demo
here we'll create a heat map to analyze
bookings in terms of hour of day and day
of week number
for this i am using
sns.heatmap function
the brightest spot will tell the day or
the r
with the highest frequency of trips
let's run this
there you go
we have a nice heat map ready
the dark regions depict the frequency of
trips where less
while the bright regions so the highest
number of trips
so if i come down
these are the bright regions
so if you look at this heat map we can
conclude
that
5 pm
on
wednesdays had the maximum number of
trips because this region is the
brightest
and now let us focus on benefits of
using r
why do companies extensively use r for
data analysis and why is it chosen
firstly r is an open source programming
language which means that there is no
license required to work with r
and r does not require you to have a
coding experience which means that a
non-technical person in your team can
also learn r very easily and start
coding or building models in few lines
of codes
r can also be used with other
programming languages such as java c
plus plus and pythons
and integration of r with other
programming tools or bi tools is very
simple and easy
and various statistical models are
readily available in r which also means
that there are plenty of inbid libraries
and packages already available and
reporting the results of an analysis
becomes easier by using these inbuilt
packages and for creation of these
models in just simple few lines code
with this understanding of the benefits
of fusing r let us quickly hop on to our
studio and start performing the hands-on
exercise for data analysis
for this exercise we will use a data set
named as demographics which is in a dot
csv file type
firstly let us load the data set to
rstudio and we will locate this in a
variable named as demo
we also refer to this as a data frame
and now you will notice that a variable
is created in an environment section
which is in the bottom right hand side
of the rstudio window
and this particular variable comprises
of 510 observations or records with
eight variables
let us simply
expand this particular data frame and
have a quick check on the data structure
and understand the data types
this particular data frame includes
variables such as age
marital
income
the unit of income is dollar per day
education levels
the car price car category with several
levels
gender
and retired status
now let us view the top six records of
this particular data set
for this let's simply type head of demo
and the result is now visible in the
console section
if you're interested to view all the
records then simply type view of demo
and this new window will show you every
single record that is being loaded to
our studio
you may also simply apply the filters
and the filter section here on
individual categorical variables
now that we have loaded the data set and
also viewed individual records let us
focus on creating subsets of records by
applying filters on individual variables
or multiple variables
so firstly let us apply filter on gender
we will only retrieve the records where
gender is equal to female and we will
locate these records in a variable named
as demo2
as you notice now in the environment
section the second variable is also
created that is demo and this now is
comprising of 250 observation which
means the records are filtered down to
only gender female
next let us see how to apply a filter on
income variable
let us only retrieve the records where
income is greater than hundred
let's view the result
as we say here all the records include
income greater than 100.
now let us modify this query
and
we will ensure that the retrieved
records includes
income greater than 100
and also specific variables are returned
let's say we only want to have
the first variable third variable and
the seventh variable returned as the
result
let's have a quick check
so we only have the first
third and the seventh variable returned
how about we only exclude
the variable
six to eight
for this we include a prefix of minus
sign
and now let us see what is the result
we have the variables from first to the
fifth variable however we don't have 6 7
and 8 variable
i hope it's clear so far
yes
all right
now let us see how can we apply
condition by including both the
variables that is gender and income and
then we will filter the record and
create a subset of data
now let's view the result
income is greater than 100
and the gender is only female
this is one way of creating subsets
however now let us see how to use the
subset command and create the subset
let's create a subset of records
by applying filter marital status
and age
we'll only retrieve records where
marital status is equal to married
and age is greater than 35.
let's now view the result
so here we have the age greater than 35
and marathon status is married
let's use the same code
and this time we will retrieve selected
variables let's say variables ranging
from 1 to 3.
let's have a quick check
so there are three variables
age is greater than 35 and marathon
status is married
now let us see how to structure the data
by sorting the data frame in ascending
and in descending order
we will apply this order function on the
variable income
firstly let us see how to order income
variable in ascending order
let's do a quick check
and here we have income in ascending
order
now let's see
how to
modify the same code and view the
records
with income in descending order
so we have now the income in descending
order how about include two variables
and sort the variables accordingly
firstly we will sort
the records
by ordering income and age in ascending
order
let's quickly view the result we have
income in ascending and age as well in
ascending
let's now modify this code
this time
we will
order
income in descending
and age in ascending
let us view the result
so the income is in descending and age
is in ascending order
so hope this is clear on how to solve
the data frame by ascending and
descending order per variable or by
using multiple variables with this we
will focus on learning statistical
analysis
how to perform statistical analysis on
individual variable or multiple variable
let's start by understanding the data
distribution of variable income
so that we identify what is the minimum
value of income what is the maximum what
is the range what is median what is the
mean
and we will also focus on the quantile
distribution
which is also analyzed in a box plot
what is the minimum
value
in the variable income
it's 9
and what is the maximum
so we have the maximum value
now let us see what's the range
so the range shows you the result with
minimum and the maximum value
how about
the difference of maximum
and the minimum
now let us focus on other summaries of
data distribution for this variable
income
let's identify what is the mean value of
income
the mean is 78.
let's also understand what is the
standard deviation
all right so the standard deviation is
112 dollar
let us see
what is the variance the variance should
be larger
than
the standard deviation
now let's see what is the
median absolute deviation
as you notice here
the median absolute deviation value is
lower than standard deviation
why do we make this comparison
from this it is evident
that median absolute deviation is robust
to outliers and standard deviation is
sensitive to outliers and also to the
change in the mean value
now let us understand the quantile
distribution this is the same analysis
that is visualized in a box plot ranging
from zero percent to hundred percent
identifying the individual data points
and we can also refer and compare this
to the min the max and the median values
let us quickly see what is the median
value
of income
as you notice here the median is 45
as well the 50th percent of quantile is
45
which means zero percent is minimum and
hundred percent is the maximum value
number of your question is what is 25
and 75 percent
this is again used for identifying the
range of interquartile
the interquartile range is nothing but
the difference of 75 percent minus the
25 percent
let's quickly see what is the iqr
of income
the iqrf income is 58.
let us do a quick check
five percent of quantile is eighty six
and in five percent of quantile is
twenty eight
and the value is fifty eight which is
equal to the iqr result
now that we have focused on the
statistical analysis of the individual
variables data distribution
let us focus on the data visualization
in this we will have a pictorial
representation of analysis to identify
the outliers to see what is the minimum
and where do we see the data densely
populated and how is it scattered
etcetera
we will begin with creating a histogram
now histogram can be used for univariate
analysis
which means in this scenario we will
consider
income variable and we will see how the
count of income ranges gets distributed
in a histogram
for this we will have to
install a package called as ggplot2 and
also call this library ggplot
let us install the package
now let us call the library
all right
and we are ready now to begin with
visualization
for this we will use the geometric
object histogram
on the data demo data frame
let me expand this window
so that the code is
visible and also use an aesthetic
mapping
for variable income
this will be helpful for filling colors
or filtrations etc
and only include 30 bins
with individual bin size width
of 100 which means there will be 100
incomes in individual bins
let's quickly look at the distribution
of this histogram
as you notice there are couple of
outliers
the counts of these income range are
very limited
however we see the densely populated
income ranges
with higher counts
between 0 to 200
dollars per day
this is also a way to identify and
segment the customers
based on their income ranges
now let us see how to change the color
of this histogram and also the border of
the histogram
for this we will include some additional
options
such as fill
fill with blue color
and the border color
is black
now as you notice here the executed code
provides us the histogram with blue
color bars and black color border lines
now we will focus on creating a facet
grid
facing grid is also an aesthetic mapping
object
we will see how to enable the multiple
histograms across the marital status and
the genders
so that we identify how the income is
distributed for individual marital
status as well the genders
let's zoom this view and have a look at
it
as you notice here there are some
interesting outliers here in the data
distribution
female unmarried drawing higher income
and male
unmarried and married also drawing
higher income as compared to the females
whereas if you notice that the female
unmarried is drawing much higher income
than the male
this may also be very much related to
the age
now let us see how to create a stacked
histogram when i say a stacked histogram
i mean instead of filling the color we
will fill the gender
so that there is a stack within the
histogram
so as you notice here i have made couple
of changes
i have included fill equal to gender
within the aesthetic mapping now let us
look at this histogram as you see here
the gender is filled in the histogram
hence we have stacked distribution of
female and the male
now let us focus on creating a bar chart
with education versus income where we
can identify the education levels and
the income ranges for these education
levels
as you notice here we are going to
create a visualization where we have the
aggregation in form of mean
and the geometric object used here is
bar plot now let's zoom this view and
understand which education level
have higher average income
so as we see here the blue color bar is
the post undergraduate degree
which means this education level draws
higher average income as compared to
other
education levels
now let's create a histogram where we
will see car price and the number of
cars for individual category
let's look at this visualization
this visualization provides some
interesting insight just by looking at
the distribution of the car prices and
the counts of the cars
at
the car category economy and even the
luxury
luxury car category or car price is
pretty much distributed whereas economy
car category is tensed which means that
we could also look back into the income
and age variables and try to figure out
furthermore insights and then segment
the customers for further targeting of
these customers
now what happens if we simply change
this bin width to 30.
as you observe here
changing the bin width or increasing the
bin width will also reduce the number of
bins
now we only have four bins here
and the car category is filled
that is what we have enabled within the
aesthetic mapping
and we see some more interesting insight
as you look at the standard and the
luxury car category
the car prices are pretty much
overlapping
for the car category luxury and standard
this could be the starting car price of
the luxury brands
now let us create
a clustered bar chart
let's look at this visualization
in this visualization
as you observe though we have enabled
fill equal to gender in the aesthetic
mapping we do not have the view in
stacked form but we have the bars one
besides the other
it is also because we have enabled a
position called as position equal to
dodge
in the code
now what is the inside that we can draw
from this visualization
as you see post graduate degree with
female gender
is drawing
higher average income as compared to any
other education level
now let us see how to create a box plot
for variable income across the genders
so the box plot can be enabled if there
is a bivariate analysis to be performed
on a continuous variable and a
categorical variable
or multiple categorical variables with a
continuous variable
now let's look at this visualization
what does this say
we have data distribution of income
for individual genders that is for
female and the male
and we also notice outliers here
anything above this whisker is
considered to be outliers
it might make more sense if we also
include some coloring for these outliers
maybe also enable shape
now we have colored the outliers
and it's colored
orange let's see if we can also enable
the shapes
and now we have here the outlier color
as well the shape enabled
now let us see how to enable a violin
plot
what is the utility of violin plot with
the box plot we understand the analysis
and the distribution of the data points
is to identify the outliers to know what
is the minimum value what is the max
what is the median and what are the
outliers
but what is the purpose of a violin plot
let us have a quick check
as you observe there is some
concentration of data points in the
bottom of every car category
however the concentration is higher for
standard car category as compared to
economy and the luxury
now this is an interesting insight that
you wouldn't have come across in box
plot the box plot is a very good
representation for identifying outliers
however violent plot will help you focus
on the nuances which is not captured by
the box plot
we can also simply combine the box plot
and the violin plot together
simply include this jaw
object
let's zoom this
now you have a representation of box
plot and the violin plot both combined
in a single visualization
interestingly you notice the outliers as
well the concentration in the bottom of
this violin plot so this could be some
interesting insights that you draw and
focus on these data points and
understand what exactly is happening
there
now let's focus on the density plot that
is density estimate of the histograms
rather than just viewing the frequencies
now we see the frequency in the y-axis
across the income distributions
how about enabling the probability as
true
so that we enable the density instead of
the frequency
so now we have the density in the y-axis
and in the x-axis we still have the
income distribution
this is the way of also adding a line
plot which is a density plot on the
histogram now as you observe here the
density plot is not in the same level as
the bar so let us adjust this line
for this we will include
adjust
let's say equal to 3 and now let us see
how the visualization appears now the
density plot is on the same level as the
bar
now let us see how to create a cross
table
for car category
and gender
for this let us call the library descr
now let us create the visualization
enabling cross table for car category
and
gender
let's look at the result in console
as you see here now we see the counts of
the gender for individual car category
the values over here represents that
there are 67 females
falling within the car category economy
and 80 males within the card category
economy
and for luxury we see that the count of
female is higher than the male
as well the proportions now how do you
understand what proportions are
presented here
we may simply turn off some of the
proportions like the t-test the
chi-square etc let us see how to enable
that
now let's look at the result
this looks better
now that we have the counts the female
counts and the male counts across
individual car category we also see the
percentages
rather than just looking at the absolute
value so there are
45.6 percentage of female within the car
category economy and 54.4 percentage of
mail within the car category economy
similarly across rest of the car
categories
this kind of cross table or a
contingency table is also helpful when
you want to analyze the different
categorical variables and identify the
counts or the proportions
now let us see how to use a scatter plot
of age versus income
scatter plot is a visualization used for
bivariate analysis when you want to
perform some analysis between two
continuous variable at a data point
level rather than performing the
analysis at an aggregated level such as
sum or main
and now we have a scatter plot of age
versus the income age in the x-axis and
income in the y-axis
though we do not see any kind of a
positive correlation or a negative
correlation but we still see some
interesting insights over here
some of the data points are pretty much
scattered and much away from densely
populated data points
i hope the learning has been informative
and interesting so far we have covered
the concepts of data analytics as well
we have performed some hands-on doing
some statistical analysis and also
creating interesting visualization
hi everyone
welcome to this section of our
programming let's learn about data
manipulation in r
and here we will learn about
d player package
and when we talk about this d player
package it is much faster and much
easier to read than base r
so d player package is used to transform
and summarize tabular data with rows and
columns you might be working on a data
frame or you might be getting in a
inbuilt r data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get this package deployer by just
calling in library function
and this can be used for grouping by
data summarizing the data adding new
variables selecting different set of
columns filtering our data sets sorting
it selecting it arranging it or even
mutating that is basically creating new
columns using functions on existing
variables so let's see how we work with
dplyer now here
i can basically get the package here so
i can just say
install dot packages d plier now we
already see the the package here which
is showing up so i will just select this
one i can do a control enter and that
will basically set up the package
package player successfully unpacked
so that is done now you can start using
this package by just doing a library d
plier and this was built it shows me my
version of r
so let's also use a inbuilt data set
that is new york flights 13 so we can do
install dot packages and that will
search and get that relevant data set
i can again call it by using library
function
now once that is done we can look at
some sample data here by just doing view
flights and that shows me the data in a
neat and a tabular format which shows me
year month day
departure time schedule departure time
and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data
which can help us in understanding the
data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here
it shows me how many variables we have
so this is fine now we can start using
deployer and
in that we can use
say filter function if we would want
to look in for specific value now here
we have the column as month so i will do
a filter now i'm creating a variable f1
i'm using the filter function
on flights
which we already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically
look at the month where the month value
is 0 7
so let's look at that
and this one
you can do a view on f1 which shows me
the data wherein you have filtered out
all the data based on month being 7.
so this is a simple usage of filter we
can take some other example we may want
to include multiple columns so we can
say f2 filter
flights and here we will say month
is equal to seven day is three and then
look at the value of f2 if you are
interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month is seven
and days three you could also look into
a more readable format by using view on
f2 and that gives me my selected result
so we are just extracting in some
specific value we can keep extending
this so here we can say flights
is what we would want to work on i'm
using the filter function so i can
straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view i can also do a view in
this way i can just pass in my filter
within the view and within this i am
saying filter
i would want to look at the flights
month being 0 9 day being 2 and origin
being lga
and then that shows me the value here
and obviously you can scroll and look at
all the columns and if you see the
origin column it shows the selected
value so now we have filtered out our
data based on values
in three different columns
now
what we can also do is we can use and or
we can use or operators so i could have
done this
in a a little different way so i could
have said head which shows me
initial result i will do a flight so
within my head function i am passing in
this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights and in this flights data
set you would want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we given a value and i'll
say and and i'll again say flights
wherein i will select the day being two
and and and remember when you talk about
and it is going to
check if all the values are met true so
then you say flights origin
lg a and you look at the value so in
this way i can
filter out
specifically multiple values by
specifying columns now we could have
done it in this way we could have
created a view or we could have assigned
this to a variable and then done a view
on that where we could have selected
month being day and origin or you can be
more
specific
in specifying all the columns it makes
the code more readable so let's look at
the values and here you are looking at
head which shows me based on month
day and then you can look for further
columns for other variables that is
origin being lga
now what we can also do is we can do
some slicing here to select rows by
particular position
so i can say slice and i would want to
look at
rows one two five and i can do this
so you can always assign or look at the
view of this
i can just do
here so when i did a slide 1 is to 5 it
shows me
my entries
for 1 to 5. now similarly we can do is
slice 5 to 10
and now you are looking at
5 to 10 values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to apply some variable on a
particular data set and then you would
want to
add it to
your
existing data frame or you would want to
add a new column so this is where you
use
mutate which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you work on
mutate
so it's pretty simple so you create a
variable over delay now i would want to
do a mutate so that it adds a new column
so i'm selecting my data which is flight
i will call the new column as overall
delay and then basically
i can look at
overall delay being arrival delay minus
departure delay so let's create this and
let's look at view of this which shows
me
or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay which was not in
my original data set so you can anytime
do a head on this one to compare the
value so this one shows me arrival delay
and then there are many other variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view
and you could have just look at flights
if you would want to compare
so you can look at the flights and this
one would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here
and if you
do a view on overall delay then that
basically shows me 20 columns so we know
that the new column has been added
to
this overall delay so if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show only the
new column so we can do an overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay
the computation remains same but at this
time if i look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value and then
we can decide if we would want to add it
to our existing structure
now you can also use summarize
and summarize basically helps us in
getting a summary
based on certain criteria so we can
always do a
summarize
and
what we can do is we can look at our
data
and we can say on what basis we would
want to summarize this particular data
so we can do a summarize function now
summarize on flights i will say average
a time
and i would want to calculate an average
so for that i'm using inbuilt function
called mean
i will do that on airtime column
so
let's look at flights once again and
here we can see there is
arrival time not a time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this so what i'll do
is i will use the summarize function
i will say average airtime and this one
i will look at mean of a time so let's
see if there is a airtime column i might
be
let's look at this one and i will delay
and yes we have an airtime so we were
actually looking at summarizing based on
air time not the arrival time
so air time is how much time it takes in
air for this particular fight and we
will want to use the trans summarize
function not the transmute so summarize
flights average a time and this one we
will calculate the mean of average a
time
and
i will also do a any removal which is
i'm saying true so let's do this and
that basically shows me the average a
time is 151
i can also do a total a time where i am
doing a summation of values or i can get
the standard deviation
or i can basically
get multiple values such as mean
i can say total airtime where i am doing
a summation
and then i can look at other values
which is if you would want to put in
standard deviation here you could do
that so let's look at the result of this
summarize and this basically allows me
to get some useful information which is
summarized based on
a particular function such as mean sum
standard deviation or
all three of them
now
let's look at grouping by so sometimes
we may be interested in summarizing the
data by groups and that's where we use
the group by function so we can always
use
the group by clause
now
here we are taking a different data set
so we will say for example let's look at
head of mt
cars
and that is basically my data set on
empty cars now that shows me the model
of the car
it shows me my lathe cylinder power this
and your horsepower
and various other characteristics or
variables in this particular data set
so here
we can say let's do a grouping by gear
so there is a column called gear so i
will call it by gear i will look at my
data set and then what i'm using here
which you see with these percentage and
greater symbol
is called
piping
so that basically
feeds your previous data frame into next
one so this is sometimes useful and you
can get this by just saying control
shift and m and you can then use this so
we are going to have
piping so i am saying empty cars now
this is my original data set where i did
a head
or i could have done a view on this one
if you would want to see it in a more
readable format and that basically shows
me the data
so we are using a different data set so
i want to group it by the gear column so
i'm going to call it by gear
and
this one takes my data that is empty
cars i'm using the piping and then i'm
saying group the data based on gear
column that's done now let's look at the
value of by gear
or
you can always do a view so remember
whenever you're doing a group by it is
giving you a
internal object where your data is
grouped based on a particular column
so we can look at the values here you
can do a view that shows you your data
grouped based on a particular column
now i can again use the summarize
function
where i would want to now work on the
new one where it was grouped based on
gear so i am doing a summarize and here
i am going to say gear1 which will be
having the value of summation on the
gear column
and then i'm saying gear 2 which is mean
well you could give some meaningful
names to this
and let's look at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is some and mean values
based on the gear
similarly we can use look at different
example so we can say by gear
and i am again using piping
but earlier we had taken gear
we had grouped the data
and we called it by gear so we took our
original data set empty cars but now
within this particular data which was
grouped by gear
i will take this data set i will use the
piping and i will summarize it where i
am saying
within this particular data set i would
want to get the sum or i would want to
get the mean and then you can look at
the values
so what you are doing is
you are
either looking at your original data set
or you are looking at the data which was
already grouped and then you can look at
the values
now here what we can do is we can group
by cylinder say might be you are
interested in looking at data which is
summarized based on the cylinder column
you can do that and then for this by
cylinder i am doing a piping where i am
using the summarize function and
summarizing will then be done based on
the mean values of the gear column or
the horsepower
so let's do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point you may want to look
at the data set again so just go ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain
and
by cylinder or by gear and do a head and
it gives you the value so you can always
do some summarizing or grouping in these
ways
now here we are going to use sample
underscore n function and sample
underscore
fraction for creating samples
so for this
let's take the flights data set again
and we would want to
get 15 random values now that is done
and it shows me 15 rows with some random
values from the data
what you can also do is you can do a
portion of data by using sample
underscore
fraction and here i'll say flights i'll
say 0.4 which will return 40 percent of
the total data so this can be useful
when you are building your machine
learning where you would want to split
your data into training and test might
be you are interested in some portion of
the data so you can do this
which is very useful function
and then you can look at the value of
that now
what we can also do is we can use a
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were
trying to pull out a particular column
so in the same way we can use a range
which is a convenient way of sorting
than your base are sorting so for a
range function
let's do a view
based on a range so we will work on the
flights data set which we have
and here what we would want to do is we
would want to arrange the flights data
set which is based on year and departure
time and we are doing a view out of it
so that basically
gives me the data
which is arranged based on
your year and departure time now i can
do a head to give me
some highlighting of that data
now
the piping operator what we are using
can be used in these ways also so here i
will say df i will just assign the data
set empty cars to it let's look at the
df which has basically your different
models you can obviously
look at the head or view of it to look
at useful information we can also go for
nesting options which can be useful so
we are
creating a variable called result here
now that has the arrange function
so
what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange to
sort the data
so i would want to sort the data but
what data would i sort so i will use
sample n
which will give me some portion of the
data or some sample data now what is
that sample data so here we are using
nesting that is
earlier when we did a sample we just
said data and how many random samples we
want but instead of giving that what we
are going to do is we are going to use
filter here
now this filter will work on df
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20
i will say size is 5 and i would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so i'm using the des
on this particular mileage column by
default it is always ascending
so let's get the result out of this
which will basically show me the mileage
details in a descending order so this is
my data frame
and now
we can look at the result what we have
created
so just do a view or do a head
and look at the view so here you see
mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have
not only used an inbuilt function
we have not only arranged the data that
is we have sorted the data but we have
sorted the data based on a descending
order on a particular column we have
said the value should be greater than 20
and we have also said we just need five
random samples
now let's look at some other examples so
you can always do a multi assignment
so i can say filter
wherein i am going to use
df which was assigned empty cars
i am going to say mileage should be
greater than 20 then i say b which is
going to get a sample out of a
and i just want five random values so
let's look at that so we have b which is
going to get a
set of five values from a
now i will create a result variable
which will arrange b which is sample
data in a descending order now let's
look at the result of this and that
basically shows me what we were seeing
earlier so you can do a multi assignment
where you can create a variable get a
sample out of it and then basically
whatever is that result you can arrange
that or sort that in a descending or by
default ascending order
so same thing we can do it using pipe
operator
so piping
so here i will say result
i'm passing in my df that's the data set
i'm using piping and which basically
tells what you need to do on this
particular data set so i'm going to
filter out the data based on mileage 50
sorry mileage 20 then i'm going to push
that
or forward it to get the random sample
and whatever is this random sample is
going to be pushed
so you are arranging this in a
descending order so this is one more way
of doing it and then basically you can
look at the result so these are some
simple examples where you can use your d
plier with multiple assignments or using
your nesting to filter out the data
you can also do a
arrange which is to sort the data you
can get some random samples out of it
you can summarize the data
you can also
summarize the data based on one or two
or multiple columns and you can use some
inbuilt functions to summarize the data
based on some
functions which are applied on the
variables or on the columns
you can transmute it
where you would be interested in only
looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it
and you can give the conditions where
you can say and on or
to filter out the data
so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example df where i have my data
let's look at this one
and if i just do a df at this point it
shows me my data set
and if you would be interested only in
particular column
then your d player also allows you to
either we can do a filter or we can
simply do a select
now for selecting we can choose
uh our data so for example i'll say df
underscore i'm interested in mileage i'm
interested in horsepower
might be i'm interested in
your cylinders in this
and for this one what i can do is when i
would want to do a select i can
basically say
selected df
let's call it some name
i can say
control shift m
which is for piping
and then basically what you can do is
you can do a select
and you can choose your columns so i was
interested in mileage i was interested
in
horsepower
i was interested in cylinder and here
what i'm doing is i'm using a select
where i can look at the new data frame
so let's do this
and
i'm sorry here we will have to give it
df this is where you are passing in your
data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one by just
doing a df
or
head
on df
underscore
mileage horsepower cylinder and look at
the selected result so you can be
looking at selective columns i could
have done this filter but filter will
always look for a condition say your
mileage is greater than 20 or might be
your cylinders are more than 4 or
something else but when you do a select
you are selecting specific columns
so view always gives you all the columns
head gives you highlight but then select
can be useful when we are interested in
looking at only specific data so this is
how you can use dplyer for manipulation
for your data transformation for
basically filtering out the data
by selecting particular data and then
working on it so similarly there is one
more package called tidr and we'll see
how we can use data manipulation
done using your tie dr package
let's
learn about that idr package it makes it
easy to tidy your data
and this basically helps you creating a
more cleaner data
so
which is easy to visualize and model now
this comes with mainly four functions so
you have gather which makes
your data wide or it makes white data
longer so that is basically used to
stack up multiple columns
you have spread function which makes
long data wider that is stacking the
data together or stack
if you would want to unstack the data to
data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes
and then your spread can spread the data
across multiple columns
you have separate which is function
which splits single column into multiple
columns
and to complement that you have one more
function which is unite and that
combines multiple columns into single
columns so these are four main functions
which are used in your idr package so
let's look how we work with this
so let me bring up my r studio here now
for this first is let me just clean up
my screen here doing a control l
so i will install the package it is
already installed but we can just do a
control enter
and then
i can say do you want to restart our
prior to reinstall
install i'll say okay
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says package ti
ti dyr that is idr has been successfully
unpacked let's use that package
using our library function
and that was built under our version 3.6
now i can basically
start using these functions so for
example here we are creating a data
frame so let's say n is 10
and then we basically would say
we will call it white
now that's the variable name i'm using
the data.frame function
i'm saying id which will be
1 to n so that will take the values from
1 to 10 and then these are the values
which have
10 entries so this is a vector phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 let's create a data
frame out of it now that's done we can
have a look at our data frame by just
doing a view wide and that shows me the
id column and it has face dot one phase
dot two and face dot three now we can
use our function so for example we can
work with gather that is reshaping the
data from wide format to long format and
basically you can say stacking up
multiple columns
so let's see how we do that here i'll
call it long i'm working on white i'm
using the piping
functionality and then i'm using gather
so this one i will say what will be the
data which i will use
so we are using wide as a data frame
then i am saying response time so that
will be basically one more column
and then you have your columns which you
would want to
basically stack so i'm saying from phase
one to phase three so let's do this
and once this is done let's have a look
at our variable long
so this one shows me that i have an id
column
i have the response time column and i
have the face column which we mentioned
and that basically has all the values
stacked in so you have face dot one face
dot two and face dot three so all the
columns are being stacked here so all my
data so now i have totally 30 entries in
this one so this is basically using your
gather function now sometimes we may
want to use
a separate function now separate
function is basically splitting a single
column
into multiple columns so which we
would want to use when multiple
variables are captured in a single
variable column okay so let's look at an
example of this one so let's say long
separate that's what we will call we
will work on this long which has all the
data stacked in
as the columns we selected then i'm
saying separate
i want the face column and then i would
say
when i separate the columns what are my
column names now i could also give a
separator by giving a comma and then
mentioning the separator if that is
required so let's do this
now once this is done let's have a look
at our long separate so what we see here
is the
column which we used so we were doing a
face column and that was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
target and number so that's what we see
here so you have face being split into
target and number and then you have the
response time so this is how you use the
separate function now there is also
something called as unite function which
is basically a complementing of separate
function so it takes multiple columns
and combines the elements to a single
column so for example here
we will
call it long unite
and we will take long separate which was
separating the data we want to unite so
we will take phase target
number
and we want to have a separator between
them so let's basically do this
and now let's look at the result of this
unite
so you see you have the face and target
merged together so you have face dot one
the separator is dot as we have
mentioned and we have united multiple
columns
so
this is one more function of your ti dr
which helps you
basically
tidy up your data or put it in a
particular way
now then you have your spread function
and this is basically for unstacking so
that is
if you have if you would want to convert
a stack to data or if you would want to
unstack the data which is of same
attributes spread can be used so that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns
so it will take two columns say key and
value and spread it into multiple
columns so it makes long data wider so
we can look at this one we will say long
unite
i'm using the piping i will use the
spread function i'll work on the face
column and response time and let's do
this and then let's do a view on this
so it tells me our data is back in the
shape as it was in the beginning so
these are four functions
which are very helpful when we work with
idr package welcome to this video
tutorial on introduction to sql by
simplyloan
in this session we are going to learn
about databases
how data is stored in relational
databases and we'll also look at some of
the popular databases
finally we'll understand various sql
commands on mysql server
now let's get started with what is a
database
so according to oracle a database is an
organized collection of structured
information or data that is typically
stored electronically in a computer
system
a database is usually controlled by a
database management system or dbms
so it is a storage system that has a
collection of data
relational databases store data in the
form of tables that can be easily
retrieved managed and updated
you can organize data into tables rows
columns and index it to make it easier
to find relevant information
now talking about some of the popular
databases
we have mysql database we also have
oracle database then we have mongodb
which is a nosql database
next we have microsoft sql server next
we have apache casendra which is a free
and open source nosql database and
finally we have postgresql
now
let's learn
what is sql so sql is a domain specific
language to communicate with databases
sql was initially developed by ibm
most databases use structured query
language or sql for writing and querying
data sql commands help you to store
process analyze and manipulate databases
with this
let's look at what a table is
so this is how a table in a database
looks like
so here you can see
the name of the table is players
on the top you can see the column names
so we have the player id the player name
the country to which the player belongs
to and we also have the goals scored by
each of the players so these are also
known as fields in a database
here each row represents a record or a
tuple
so if you have the player id which is
103 here the name of the player is
daniel
he is from england and the number of
goals here score is 7. so you can use
sql commands to query update insert
records and do a lot of other tasks
there are mainly four types of sql
commands
so first we have data definition
language or ddl
so ddl commands change the structure of
the table like creating a table deleting
a table or altering a table all the
commands of ddl are auto committed which
means it permanently save all the
changes in the database
we have create alter drop and truncate
as ddl commands
next
we have data manipulation language or
dml
so dml commands are used to modify a
database it is responsible for all forms
of changes in the database dml commands
are not auto committed which means it
can't permanently save all the changes
in the database
we have select
update
delete and insert as dml commands now
select command is also referred to as
dql or data query language third we have
data control language or dcl
so dcl commands allow you to control
access to data within the database
these dcl commands are normally used to
create objects related to user access
and also control the distribution of
privileges among users
so we have grant and revoke which are
the examples of data control language
finally we have something called as
transaction control language or tcl
so tcl commands allow the user to manage
database transactions
commit and roll back our example of tcl
now let's see the basic sql command
structure
so first
we have the select statement
so here you specify the various column
names that you want to fetch from the
table we write the table name using the
from statement
next
we have the where clause to filter out
our table based on some conditions so
you can see here where condition 1
condition 2 and so on
then we have the group by clause that
takes various column names so you can
write group by column 1 column 2 and so
on
next we have the having clause to filter
out tables based on groups
finally we have the order by clause to
filter out the result in ascending or
descending order now talking about the
various data types in sql
so we have
exact numeric which has integer small
end bit and decimal
then we have
approximate numeric
which are float and real then we have
some date and time data type such as
date time time stamp and others
then we have string data type which
includes car this varchar and text
finally we have binary data type
and binary data types have binary
var binary and image
now let's see some of the various
operators that are present in sql
so first we have our basic arithmetic
operators so you have addition the
subtraction multiplication division and
modulus
then we have some logical operators like
all and any or between exists and so on
finally we have some comparison
operators such as equal to not equal to
this greater than less than greater than
equal to or less than equal to not less
than or not greater than
now let me take you to my mysql
workbench where we will learn to write
some of the important sql commands use
different statements functions data
types and operators that we just learned
now let me now go ahead and open my
mysql workbench
so in the search bar i'll search for
mysql workbench you can see i'm using
the 8.0 version
i'll click on it and
here it says welcome to mysql workbench
and below under connections you can see
i have already created a connection
which says local instance then you have
the root the local host and the port
number
let me click on it
you can see the service the username is
root and i'll enter my password
and hit ok
now this will open the sql editor
so this is how the mysql workbench looks
like
here
we learn some of the basic sql commands
so first let me show you the databases
that are already present
so the command is so databases
you can hit tab to autocomplete i'll use
a semicolon
i'll select this and here on the top you
can see the execute button so if i run
this
below you can see the output it says
show databases seven rows are returned
which means
currently there are seven databases
you can see the names
all right
now
let's say i want to see the tables that
are present inside this database called
world
so i'll use the command use
world which is the database name
now let me run it so currently i'm using
the world database
so to display the tables that are
present in the world database i can use
the show command
and write show tables
give a semicolon and i'll hit ctrl enter
this time to run it
all right so you can see the tables that
are present inside this
world database so we have three tables
in total city country and country
language
now
if you are to see the rows that are
present in one of the tables you can use
the select command
so i'll write select star which
basically means i want to display all
the columns so star here means to
display all the columns
then i'll write my
from
the table name that is
city
so this command is going to display me
all the rows that are present inside the
city table
so if i hit ctrl enter
all right you can see the message here
it says
thousand rows were returned which means
there were total thousand records
present inside the city table
so here you can see there's an id column
a name column this country code district
and population
all right
similarly you can check the structure of
the table by using the describe command
so i'll write describe
and then
i'll give the
table name that is city now let's just
run it
there you go the field shows the column
name so we have id name country code
district population
type here shows the data type of each of
the columns so district is character 20
id is an integer population is also
integer
null says yes or no which means if no
then there are no null values if it's
yes which means there are null values in
your table
key here represents whether you have any
primary key or foreign key
and these are some extra information now
let's learn how to create a table in
mysql so i'll use the create table
command for this and before that
let me create a database
and i'll name it as sql intro so the
command is create
database
and i'll give my database name that is
sql underscore intro
let me give a semicolon and hit control
enter
so you can see i have created a new
database
now
if i run this command that is show
databases
you can see this
newly created database that is sql intro
if i scroll down
there you go you can see the name here
sql intro
okay now within this database we'll
create a table called employee details
now this will have the details of some
employees
so let me first show you how to create a
table
that will be present inside the sql
intro database
so use the command create
table
and then
i'll give my
table name that is going to be employee
underscore
details
next
the syntax is
to give the column names so my first
column would be the name column which is
basically the employee name
followed by
the data type for this column since name
is a text column so i'll use
varchar
and i'll give a value of 25
so it can hold only 25 characters
okay
next
i also want the age of the employee
now age is always an integer
so i'll give int
okay
then
we can have the gender of the employee
so gender can be represented as f or m
for female and m for male so i'm using
the car data type or character data type
and i'll give the value as one
then let's have the
date of join
or doj and this is going to be of data
type date
all right
next
we'll have the city name that is the
city to which the employee belongs to
so again this is going to be worker
15
finally we'll have a salary column
and salary will keep it as float since
salary can be in
decimal numbers as well
now i will give a semicolon
all right so let me just quickly run
through it so first
i wrote my create command then the table
which is also a keyword
followed by
the table name which is employee details
here and then
we keep the column names such as name
age
this gender
date of join city and salary
for each of the columns we also give the
data type
all right so let me just run it
okay
so here you can see we have successfully
created our first table
now
you can use the describe command to see
the structure of the table
i'll write describe emp underscore
details
if i run this
there you go
so under field you can see the column
names then you have the data types
null represents if
the table can accept null values or not
and these are basically
empty
and we haven't set any default
constraint
all right
moving ahead
now let's learn to add data to our table
using the insert command so on a notepad
i have already
written my insert statement so let me
just copy it and then i'll explain it
one by one all right
so if you see this
so we have used an insert into statement
or a command
followed by
the table name that is emp details
then this is the syntax using values i
have passed in
all the records
so first we have jimmy which is the name
of the employee then we have 35 it
basically represents the age
then m means the gender or the sex then
we have the date of join
next we have the city to which the
employee belongs to and finally we have
the salary of the employee so this
particular information represents one
record or a tuple
similarly the next employee we have is
shane you can see the age and other
information
then we have
mary there's dwayne sarah and amy
all right
so let me go ahead and
run this
so this will help you insert
the values in the table that you have
created
you can see we have successfully
inserted six records
now
to display the records let me
use the select statement so i am using
select star from emp underscore details
if i run this
you can see my table here and the values
it has
so we have the name column the age
column the state of join city salary
and these are the values that you can
see here
moving ahead now let's say you want to
see the unique city names present in the
table
so in this case you can use the distinct
keyword along with the column name in
the select statement so let me show you
how you can print the distinct
city names that are present in our table
now if you notice this table clearly
we have chicago seattle boston austin
this new york and there's seattle
repeated again so i only want to print
the unique values
so for that i can write my select
statement as select
extinct
then i'll give my column name which is
city from
my table name that is emp details
if i run this
you can see
my query has returned five rows and
these are the values so we have chicago
seattle which was repeated twice is just
been shown once then we have boston
austin and new york
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now let's see how you can use inbuilt
aggregate functions in sql
so suppose you want to count the number
of employees in the table so in that
case you can use the count function in
the select statement so let me show you
how to do that
so i'll write
select
i'll use my function name that is count
now since i want to know the
total number of employees i am going to
use their name
inside the brackets from
employee underscore details
now if i run this
this will return the total number of
employees that are present in the table
so we have
6 employees in total
now if you see here in the result it
says count name now this column is
actually not readable at all
so what sql provides is something called
as an alias name so you can give an
alias to the resultant output so here
i can write select count of name
and use an alias as
as
i can give an alias as
count underscore name
and run this statement again
there you go you can see here in the
resultant
output we have the column name as count
name which was our alias name now
suppose you want to get the total sum of
salaries you can use another aggregate
function called sum
so i'll write my select statement
and this time instead of count i'm going
to write sum
and since i want to find the sum of
salaries
so inside the bracket i'll give my
salary column
from
my table name that is employee details
if i run this
this will result in the total sum of
salaries
so basically it adds up
all the salaries that were present in
the salary column
now let's say you want to find the
average salary so instead of sum you can
write the average function which is avg
so this will give you the average salary
from the column salary so you can see it
here this says average salary now if you
want you can give an alias name to this
as well now you can select specific
columns from the table by using the
column names in the select statement
so initially we were selecting all the
columns for example like
you saw here
the star represents that we want to see
all the columns from the employee
details table
now suppose you want to
see only specific columns you can
mention those column names in the select
statement
so let's say i want to
select
just the name
age
and the city column
from my table that is employee details
so this will result
in displaying only the name age and city
column
from the table if i run it there you go
it has given only three columns to me
now sql has a where clause to filter
rows based on a particular condition
so if you want to filter your table
based on specific conditions you can use
where clause
now where clause comes after
you give your table name
so suppose you want to find the
employees
with age greater than 30 in this case
you can use a where clause so let me
show you how to do it
i'll write select
star from
my table name that is
employee
details
and after this i'll use my where clause
so i'll write where
age
greater than
30.
if i run this
it will give me the output where the age
is only greater than 30 so it excluded
everything that is less than 30.
so we have four employees whose age is
greater than 30 here
now suppose you want to find only female
employees from the table you can also
use a where clause here
so i'll write
select
let's say i want only the name the
gender which is
sex here
comma city
from my table that is employee details
where
i'll give my column name that is sex is
equal to
since i want only the female employees
i'll give
f
and run this statement
okay you can see here
our employee table has three female
employees
now suppose you want to find the details
of the employees who belong to chicago
or austin
in this case you can use the or operator
now the or operator in sql displays a
record if any of the condition separated
by or is true
so let me show you what i mean
so since i want the employees who are
from chicago and austin
i can use
an or operator so i'll write select star
from
emp details which is my table name
then i'll give my where clause where
city
equal to
i'll give my
city name as chicago
and then i'm going to use the or
operator or
city
equal to
i'll write austin
i'll give a semicolon and let me run it
there you go
so in the output you can see all the
employees
who belong to the city chicago and
austin
now there is another way to write the
same sql query
so you can use an in operator to specify
multiple conditions
so
let me just copy this and instead of
using the or operator
this time i am going to use the in
operator
so i will delete this
after the where clause i am going to
write where city
and use the in operator
inside bracket
i'll give my city names as chicago
and i want
austin so i'll give a comma
and write my next city name that is
austin
so this query is exactly the same that
we wrote on top
let me run this
you will get the same output there you
go
so we have jimmy and duane who are from
chicago and austin respectively
now sql provides the between operator
that selects values within a given range
the values can be numbers text or dates
now suppose you want to find the
employees whose date of join was between
1st of jan 2000 and
31st of december 2010
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write select star from
emp details
where
my date of join that is doj
between
i'll give my two date values that is
first of
jan
2000
and
i'll give my
second value
the date value that is
31st of december 2010.
so every employee who has joined between
these two dates will be displayed in the
output
if i run it
we have two employees who had joined
between
2000 and 2010 so we have jimmy and mary
here who had joined in 2005 and 2009
respectively
all right
now in where clause you can use the and
operator to specify multiple conditions
now the and operator displays a record
if all the conditions separated by and
are true
so let me show you an example i'll write
select
star from
employee details table
where
i want the age to be greater than 30
and i want
sex to be
male
all right so here you can see i have
specified two conditions so if both the
conditions are true only then it will
result in an output
if i run it
you can see there are
two employees who are male
and their age is greater than 30.
now let's talk about the group by
statement in sql
so the group by statement groups rows
that have the same values into summary
rows like for example you want to find
the average salary of customers in each
department
now the group by statement is often used
with aggregate functions such as count
sum and average to group the result set
into one or more columns
let's say
we want to find the total salary of
employees based on the gender
so in this case you can use the group by
clause so i'll write
select
let's say
sex
comma
i want to find the total sum of salary
as
i'll give an alias name let's say total
salary
from
my table name that is employee details
next i am going to group it by sex
okay
let me run it
there you go
so we have two genders male and female
and here you can see the total salary so
what this sql statement did was first it
grouped all the employees based on the
gender and then it found the total
salary
now sql provides the order by keyword to
sort the result set in ascending or
descending order
now the order by keyword sorts the
records in ascending order by default
to sort the records in descending order
you can use the desc keyword
so let's say i want to sort my employee
details table
in terms of salary so i'll write select
star from
emp underscore
details
and i'll use my order by clause on the
salary column
so this will sort
all the records
in ascending order of the salary which
is by default you can see
the salary column is sorted in ascending
order
now suppose you want to sort the salary
column
and display it in descending order you
can use this keyword that is desc
let me run it
you can see the output now this time the
salary is sorted in descending order and
you have the other values as well now
let me show you some basic operations
that you can do using the select
statement so suppose i write select
and
do an addition operation let's say 10
plus 20
and i'll give an alias name as addition
if i run this
it will give me the sum of
10 and 20 that is 30.
similarly
you can use
the subtraction operator
and you can change the alias name as
let's say subtract
let's run it
you get -10
now there are some basic inbuilt
functions
there are a lot of inbuilt functions in
sql but here i'll show you a few suppose
you want to find the length of a
text or a string you can use the length
function
so i'll write select and then use the
length function i'll hit tab to auto
complete let's say i want to find the
length of
country india
and i'll give an alias as total
length
if i run it
you see here it returns 5 because there
are 5 letters
in india there's another function called
repeat so let me show you how repeat
works
so i'll write select
repeat
let's say i want to repeat the symbol
that is at the rate
i'll put it in single quotes because it
is a
text character
and i want to repeat this character for
10 times
close the bracket
and let's run it
you can see here in the output it has
printed at the rate 10 times you can
count it
all right
now let's say you want to convert a text
or a string to uppercase or lowercase
you can do that as well
so i'll write select and use the
function called upper
let's say i want to convert
my string that is india to uppercase
i am not giving in any alias name
if i run this
see my input was
capital i and everything else was in
small letter
in the output you can see it has
converted
my input to all caps
similarly you can change this
let's say you want to print something
lower case you can use the lower
function
let's say
this time everything is in
uppercase if i run it
it converts india to lower case
now let's explore a few date and time
functions let's say you want to find the
current date there's a function called
cur which stands for current
and
this is the function i'm talking about
which is current date
if i run this you will get the current
date
that is 28th of jan 2021
and let's say you want to extract the
day from a date value
so you can use
the day function let's say i'll use day
and i want to find the day from my
current date
if i run this
you get 28 which is today's
day now similarly you can also
display the current date and time
so for that you can use a function that
is called now
so this will return the current date and
time
you can see this is the date value and
then we have the current time
all right
and this brings us to the end of our
demo session
so let me just scroll through whatever
we have learned so first i showed you
how you can see the databases present in
mysql then we used one of the databases
and checked the tables in it then we
created another database called sql
intro for our demo purpose
we used that database and then
we created this table called employee
details with
column names like name integer the sex
date of join city and salary
i showed you the structure of the
database let me run this again so you
get an idea you can see this was the
structure of our table
then we went ahead and inserted a few
records so we inserted
records for six employees so you have
the employee name the age the gender the
date of join the city to which the
employee belongs to and the salary of
the employee
then we saw how you can use the select
statement and display all the columns
present in the table
we learned how you can
display the unique city names
we learnt how to use
different aggregate functions like count
average and sum
then we learned how you could display
specific columns from the table
we learned how to use where clause
then we used
an or operator we learned about
inoperator
the between operator
then we used an and operator to select
multiple
conditions
finally
we learnt about group by order by and
some basic
sql operations
we are going to learn two important sql
statements or clauses that are widely
used that is grouped by and having
first we will understand the basics of
group by and having and then
jump into mysql workbench to implement
these statements so let's begin
first
what is group by and sql
so the group by statement or clause
groups records into summary rows and
returns one record for each group it
groups the rows with the same group by
item expressions and computes aggregate
functions for the resulting group
a group by clause is a part of select
expression
in each group no two rows have the same
value for the grouping column or columns
now below
you can see the syntax of group by
so first we have the select statement
and then followed by the column names
that we want to select
from we have the table name
followed by the where condition
and next we have the group by clause
and here we include the column names
finally we have the order by and the
column names
now here is an example of the group by
clause
so we want to find the average salary of
employees for each department
so here you can see we have the
employees table it has the employee id
the employee name
the age of the employee we have the
gender
the date on which the employer joined
the company then we have the department
to which each of these employees belong
to we have the city to which the
employees belong to and then we have the
salary in dollars
so actually we'll be using this
employees table on mysql workbench as
well
so if you were to find the average
salary of employees in each department
so this is how your
sql query with group by clause would
look like
so we have selected department and then
we are using an aggregate function that
is avg which is average
and
we have chosen the salary column and
here we have given an alias name which
is average underscore salary which
appears in the output you can see here
from employees and we have grouped it by
department so here in the output you can
see
we have the department names and the
average salary of the employees in each
department
now let me take you to my mysql
workbench where we'll implement group by
and solve specific problems
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
okay so i am on my mysql workbench so
let me make my connection first
i'll enter the password
so this will open my sql editor
so first of all
let me
check the databases that i have
so i'll use my query that is show
databases
let's run it
okay you can see we have a list of
databases here
i'm going to use my
sql underscore intro database so i'll
write
use
sql underscore intro
so this will take us inside this
database i'll run it
all right
now you can check the
tables that are present in sql
underscore intro database
if i write show tables you can see the
list of tables that are already present
in this database to do our demo and
understand group by as well as having
let me first create an employee table
so i'll write create table
employees
next
i'll give my column name as employee
underscore id which is
the id for each employee
i'll give my data type as integer and
i'll assign
employee id as my primary key
next i'll give
employee underscore
name
and my data type would be
varchar
i'll
give the size as 25
my third column would be the age column
age would obviously be an integer
then i have
my gender column
i'll use character data type and assign
a value of 1 or size sizeof1
next we have the date of join
and the data type will be date
we have the
department column as well this is going
to be of
varchar and 20 will be the size
next
we have the city column
which is actually the city to which the
employee belongs to and finally we have
the
salary column which will have the
salary for all the employees
okay
now let me select and run this
you can see here we have successfully
created our table
now to check
if our table was created or not you can
use the describe command
i'll write describe employees
you can see the structure of the table
so far
all right now it's time for us to insert
a few records into this employees table
so i'll write
insert
into employees
and i'll
copy paste the records which have
already
written on a notepad so let me show you
so this is my emp notepad and you can
see i have already
put the information for all the
employees so let me just copy this
and
we'll paste it here
all right
let me go to the top and verify if
all the records are fine
all right
so let's run our insert query
okay so you can see here we have
inserted 20 rows of information
and
now let's check
the table information or the records
that are present in our employees table
i'll write select star from employees if
i run it you can see here
i have my employee id the employee name
age gender
we have the city salary and in total we
have
incided 20 records
now
let me run a few sql commands to check
how the structure of our table is
let's say i want to see the distant
cities that are present in our table
so i'll write select distinct city from
employees
if i run this
you see here there are total
eight different
cities present in our employees table so
we have
chicago the shuttle boston we have new
york
miami and detroit as well
now let's say
you want to know the
total number of departments that are
present
so you can use distinct department
if i run this
all right you can see we have seven rows
returned and here are the department
names so we have sales marketing product
tech i t finance and hr
all right
now let me show you
another sql command
now this is to use an aggregate function
so i want to find the
average age of all the employees from
the table
so i can write
select
avg which is the aggregate function for
average
inside that i have passed my
age column from employees if i run this
so the average age of all the employees
in our table is
33.35 now
say you want to find the average age of
employees in each department
so for this you need to use the group by
clause
i'll give a comment here i want to find
the
average age
in each department
so
i'll write select
department
comma
i'll write
average of age
from
employees
group by
department
now if i run this
you can see here
we have our
seven departments
on the left
and on the right you can see the average
age of employees in each of these
departments now you can see here
in the output it says evg of age which
is not readable so i can give an alias
name as
average age
all right
i can bring this down
and if you want you can round the values
also
so you can round the decimal places so
i'll use a round function before the
average function
and
the round function takes two parameters
one is the variable and
the decimal place you want to round it
to
so if i run this
there you go you can see here we have
the
average age of all the employees in each
of these departments
all right
now suppose
you want to find the total salary of all
the employees for each department
so
you can write select
department comma
now i want the total salary so i'll use
the sum function
and i'll
pass my column as salary
from
employees
group by
department
let's run this query
you can see here
in the output we have the different
departments
and on the right you can see the total
salary of all the employees in each of
these departments
now here also you can give an alias name
as
total underscore salary
let's run it again
and you can see the
output here
all right now moving ahead you can also
use the order by clause along with the
group by clause
let's say you want to find the total
number of employees in each city and
group it in the order of employee id so
to do this i can use my select query
i'll write select
count of let's say employee id
and i want to
know the city as well
from
employees
group by
city
and next
you can use the order by clause
i'll write order by
count
of
employee id
and i'll write desc which stands for
descending
if i
run this query
you can see here
on the left you have the count of
employees and on the right you can see
the
city names so in chicago we had the
highest number of employees working that
was four then we had seattle houston
boston austin
and the remaining also had two employees
so in this case we have ordered our
result based on the count of employee id
in descending order so we have the
highest number appearing at the top and
then followed by the lowest okay
now let's explore another example
suppose we want to find the number of
employees that join the company each
year we can use the year function on the
date of joining column then we can count
the employee ids and group the result by
each year
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select
i'm going to extract here from
the date of join column
i'll give an alias as year
next
i'll
count the
employee id
from my table name that is
employees
and
i am going to group it by
year
date of join
i give a semicolon
all right
so let's run this
great you see here in the result we have
the year
that we have extracted from the date of
join column and on the right you can see
the
total number of employees that joined
the company each year so we have in 2005
there was
one employee similarly we have in 2009
there were two employees
if you scroll down you have information
of other years as well
now if you want you can
order this as well based on year or
count
okay
now you can also use the group by to
join two or more tables together
so
to show you this operation let me first
create a sales table
so i'll write create
table
sales
and the sales table will have columns
such as the product id
which is going to be of integer type
then we have the
selling price of the product
now this will be a
float value
then we have the quantity sold for each
of the
products so i'll write
qty
quantity will of integer type
next we have
the state in which the item was sold
and state i'll put it as var car and
give the size as 20.
let's run this so that we'll create our
sales table all right
so we have successfully created our
sales table
next we need to insert a few values to
our sales table so i have already
written the records in a notepad let me
show you
okay so here you can see i have my
sales text file let me just copy these
information
i'll just paste it on
the query editor
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this
insert command
all right so you can see here we have
successfully inserted
nine rows of information
so
let me just
run it through what we have inserted
so the first
column is the product id column then we
have the selling price at which this
product was sold
then we have the quantity that was sold
and in which state it was sold so we
have california texas alaska
then we have
another product
id which is one two three
and these are the states in which
the products are sold
so let me just
confirm with the
select statement i'll write select star
from
sales
where on this you can see we have
successfully created our table
okay
now suppose you want to find the revenue
for both the product ids
one two one and let's say one two three
since we have just two product ids here
so for that you can use the select query
so i'll write select
product id
next
i want to calculate the revenue so
revenue is nothing but
selling price multiplied by the quantity
so i'll use the sum function to find the
total revenue
and inside the sum function i'll use my
selling price column
multiplied by
my quantity column
i'll give this
an alias name as revenue
from
my table name that is sales
finally i'll group it by
product id
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
the two product ids one two one and one
two three and here you can see the
revenue that was generated
from these two products
all right
now let's see
we have to find the total profit that
was made from both the products
one two one and one two three so for
that i'll create another table now this
table will have the cost price of
both the products so let me create the
table first
i'll write create table
let's say the table name is c product
which stands for the cost price of the
products
i'll
give my first column as product id
this will be an integer
and i'll have my second column as
cost price
cost price will have floating type
values
let's run this
so we have successfully created our
product cost table
now let me
insert a few values into the c product
table so i'll write insert into
c underscore
product
i'll give
my values
for one to one
let's see the
cost price was
270 dollars
for each
and next we have my
product as one two three
and let's say the cost price for product
one two three was
250
let's insert these two values okay
next we'll join our sales table and the
product cost table so this will give us
the profit that was generated for each
of the
products
so i'll write select
c dot
product underscore id
comma
i'll write
sum
s dot cell underscore price now here c
and s are alias names
so if i subtract my
cost price from the selling price
that will return the profit that was
generated
i'll multiply this with s dot
quantity
close the bracket
i'll give an alias name as
profit from
sales as s
so here s stands for the sales table
i am going to use
inner join
c underscore
product table
as
the alias name should be c
where
s dot
product underscore id is equal to c dot
product underscore id we are using
product underscore id because
this column is the common column to both
the tables
and finally
i am going to
group it by
c dot product underscore id
all right
so let me tell you what i have done here
so i am selecting the product id
next i am calculating the profit by
subtracting the cost price from the
selling price and i have multiplied
the quantity column
i am using an inner join to connect my
sales and the product cost table
and i am joining on the
column that is product id and i have
grouped it by c dot product id
let's run this
there you go so here you can see for
product id one to one
we made a profit of
eleven hundred dollars
and for product id one two three
we made a profit of
eight hundred and forty dollars so now
that we have learnt group by in detail
let's learn about the having clause in
sql
the having clause in sql operates on
grouped records and returns rows where
aggregate function results matched with
given conditions only
so now having and where clause are kind
of similar but where clause can't be
used with an aggregate function
so here you can see the syntax of having
clause you have the select statement
followed by the column names from the
table name then we have the where
conditions next we have the group by
finally we have having
and at last we have order by column
names so you can see here we have a
question at hand
we want to find the cities where there
are more than two employees
so you can see the employee table that
we had used in
our
group by clause as well
so if you were to find the cities where
there are more than two employees so
this is how your sql query should look
like
so we have
selected
the employee id and we are finding out
the count using the count function
next we have selected the city column
from employees we have grouped it by
city
and then we have user having clause so
we have given our condition having count
of employee id should be greater than
two
so if you see the output we have the
different city names and
these were the cities where the
count of employees was greater than 2
all right so let's go to our mysql
workbench and implement how
having works
so suppose
you want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
thousand dollars
you can use the having clause for this
so let me first run my table which is
employees
if i run this you can see we had
inserted 20 rows of information
and
the last column we had was salary
so the question we have is
we want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
thousand dollars
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write
select
department
comma
i'll use the aggregate function that is
average
salary i'll give an alias name as
evg
underscore salary
from
employees
next we'll use the
group by clause and i want to group it
by each department
and then i'm going to write my
having clause so in having clause i'll
use my condition that is having
average of salary
greater than
seventy five thousand dollars
let's run it
and see the output
there you go
so here you can see
there were total three departments in
the company that is sales finance in hr
where the average salary is greater than
seventy five thousand dollars
okay next
let's see you want to find the cities
where the total salary is greater than
200 000 dollars
so
this will again be a simple
sql query so i'll write select city
comma
i want to find the total salary so i'll
use the sum function
and i'll pass my column as salary
as
i'll give a
alias name as total from
employees
group by
city
and then i am going to use my having
clause
i will pass in my condition as having
sum of salary
greater than
two hundred thousand dollars
all right
so let's run this query
there you go
so
so the different cities are chicago
seattle and houston where the total
salary was greater than two hundred
thousand dollars now suppose you want to
find the departments that have more than
two employees so let's see how to do it
i'll write select
department comma
this time since i want to find the
number of employees i'm going to use the
count function
i'll write count star
as
employee underscore count or emp
underscore count which is my alias name
from
employees
next i'll group it by
department having
i'll give my condition
count star greater than two
let's run this
okay
so you have departments such as sales
product tech and id where
there are more than two employees
okay now you can also use a where clause
along with the having clause in an sql
statement
so suppose i want to find the cities
that have more than two employees apart
from houston
so
i can write my query as select
city comma
count star
as
emp count
from
employees
where
i'll give my condition city
not equal to
houston i'll put it in double quotes
since i don't want to see
the information regarding houston
i'll group it by
city
having
count
of employees greater than 2.
so if i run this query
you see we have information for
chicago and seattle only
and we have excluded the information for
houston
now you may also use aggregate functions
in the having clause that does not
appear in the select clause
so if i want to find the total number of
employees for each department that have
an average salary greater than 75 000
dollars
i can
write it something like this
so select
department
comma
count
star as
emp count
from
employees
group by
department
and in the having clause
i am going to provide the column name
that is not present in the select
expression so i'll write having
average salary
greater than
75000
this is another way to use the having
clause let's run this
all right you can see
we have department sales finance and hr
and you can see the employee count where
the average salary
was greater than 75 000
okay
so let me
run you from the beginning what we did
in our demo so first we created a table
called employee then we inserted 20
records to this table
next we explored a few sql commands like
dixtend then we used average and finally
we started with our
group by clause
followed by
looking at how group by can be used
along with another table and we joined
two tables that was sales and
product cost table to find out the
profit
then you learned how to use the having
clause
so we explored several different
questions and
learnt how to use
having an sql we will learn about joins
in sql
joins are really important when you have
to deal with data that is present on
multiple tables
i'll help you understand the basics of
joins and make you learn the different
types of joints with hands-on
demonstrations on mysql workbench
so let's get started with what are
joints in sql
sql join statement or command is often
used to fetch data present in multiple
tables
sql joins are used to combine rows of
data from two or more tables based on a
common field or column between them now
consider this example where we have two
tables
an orders table and a customers table
now the order table has information
about the order id which is unique here
we have the order date
that is when the order was placed
then we have the shipped date this has
information about the date on which the
order was shipped
then we have the product name which
basically is the names of different
products
we have the
status of delivery whether the product
was delivered or not or whether it was
cancelled
then we have the quantity which means
the number of products that were ordered
and finally we have the price of each
product
similarly
we have another table called customers
and this customer table has information
about the order id
which is the foreign key here
then we have the customer id which is
the primary key for this table
we also have the phone number customer
name and address of the customers
now suppose
you want to find the phone numbers of
customers
who have ordered a laptop now to solve
this problem
we need to join both the tables the
reason being the phone numbers are
present in the customers table as you
can see here
and laptop which is the product name is
present in the orders table which you
can see it here so using a join
statement you can find the phone numbers
of customers who have ordered a laptop
now let's see another problem where you
need to find the customer names who have
ordered a product in the last 30 days
in this case we want the customer name
present in the customers table and the
last 30 days order information which you
can get from the order date column that
is present in the orders table
okay
now let's discuss the different types of
joints one by one so first we have an
inner join
so the sql inner join statement returns
all the rows from multiple tables as
long as the conditions are met
from the diagram a verb you can see that
there are two tables a and b
a is the left table and b is the right
table
the orange portion represents the output
of an inner join
which means an inner join returns the
common records from both the tables
now you can see the syntax here so we
have the select command
and then
we give the list of columns from table a
which you can see here is the left table
followed by the inner join keyword and
then the name of the table
that is b
on
a common key column from both the tables
a and b
now let me take you to the mysql
workbench and show you how inner join
works in reality
so here
i'll type
mysql
you can see i have got
my sequel workbench
8.0 version installed i'll click on it
it will take some time to
open
okay
i'll click on this local instance
and here i'll give my password
okay so this is how an sql editor on
mysql workbench looks like
so first of all
let me go ahead and create a new
database
so i'll write
create
database this is going to be my command
followed by the name of the database
that is going to be sql underscore joins
if i give a semicolon and hit control
enter
this will create a new database you can
see here one row affected
now
you can check whether the database was
created or not using show databases
command
if i run it
here you can see i have
sql joins database
created
now i'll use this database so i'll write
use sql underscore joins
okay
now to understand
inner join
consider that there is a college
and in every college you have different
teams for different sports such as
cricket football basketball and others
so let's create two tables cricket and
football
so i'll write
create
table
and my table name is going to be cricket
next
i am going to
create two columns
in this table the first column is going
to be cricut
id
then
i am going to give
the data type as int and use the auto
increment operator
i am using auto increment because my
cricut id is going to be my primary key
then i am going to give
the name of the students who are part of
the cricket team
and for this i'll use
varchar data type and give the length as
30.
i'll give another comma
and
i'll assign my cricut id as primary key
within brackets i'll give
cricut underscore id
cricket id is nothing but a unique
identifier for each of the players like
you have roll numbers in college
okay
let me just run it
all right so we have successfully
created our cricket table
similarly let me just copy this and i'll
paste it here
i'll create
another table called football
this will have the information of all
the students who are part of the
football team
and instead of cricket i am going to
give this as football id
all right
and
the name column will have the names of
the students
i'll change my primary key to football
id
alright
let me run this ok
so now we have also created our
football table
the next step is to insert a few player
names into both the tables
so i'll write my insert into command
first let's load some data to our cricut
table
so i'll write cricut and
i'll give my name column
followed by
values and here i'll give some names
such as
let's say stuart
give another comma
the next player i'll choose is let's say
michael
similarly i'll add a few more let's say
we have
johnson
the fourth player i'll take is let's say
hidden
and finally we have
let's say fleming
okay now i'll give a semicolon and run
this
okay so let me just check if all the
values were inserted properly for this
i'll use
select star from table that is cricket
if i run it you can see i have created a
table and have successfully inserted
five rows of information
now similarly
let's insert
a few student names
for our football table
so i'll change this to
football
and
obviously there would be students who
will be part of both cricket and
football team
so
i'll keep a few
repeated names let's say stuart
johnson and let's say hayden are
part of both cricket and football team
then we have let's say
langer
and
let's say we have another player in the
football team that is astral
i'll just run it
okay
you can see there are no errors so we
have successfully
inserted values to our football team as
well
let me just recheck it
i'll write select star from
football
all right
so we have five players in the football
team as well
okay
now the question is
suppose you want to find the students
that are part of both the cricket and
football team in this case you can use
an inner join
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select star from
cricket
as i'm using an alias name as c which
stands for cricket
then i am going to write inner join
my next table is going to be football
as f which is an alias name for the
football table
then i am going to use the on
command or operator
and then
i will give the
common
key that is name here so c dot name is
equal to f dot name
so based on this name column from both
the table my inner john operation will
be performed
so let's just run it
there you go so stuart johnson and
hayden are the only three students who
are part of both the teams
all right
now you can also individually select
each of the columns from both the tables
so let's say i write select c dot
cricut underscore id
comma
c dot name
comma
f dot
football underscore id
comma
f dot name
from
i'll write
cricket as c
inner join
football as f
on
c dot
name is equal to
f dot name
now if i run this you see we get the
same output here as well
all right
now let's explore another example to
learn more about inner joins so we have
a database called classic models let me
first
use classic models
i'll run this okay
now let me just show the different
tables that are part of classic tables
all right
so
here you can see there are tables like
customers there's employees office
there's office details
orders payments products and product
lines as well
all right
so
let me use
my select statement to show
what are the columns present in the
products table
okay
so this product table has information
about different
product names you have the product code
now this product code is unique here
we also have the product vendor
a little description about the product
then we have the quantity in stock
buying price and msrp
let's see what we have in
product lines
if i run it
you see here we have the product line
which is the
primary key for this table then we have
the
textual description for each of the
products this is basically
some sort of an advertisement
all right
now suppose you want to find the product
code the product name and the text
description for each of the products you
can join the products and product lines
table
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my select statement and
choose my columns as product code then
we have
product name
and let's say i want the text
description
so i'll write this
column name
okay
then i'll use from
my first table that is
products
inner join
product lines
i can use using
the common key column that is product
line
close the bracket i'll give a semicolon
and if i run it
there you go so you can see the
different product codes
then we have the different product names
and the textual description for each of
the products
so this we did by joining the products
table and the product lines table
all right
now suppose
you want to find the revenue generated
from each product order and the status
of the product to do this task we need
to join three tables that is orders
order details and products so first let
me show you
what are the columns we have in these
three tables we have obviously seen for
the products table now let me show you
for orders and order details table
so i'll write select star from
orders
if i run it you can see it has
information about the order number
the date on which the order was placed
we also have the shipment date we also
have the status column which has
information regarding
whether the order was shipped or
cancelled
then we have some comments column we
also have the customer number who
ordered this particular product
similarly
let's check what we have under order
details
so i'll write select star from
order
details if i run it
you can see it has the order number the
product code quantity of each product we
have the price of each product then we
have the order line number
okay
so using the product
orders and order details let's perform
an inner join
so i'll write
select
o dot
order number
comma
o dot
status
comma
i need the product name which i'll take
from the products table so i'll write p
dot
product name now here o
p are all
alias name for the tables orders
products and i'll use od for order
details
comma
since we want to find the revenue
we actually need to
find the product of quantity ordered
into
price of each product so i'll use a sum
function and inside the sum function
i'll give
quantity
ordered
multiplied by
the price of each item
i'll use an alias as revenue
then i'll use my
from clause
from orders as o
inner join
order
details as i'll use an alias name as od
on
i'll write
o dot
order number
is equal to
od dot
order number
i'll use another inner join and this
time we'll join the products table so
i'll write inner join
products as
p
on
p dot
product
code
is equal to
[Music]
od dot
product code
and finally i'll use the group by clause
and group it by order number
all right
let me run this
okay there's some mistake here we need
to debug this
it says
you have an error in your sql syntax
check the manual all right
okay i think the name of the tables is
actually orders and not order
all right now let's run it
okay there's still some error
it says
classic models dot product doesn't exist
so again the product name is
i mean the table name is products and
not product so let's run it again
all right there you go so we have the
order number the status
the product name and the revenue
this we got it using
inner join from three different tables
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now talking about left joins
the sql left join statement returns all
the rows from the left table and the
matching rows from the right table so if
you see this diagram you can see we have
all the rows from the
left table that is a and only the
matching rows from the right table that
is b so you can see this
overlapped
region
and the syntax
for sql
left join is something like this so you
have the select statement and then you
give the list of columns from table e
which is your left table then you use
the
left join
keyword
followed by the next table that is table
b on the common key column so you write
a dot key is equal to b dot key
okay
now in our classic models database we
have two tables customers and orders so
if you want to find the customer name
and their order id you can use these two
tables so first let me show you the
columns that are present in
customers and orders
i think orders we have already seen let
me first show you
what's there in the customers table
okay so you can see we have the customer
number
the name of the customer then we have
the contact last name the contact first
name
we have the phone number then there's an
address column there are two address
columns actually
we have the city name the state
and we have other
information as well and similarly we
have
our orders table
so i'll write select start from
orders
so i'll write select star from orders
if i run this you can see these are the
information available in the
orders table
okay
so
let's perform a left join
where we want to find the customer name
and their order ids
so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
or let's say first we'll choose the
customer number comma
then i want the customer name so i'll
write c dot customer name
then we have the
order number column which is present in
the orders table
and let's say i also want to see the
status
then i'll give my left table that is
customers
as c
left join
orders as o
on
c dot
customer number equal to
o dot
customer number
let's run it
okay again there is some problem
all right so the table name is customers
let's run it
so there's another mistake here this is
customer number so b is missing cool
let me run it all right so here you can
see we have the information regarding
the customer number
then
the respective customer names we have
the order number and the
status of the shipment so if i scroll
down you'll notice one thing there are a
few rows you can see which have null
values
this means
for customer number 125 and for this
particular customer name there were no
orders
and similarly if i scroll down you will
find a few more null values
you can see here there are two null
values here for
customer number 168 and 169 there were
no orders available
all right
now to check those customers who haven't
placed any orders
you can use the null operator so what
i'll do is here
i'll just continue with this i'll use a
where clause and write where
order
number is
null
now let me run this
okay so here you can see there are
24 customers from the table
that don't have any orders in their
names
okay
now talking about right joins
so sqlridejoin statement returns all the
rows from the
right table and only matching rows from
the left table so here you can see we
have our left table as a and the right
table as b
so the right join will return all the
rows from the right table and only the
matching rows from the left table
now talking about the syntax so here you
can see we have the select statement
followed by the select statement you
will have the list of columns that you
want to choose
from table a
right join table b on the common key
column from both the tables
all right
now to show how right join works i'll be
using two tables that is customers and
employees so let's see
the rows of data that are present in the
customer table first so i'll write
select star from
customers
let's run it so here you have the
customer number the customer name
then we have the phone number the
address of the customers
you also have the country to which the
customer belongs to the postal code
and the credit limit as well similarly
let's see for
the employees table
here i'll change customers to employees
let's run it
okay so we have the employee number the
last name the first name
we have the extension the email id
the job title
and also
reports to here means the manager
okay
so based on these two tables we'll find
the customer name
the phone number of the customer
and the email address of the employee
and join both the tables that is
customers and employees
so let me show you
the command so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
comma
then we have c dot
phone i'll give a space here
next
i want
the employee
number from the employee table so i'll
write e dot
employee number
comma
e dot
email
from
customers as c
right join
employees
as e
on
e dot
my common key column is employee number
here so i'll write e dot
employee number
is equal to
c dot
we have
sales
representatives
employee number
and i'm also going to order it by
the employee number column
okay
so you can see i have
my customer name selected from the
customers table the phone number of the
customer then we have the employee
number and the email address
so let me run it
okay
there's some problem
all right so the table name is customers
actually
let's run it once again
there you go
so you can see here
we have
all the values selected from our right
table which is the employees table you
can see right zone employees which means
your employees table is to the right
and then we have
the customer name and phone numbers of
the customers from the customer table
which is actually your left table
so you have a few
employee numbers such as 1002 this one
zero five six we don't have any customer
name or phone numbers
okay so there's another popular join
which is
very widely used in sql known as self
joins so self joins are used to join a
table to itself
so in our database we have a table
called employees let me show you the
table first
all right
so here you can see we have the employee
number the last name the first name of
the employee we have the email id
and here if you see we have a column
called reports2 now this you can think
of as
the manager column so the way to read is
for example for employee number 1056
the manager is one zero zero two so if
you check for one zero zero two we have
day in murphy
then
if i scroll down
let's see for employee number
1102
yeah for employee number 1102 the
manager is 1056. so here you can see
who is at 1056 you have
mary patterson
similarly if i scroll down let's say
for employee number 1188
we have
the manager as one one
four three now if i check the table at
one one four three we have anthony bow
so
so the employee julie ferelli reports to
anthony bow
all right
now suppose you want to know who is the
reporting manager for each employee so
for that you can use a self join
so let me show you how to join this
employees table
i'll write select
and then i'm going to use a function
called concat
within brackets i'll start with my alias
name that is m dot
then i'll write
last name
i'm going to concat last name
followed by a comma
then i'll have my
first name
i'll close this bracket
and then i am going to give my
alias name lets say manager
comma
next
i am going to concat
the same
last name and first name and this time
i'm going to use a separate alias let's
say
e which stands for employee so i'll
write e dot
last name comma
and within
single quotes
i'll
give my comma and then i'll write e dot
first name
i close this bracket i'll give an alias
as let's say
employee
from
i'll write
employees
as e
inner join
employees
as
m
on
m dot
i'll use my
common key column as employee number so
i'll write
m dot
employee
number
is equal to
e dot
here i am going to use the reports 2
column
and then
i'll
order it by
let's say manager
okay
now let's run this
there you go so you have your two
columns as manager and employee so for
employee louie
bonder
the manager is zerat bonder
similarly if i scroll down
you have there are multiple employees
reporting to this particular manager
similarly we have our manager as
anthony bow and we have
different employees who are reporting to
this particular manager
and so on
all right now moving ahead
now let's see what a full join is
so sql full outer join statement returns
all the rows when there is a match in
either left or right table now you must
remember that mysql workbench does not
support full outer join by default but
there is a way to do it
so
by default this is how the syntax of
full outer join looks like
now this statement will work on other
sql databases like microsoft sql server
but it won't work on mysql workbench
i'll show you the right way of using
full outer join on mysql workbench
so to show full outer join i am going to
first use a left join and then we'll
also use a right join and finally we'll
use a union operator so the union
operator is used to combine the result
set of two or more select statements
so first of all let me write
c dot
customer name so for this example i'm
using the customer table and the order
table
comma
o dot
order number
so i just want to know the customer name
and the
order number related to the customer
from
i have
customers
as
c
left join
i'll write
orders as o
on
c dot
customer number
is equal to
o dot
customer number
let me just copy this
and after this i am going to use my
union operator
so union operator is used to merge
results from
two or more
tables
so basically this performs a vertical
join
and next i am going to use my right join
operation
so here instead of left join i'll write
right
restore looks fine
let me just run it
there you go so we have successfully
run our
full outer join operation you can see we
have the different customer names
and
the order that each customer had placed
all right here we're going to jump into
some common questions you might see on
numpy arrays and pandas data frames and
the python along with some excel tabloo
and sql
let's start with our first question what
is the difference between data mining
and data profiling
it's real important to note that data
mining is a process of finding relevant
information which has not been found
before it is a way in which raw data is
turned into valuable information
you can think of this as anything from
the cells
stats and from their sql server all the
way to web scraping and census bureau
information where the heck do you mind
it from where do you get all this data
and information
then we look at data profiling is
usually done to assess a data set for
its uniqueness consistency and logic
it cannot identify incorrect or
inaccurate data values
so if somebody has a statistical
analysis on one side and they're doing
their you might in the wrong data to
then program your data set up so you got
to be aware of that when you're talking
about data mining you need to look at
the integrity of what you're bringing in
where it's coming from data profiling is
looking at it and saying hey how is this
going to work what's the logic what's
the consistency is it related to what
i'm working with
find the term data wrangling and data
analytics
data wrangling is a process of cleaning
structuring and enriching the raw data
into a desired usable format for better
decision making
and you can see a nice chart here with
our discover it we structure the data
how we want it we clean it up get rid of
all those null values we enrich it so we
might take and reformat some of the
settings instead of having five
different terms for height of somebody
you know in american english or whatever
clean some of that up and we might do a
calculation and bring some of them
together
and validate i was just talking about
that the last one need to validate your
data make sure you have a solid data
source
and then of course it goes into the
analysis
very important to notice here in data
wrangling eighty percent of data
analytics is usually in this whole part
of wrangling the data getting it to fit
correctly and don't confuse that with
data cooking which is actually when
you're going into neural networks
cooking the data so it's all between 0
and 1 values
what are common problems that data
analysts encounter during analysis
handling duplicate and missing values
collecting the meaningful right data the
right time
making data secure and dealing with
compliance issues
handling data purging and storage
problems again we're talking about data
wrangling here eighty percent of most
jobs are unwrangling that data and
getting it in the right format making
sure it's good data to use
number four
what are the various steps involved in
any analytics project
understand the problem we might spend 80
percent doing wrangling but you better
be ready to understand the problem
because if you can't you're going to
spend all your time in the wrong
direction this is probably
the most important part of the process
everything after it falls in and then
you can come back to it
two data collection
data cleaning number three four data
exploration analysis and five interpret
the results
number five is a close second for being
the most important if you can't
interpret what you bring to the table to
your clients you're in trouble
so when this question comes up you
probably want to focus on those two
noting that the rest of it does eighty
percent of the work is in two three and
four well one and five are the most
important parts
which technical tools have you used for
analysis and presentation purposes
being a data analyst you are expected to
have knowledge of the below tools for
analysis and presentation purposes
there's a wide variety out there
sql server mysql
you have your excel your spss which is
the ibm platform tableau
python
you have all these different tools in
here now certainly a lot of jobs are
going to be narrowed in on just a few of
these tools like you're not going to
have a microsoft sql server mysql server
but you better understand how to do
basic sql polls and also understanding
excel and how the different formats for
column and how to get those set up
number six what are the best practices
for data cleaning this is really
important to remember to go through this
in detail these always come up because
80 percent of most data analysis
in cleaning the data
make a data cleaning plan by
understanding where the common errors
take place and keep communications open
identify and remove duplicates before
working with the data this will lead to
an effective data analysis process focus
on the accuracy of the data maintain the
value types of data provide mandatory
constraints and set cross-field
validation
standardize the data at the point of
entry so that is less chaotic and you
will be able to ensure that all the
information is standardized leading to
fewer errors on entry
number seven how can you handle missing
values in a data set
list wise deletion in list wise deletion
method entire record is excluded from
analysis if any single value is missing
sometimes we're talking about records
remember this could be a single line in
a database so if you have
your sql comes back and you have 15
different columns
every one of those has a missing value
you might just drop it just to make it
easy because you already have enough
data to do the processing average
imputation
use the average value of the responses
from the other participants to fill in
the missing value this is really useful
and they'll ask you why these are useful
i guarantee it
if you have a whole group of data that's
collected and it doesn't have that
information in it at that point you
might average it in there regression
substitution you can use multiple
regression analysis to estimate a
missing value that kind of goes with the
average imputation input regression
model means you're just going to get
you're going to actually generate a
prediction as to what you think that
value should be for those people based
on the ones you do have multiple
imputation so we talk about multiple
inputs it creates plausible values based
on the correlations for the missing data
and then average the simulated data sets
by incorporating random errors in your
predictions
what do you understand by the term
normal distribution and the second you
hear the word normal distribution should
be thinking a bell curve like we see
here normal distribution is a type of
continuous probability distribution that
is symmetric about the mean and in the
graph normal distribution will appear as
a bell curve the mean median and mode
are equal that's a quick way to know if
you have normal distribution is you can
compute mean median and mode all of them
are located at the center of the
distribution 68 of the data lies within
one standard deviation of the mean
95 of the data falls within two standard
deviations of the mean
99.7 of the data lies within three
standard deviations of the mean
what is time series analysis
time series analysis is a statistical
method that deals with ordered sequence
of values of a variable of equally
spaced time intervals time series data
on a coveted 19 cases and you can see
we're looking at by days so our space is
of days and each day goes by if we take
and graph it you can see a time series
graph always looks really nice we have
like two different in this case we have
what the united states
going over there i'd have to look at the
other set up in there they picked a
couple different countries uh and it is
it's time sensitive you know with the
next result is based on what the last
one was kova is an excellent example of
this
anytime you do any word analytics where
you're figuring out what someone's
saying what they said before makes a
huge difference is what they're going to
say next another form of time series
analysis
10 how is joining different from
blending in tableau
so now we're going to jump into the
tableau package
data joining data joining can only be
done when the data comes from the same
source
combining two tables from the same
database or two or more worksheets from
the same excel file all the combined
tables or sheets contains common set of
dimensions and measures
data blending data blending is used when
the data is from two or more different
sources combining the oracle table with
the sql server or two sheets from excel
or combining excel sheet and oracle
table in data blending each data source
contains its own set of dimensions and
measures
how is overfitting different from
underfitting
always a good one overfitting probably
the biggest danger in data analytics
today is overfitting model trains from
the data too well using the training set
the performance drops significantly over
the test set happens when the model
learns the noise and random fluctuations
in the training data set in detail
and again the performance drops way
below what the test set has
the model neither trains a data well nor
can generalize to new data performs
poorly both on train and the test set
happens when there is less data to build
and an accurate model and also when we
try to build a linear model with a
non-linear data
in microsoft excel a numeric value can
be treated as a text value if it
proceeds with an apostrophe
definitely not an exclamation
if you're used to programming in python
you'll look for that hash code and not
an amber sign
and we can see here if you enter the
value 10 into a fill but you put the
apostrophe in front of it it will read
that as a text not as a number
what is the difference between count
count a count blank and count if in
excel
we can see here when we run in just
count
d1 through
d23
we get 19 and you'll notice that there
is 19
numbers coming down here and so it
doesn't count the cost of each which is
a top bracket it doesn't count the blank
spaces either with the straight count
when you do a count a
you'll get the answer is 20. so now when
you do count a counts all of them even
the title cost of each
when you do count blank we'll get three
why there's three blank fields
and finally the count if if we do
countif of
1 to e 23 is greater than 10
there's 11 values in there basic
counting of whatever's in your column
pretty solid on the table there
explain how vlookup works in excel
vlookup is used when you need to find
things in a table or a range by row
the syntax has four different parts to
it
we have our lookup value that's a value
you want to look up we have our table
array
the range where the lookup value is
located
column index number the column number
and range that contains the return value
and the range lookup specify true if you
want an approximate match or false if
you want an exact match of the return
value
so here we see v lookup f3
a2 to c8 2 0 for prints now they don't
show the f3 f3 is the actual um cell
that prince is in that's what we're
looking at is f3 so there's your prints
he pulls in from f3
a2 to c8 is the the data we're looking
into and then number two is a column in
that data so in this case we're looking
for
age and we count name as 1 ages 2.
keep in mind this is excel versus a lot
of your python and programming languages
where you start at zero in excel we
always look at the cells as one two
three so two represents the age
zero
is uh false for having an exact match up
versus one
we don't actually need to worry about
that too much in this zero or one would
work with this example and you can see
with the angela lookup again her name
would be in the f column number four
that's what the f4 stands for is where
they pulled angela from
and then you have a1 to c8 and then
we're looking at
number three so number three is height
name being one h2 and then height three
and you'll see here pulls in her height
5.8
so we're going to run jump over to sql
how do you subset or filter data in sql
to subset or filter data in sql we use
where and having clause
you can see we have a nice table on the
left where we have the title the
director the year the duration
we want to filter the table for movies
that were directed by brad bird
why just because we want to know who
what brad bird did
so we're going to do select star you
should know that the star refers to all
in this case we're what are we going to
return we're going to return all title
directory year and duration that's what
we mean by all from movies movies being
our table
where director equals brad bird and you
can see he comes back and he did the
incredible and ratatouille
to subset or filter data sql we can also
use the where and having clause so we're
going to take a closer look at the
different ways we can filter here filter
the table for directors whose movies
have an average duration greater than
115 minutes
so there's a lot of really cool things
into this sql query and these sql
queries can get pretty crazy
select director sum duration as total
duration average duration as average
duration from movies group by director
having average duration greater than
115.
uh so again what are we going to return
we're going to return whatever we put in
our select which in this case is
director we're going to have total
duration and that's going to be the sum
of the duration
we're going to have the average duration
average underscore duration which is
going to be the average duration on
there
and then we course go ahead and group by
director and we want to make sure we
group them by anyone that has an having
an average duration greater than 115.
these sql queries are so important
i don't know how many times you the sql
comes up and there's so many different
other languages not just mysql and not
microsoft sql in addition to that where
the sql language comes in especially
with hadoop in other areas so you really
should know your basic sql
doesn't hurt to get that little um
cheat sheet and glance over and double
check some of the different features in
sql
what is the difference between where and
having clause in sql
where where clause works on row data in
where clause the filter occurs before
any groupings are made aggregate
functions cannot be used
so the syntax is select
your columns from table
where what the condition is
having clause works on aggregated data
having is used to filter values from a
group aggregate functions can be used
in the syntax is select column names
from table where the condition is
grouped by
having a condition ordered by column
names
what is the correct syntax for reshape
function in numpy so we're going to jump
to the numpy array program
and what you come up with is you have in
this case would be numpy.reshape a lot
of times you do an import numpy as np
reshape and then your array and the new
shape
and you can see here as we as the actual
example comes in the reshape is a and
we're going to reshape it in two comma
five setups and you can see the print
out in there that prints in two rows
with five values in each one
what are the different ways to create a
data frame in pandas
well we can do it by initializing a list
so you can port your pandas as pd very
common
data equals tom 30 jerry20 angela35
we'll go ahead and create the data frame
and we'll say
pd.dataframe is the data columns equals
name and age so you can designate your
columns you can also it is a index in
there you should always remember that
the index
in this case maybe you want the index
instead of one two to be um the date
they signed up or who knows you know
whatever and you can see right there it
just generates a nice pandas data frame
with tom
jerry and angela
another way you can initialize a data
frame is from dictionary you can see
here we have a dictionary where the date
equals name tom jerry angela mary ages
20 21 1918 and if we do a dfpd
dot data frame on the data you'll get a
nice the same kind of setup you get your
name age tom jerry angela and mary
write the python code to create an
employee's data frame from the
emp.csv file and display the head in
summary of it
to create a data frame in python you
need to import the pandas library and
use the read csv function to load the
csv file
and here you can see we have import
pandas as pd
employees or the data frame employees
equals
pd.read csv
and then you have your path to that csv
file
there's a number of settings in the read
csv where you can tell it how many rows
are the top index
you can set the columns in there
you can have skip rows there's all kinds
of things you can also go in there and
double check with your read csv but the
most basic one is just to read a basic
csv
how will you select the department and
age columns from an employee's data
frame
so we have import pandas as pd you can
see we have created our data
we will go ahead and create our
employees pd data frame on the left
and then on the right to select
department and age from the data frame
we just do employees and you put the
brackets around it now if you're just
doing one column you could do just
department but if you're doing multiple
columns you've got to have those in a
second set of brackets it's got to be
a reference with a list within the
reference
what is the criteria to say whether a
developed data model is good or not
a good model should be intuitive
insightful and self-explanatory
follow the old saying kiss keep it
simple
the model develops should be able to
easily consumed by the clients for
actionable and profitable results
so if they can't read it what good is it
a good model should easily adapt to
changes according to business
requirements
we live in quite a dynamic world
nowadays so it's pretty self-evident and
if the data gets updated the model
should be able to scale accordingly to
the new data so you have a nice data
pipeline going where when something when
you get new data coming in you don't
have to go and rewrite the whole code
what is the significance of exploratory
data analysis
exploratory data analysis is an
important step in any data analysis
process
exploratory data analysis eda helps to
understand the data better it helps you
obtain confidence in your data to a
point where you're ready to engage a
machine learning algorithm it allows you
to refine your selection of feature
variables that will be used later for
model building
you can discover hidden trends and
insights from the data
how do you treat outliers in a data set
an outlier is a data point that is
distant from other similar points they
may be due to variability in the
measurement or may indicate experimental
errors
one you can drop the outlier records
pretty straightforward you can cap your
outliers data
so it doesn't go past a certain value
you can assign it a new value
you can also try a new transformation to
see if those outliers come in if you
transform it slightly differently
explain descriptive predictive and
prescriptive analytics
descriptive provides insights into the
past to answer what has happened
uses data aggregation and data mining
techniques examples an ice cream company
can analyze how much ice cream was sold
which flavors were sold
and whether more or less ice cream was
sold than before
predictive understands a future to the
answer what could happen uses
statistical models and forecasting
techniques
example predicts the sale of ice creams
during the summer spring and rainy days
so this is always interesting because
you have your descriptive which comes in
and your businesses are always looking
to know what happened hey did we have
good sales last quarter
what are we expecting next quarter in
sales and we have a huge jump when we do
uh prescriptive
suggest various courses of action to
answer what should you do uses
optimization and simulation algorithms
to advise possible outcomes
example lower prices to increase
sell of ice creams produce more or less
quantities of certain flavor of ice
cream and we can certainly uh today's
world with the coveted virus because we
had that in our earlier graph you could
see that as a descriptive what's
happened how many people have been
infected how many people have died in an
area predictive where do we predict that
to go
do we see it going to get worse is it
going to get better what do we predict
that we're going to need in hospital
beds and
prescriptive what can we change in our
setup to have a better outcome
maybe if we did more social distancing
if we tracked the virus
how do these different things directly
affect the end and can we create a
better ending by changing some
underlying criteria
what are the different types of sampling
techniques used by data analysis
sampling is a statistical method to
select a subset of data from an entire
data set
population to estimate the
characteristics of the whole population
one we can do a simple random sampling
so we can just pick out 500 random
people in the united states to sample
them they call it a population in
regular data we also call that a
population
just because that's where it came from
was mainly from doing census
systematic sampling
cluster sampling
stratified sampling
and judgment or propositive sampling
and we have our systematic sampling
that's where you're doing like uh
using 1 5
10 15 20 use a very systematic approach
for pulling samples
from the setup
cluster sampling
that's where we look at it we say hey
some of these things just naturally
group together if you were talking about
population which is the really a nice
way of looking at this cluster sampling
would be maybe by a zip code we're going
to do everybody's zip code and just
naturally cluster it that way
stratified sampling would be more uh
looking for shared things the group has
like income
so if you're studying something on
poverty you might look at their
naturally group people
based on income to begin with and then
study those individuals in the income to
find out
what kind of traits they have
and then judgmental
that is
where the
researcher very carefully selects each
member of their own group
so it's very much
based on their personal knowledge
jumping on the 26 what are the different
types of hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is a procedure used
by statisticians and scientists to
accept or reject statistical hypothesis
we start with a hypothesis testing we
have null hypothesis and alternative
hypothesis
on the null hypothesis it states that
there is no relation between the
predictor and the outcome variables in
the population it is denoted by h naught
example there is no association between
patients
bmi and diabetes
alternative hypothesis it states there
is some relation between the predictor
and outcome variables in the population
it is denoted by h1 example there could
be an association between patients bmi
and diabetes
and that's the body mass index if you
didn't catch the bmi and you're not
medical
describe univariate bivariate and
multivariate analysis
a univariate analysis it is the simplest
form of data analysis where the data
being analyzed contains only one
variable an example of studying the
heights of players in the nba
because it's so simple it can be
described using central tendencies
dispersion
quartiles bar charts histograms pie
charts frequency distribution tables
the bivariate analysis it involves
analysis of two variables to find causes
relationships and correlations between
the variables
example analyzing sale of ice creams
based on the temperature outside
bivariate analysis can be explained
using correlation coefficients linear
regression logistic regression scatter
plots and box plots
in multivariate analysis it involves
analysis of three or more variables to
understand the relationship of each
variable with the other variables
example analyzing revenue based on
expenditure so if we have our tv ads we
have our newspaper ads or social media
ads and a revenue we can now compare all
those together
the multivert analysis can be performed
using multiple regression factor
analysis classification and regression
trees cluster analysis principle
component analysis clustering bar chart
dual axis chart
what function would you use to get the
current date and time in excel
in excel you can use the today and now
function to get the current date and
time
you can see down here with the two
examples where just equals today or
equals now
using the sumifs function in excel find
the total quantity sold by sales
representatives whose names start with a
and the cost of each item they have sold
is greater than 10.
and you can see here on the left we have
our actual table
and then we want to go ahead and sum ifs
so we want the e2 through e20
b2 through b20
greater than 10. and this basically is
just saying hey we're going to take
everything in the
e column
and we're going to sum it up but only
those objects where the d column is
greater than 10 that's what that means
there
is the below query correct if not how
will you rectify it
select customer id year order date as
order year from order
where order year is greater than or
equal to 2016.
and hopefully you caught it right there
uh it's in the devils in the details we
can't not use the alias name while
filtering data using the where clause
so the correct format is all the same
except for where it says where
the year
order date is greater than or equal to
versus using the order year which we
assign under the select setup
how are union intersect and accept
used in sql
the union operator is used to combine
the results of two or more select
statements
and you can see here we have select star
from region one and we're going to make
a union with select star from region two
and it basically takes both these sql
tables and combines them to form a full
new table on there so that's your union
as we bring everything together
we look at the intersect operator
returns the common records that are the
result of the two or more select
statements
so you can see here we select star from
region 1 intersect select star from
region 2
and we come up with only those records
that are shared that have the same data
in them
and hopefully you jumped ahead to the
accept the accept operator returns the
uncommon records that are the result of
two or more select statements so these
are the red two records or the records
that are not shared between the two
databases
using the product price table write an
sql query to find the record with the
fourth highest market price
so here we have a little bit of a brain
teaser
they're always fun
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to go ahead and i'm going to
if you look at the
script on the left
we really want the fourth one down so
we're going to select the top four from
product price
but we're going to order it by market
price
descending sp order by market price
ascending
so we do is we take the top
four
of the market price ascending
and that's going to give us the four
greatest values
and then we're going to reverse that
order and do descending
and we're going to take the top one of
that which is going to give us the
lowest value which would be the fourth
greatest one in the list
from the product price table find the
total and average market price for each
currency where the average market price
is greater than 100 and currency is in
the inr or the aud
so
inr or aud india rupal or australia
dollar
you can see over here the sql query if
you had trouble putting this together
you might actually do some of it in
reverse
and you can see right here where the
average market price is greater than 50.
remember we use having not where at the
end because it's part of the group so
group by currency because we want those
two currencies and we want the currency
india the inr or the aud
and
as you keep going backwards we're
actually going to be selecting the
currency the sum of the market price
as total price and the average market
price as average price so there's our
select it's going to come from the
product price which is just our table
over there and then we have where our
currency is in
and like i said you can put together
however you want but hopefully you got
to the end there
so this question will test your
knowledge in tableau exploring the
different features of tableau and
creating a suitable graph to solve a
business problem
and of course tableau is very visual in
its use so it's very hard to test it
without actually just getting your hands
on
and if you can't visualize some of this
and how to do it then you should go back
and refresh yourself
using the sample superstore data set
create a view to analyze the cells
profits and quantities sold across
different subcategories of items present
under each category
so the first step is to go ahead and
load the sample superstore data set
so make sure you know how to load the
sample the superstore data set that's
underneath either the connect button in
the upper left
or the
tableau icon up there and be able to
pull in the data set
and then once you've done that you just
drag the category and subcategory on
rows and salaries onto columns
it will result in a horizontal bar chart
so in this one we're just going to drag
profit onto color and quantity onto
label sort the sales axes in descending
order of sum and cells within each sub
category
and if you're at home doing this you'll
see that chairs under furniture category
had the highest sales and profit while
tables had the lowest profit for office
supplies subcategory binders made the
highest profit even though storage had
the highest sales under technology
category copiers made the highest profit
though it was the least amount of sales
let's work to create a dual axis chart
in tableau to present cells and profits
across different years using sample
superstore data set
load the orders sheet from the sample
superstore data set
drag the ordered data field from the
dimensions onto columns and convert it
into continuous month
drag cells onto rows and profits to the
right corner of the view until you see a
light green rectangle
one of those things if you haven't done
this hands on you don't know what you're
doing you're going to run into a bike so
you're gonna be just kind of dropping it
and wondering what happened synchronize
the right axes by right clicking on the
profit axis
and then let's finalize it by going
under the marks card change some cells
to bar and some profit to line and
adjust the size
and then we have a nice display that we
can either print out or save and send
off to the
shareholders
let's go and do one more tableau
design a view in tableau to show
statewide cells and profits using the
sample superstore data set
in here you go ahead and drag the
country field onto the view section and
expand it to see the states
drag the states field onto size and
profit onto color
increase the size of the bubbles add a
border and a halo color states like
washington california new york have the
highest sales and profits while texas
pennsylvania and ohio
have a good amount of sales but the
least amount of profits
we'll go ahead and skip back to python
numpy suppose there is an array
number equals np or numpy if you're
using numpy depending on how you set it
up dot array and we just have one to
nine broken up into three groups
extract the value eight using 2d
indexing so you can see on the left we
have our import numpy as in p number
equals our np array
if we print the number we have one two
three four five six seven eight nine
since the value eight is present in the
second row and first column we use the
same index position and pass it to the
array and you just have number two comma
one and you get eight and remember we're
in python so you start at zero not one
like you do in excel
always gets me if i'm working between
excel and python where i just kind of
flip and usually see excel that messes
up because i do a lot more programming
suppose there's an array that has values
0 1
all the way up to 9.
how will you display the following
values from the array 1 three five seven
nine
uh so first of all we go ahead and
create the array
np dot a range of 10 which goes from
zero to nine because there's ten numbers
in it but we don't include the ten
we print it out the first thing you want
to do is what's going on here with one
three five seven nine
well if we divide by two there's going
to be a remainder equal to one
and then from python remember that if
you use the percentage sign you get the
remainder on there so the remainder is
one
and then you have the your numpy array
and then we just want to do
a logical statement of all values that
have a remainder of one and that
generates our nice
one three five seven nine
there are two arrays a and b step back
theory is a and b
horizontally
boy these horizontal vertical questions
will get you every time
and in numpy we go ahead and we've
created two different arrays over here a
and b uh the first one is your
concatenate np dot concatenate
a and b on axes equal one
that is the same as h stack
and in the back end they're still
identical they run the same that's all h
stack is a concatenate axis equals one
how can you add a column to a pandas
data frame
suppose there is an imp data frame that
has information about few employees
let's add address column to that data
frame you can see in the left we have
our basic data frame you should know
your data frames very well basically
looks like an excel spreadsheet as you
come over here it's really simple you
just do df of address equals the address
once you've assigned values to the
address
using the below given data create a
pivot table to find the total sales made
by each cells represented for each item
display the cells as a percentage of the
grand total
so we're back in tableau select the
entire table range click on insert tab
and choose pivot table
select the table range and the worksheet
where you want to place the pivot table
it will return a pivot table where you
can analyze your data
drag the cell total on the values and
sales rep and item onto row labels it
will give the sum of the sales made by
each representative for each item they
have sold
and finally right click on sum of cell
total and expand show values
as to select percentage of grand total
real important just to understand what a
pivot table is we're just piving it from
rows and columns and switching this
direction on there
and finally we have our final pivot
table and you can see the values rolls
and sum of total sale
so we're going to go ahead and take a
product table this is off of an sql so
we can do some sql here
and we're going to use the product and
sales order detail table find the
products that have total units sold
greater than 1.5 million and here's our
sales order detail table so we have a
product table and a sales order detail
table two separate tables in the
database
and we're going to do is put together
the sql query we want to select
pp name
sum sod unit price as cells
and then we have our p p dot product id
from production product as pp interjoin
cells dot sales order detail as sod on
pp product id equals sod.productid
group by pp.name comma pp.product id
having a sum of sod.unitprice greater
than
the 150 million there that's a mouthful
and again these sql queries they start
looking really crazy until you just
break them apart and do them step by
step
and what we're looking for is the
inner join
and how did you do the group by that's
really when they know how to do this
inner join this comes up so much in sql
how do you pull in the id from one chart
and the information from another chart
and the sum totals on that chart
how do you write a stored procedure in
sql let's create a storage procedure to
find the sum
the squares are the first n natural
numbers so here we have our formula n
times n plus one times two n plus one
over six
and you can see from the command prompt
or the setup you have depending on what
your login is the command is create
procedure square sum1
declare our variable at in of integer as
begin then we're going to declare the
sum of integer
set sum equals n times n plus 1 plus 2
times n plus 1
over 6.
and then of course we can go ahead and
print those out print first cast
amber sign in or our variable
as a variable character 20
natural numbers print the sum of the
square is cast
the
at sum as variable character 40 end then
we do the output display the sum of the
square for first four natural numbers we
have execute square sum one and then
we're going to put in four and you can
see here where it brings up the first
four natural numbers sum of square is
thirty
write a store procedure to find the
total even number between two user given
numbers
a couple of things to note here first we
go ahead and create our procedure you
have your two different variables the n1
in two
and we go ahead and begin we're going to
declare our variable count as an integer
we're going to set count equal to 0 and
then we have while n is less than n2
we're going to begin and if n1
remainder 2 equals 0 so we're going to
divide it by 2 even number begin we're
going to set the count equal to count
plus 1 we're going to print even number
plus cast in as a variable
character 10 for printing count is plus
cast variable count as variable
character 10 end else print odd number
plus cast variable number one is
variable character 10 and then we go
ahead and set the
increment our variable one up one so
that goes from n one all the way to n2
and i'll print the total number of even
numbers
and you can see here we went ahead and
executed it we're going to count the
even numbers between 30 and 45 and you
see it goes all the way down to eight
what is the difference between tree maps
and heat maps in tableau
now if you've worked in python other
programmings you should automatically
know what a heat map is
but a tree map are used to display data
in nested rectangles you use dimensions
to define the structure of the tree map
and measure to define the size or color
of individual rectangles
tree maps are relatively simple data
visualization that can provide insight
in a visually attractive format
and again you can see the squares over
here this is our tree map over here with
the
each
block also has this information inside
of its different blocks
a heat map helps to visualize measures
against dimensions with the help of
colors and size to compare one or more
dimensions and up to two measures
the layout is similar to a text table
with variations in values encoded as
colors in heat map you can quickly see a
wide array of information
and in this one
you can see they use the colors to
denote one thing and the size of the
little square to denote something else
a lot of times you can even graph this
into a three-dimensional graph with
other data
so it pops out but again a heat map is
the color and the size
using the sample super stored data set
display the top five and bottom five
customers based on their profit so you
start by dragging the customer name
field onto rows and profit on columns
right click on the customer name column
to create a set
give a name to the set and select top
tab to choose top 5 customers by some
profit
similarly create a set for the bottom
five customers by some profit
select both the sets right click to
create a combined set give a name to the
set and choose all members in both sets
and then you can drag top and bottom
customer sets onto the filters and
profit field onto color to get the
desired results
as we get down to the end of our list
we're going to try to keep you
on your toes we're going to skip back to
numpy how to print four random integers
between 1 and 15 using numpy to generate
random numbers using numpy we use the
random random integer function and you
see here we did the import numpy as in p
random arrangement equals np dot random
dot random integer
1 through 15
of 4.
from the below data frame can jump again
on you now we're into pandas
how will you find the unique values for
each column and subset the data for age
less than 35 and height greater than six
to find the unique values and the number
of unique elements use the unique and
the in unique function
you see here we just did df heights
we're selecting just the height column
and we want to look for the unique
that returns an array
where in unique if we do that on the
height or the age will return just the
number of unique values
and then we can do a subset the data for
ages less than 35 and height greater
than 6.
so if we look over here we have a new df
remember this is going to be taking
slices of our original data frame it
doesn't actually change the data frame
so our new df equals the data frame or
df the data frame where age is less than
35 and
the height is greater than 6.
and in case you're not using tableau
which has a lot of its own
different mapping programs in there make
sure you understand how to use the
basics of matplot library
plot a sine graph using numpy and
matplot library in python and the way we
did this is we went ahead and generate
an x we know our y equals np dot sine of
x if you print out x you'll see a whole
value here our map plot library pi plot
as plt
if you are working in jupiter notebook
make sure you understand the map plot
library inline that little percentage
sign metplat library in line that prints
it on the page in the jupiter notebook
the newer version of jupiter notebook or
jupiter labs automatically does that for
you but i usually put it in there just
in case i end up on an older version
if you print y you can see here we have
our different y values and our different
x
you simply put in plt.plot xy and do a
plot show
and before we go let's get one more in
we're going to do a pandas using the
below pandas data frame find the company
with the highest average cells derive
the summary statistics for the cells
column and transpose these statistics
that's a mouthful and just like any of
these computer problems break it apart
so first of all we're looking for the
highest average sales so group the
company
column and use the mean function to find
the average sales
and you see here by company equals
df.group by
company once we've done that using the
describe function we can now go ahead
and look at the summary of statistics on
here use the describe function to find
the summary
so by company those are groups we're
just going to describe them and you
could actually bundle those together if
you wanted and just do them all in one
line
so here we go by company.describe
you can see we have a nice breakout
always good to remember
whether you're using any of the packages
whether it's
or
pandas
in python or even r or some other
package being able to quick look and
describe your data is very important
and then we go ahead and just do a basic
apply a transpose function over the
describe method to transpose the
statistics
all we've done here is flip the index
with the column names but if you're
following the numbers a lot of times
it's easier to follow across one line or
maybe you want to average out the
counter it's all kinds of different
reasons to do that
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on data analyst full course i
hope it was informative and interesting
if you have any questions related to the
topics that were covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you